[Music]
hi guys welcome to part one of the
digital marketing full course video by
simply learn in this video we'll be
covering everything you need to know
about digital marketing we'll do this
with the help of our instructor rob
sanders so let's start with an
introduction to digital marketing a
digital marketing course video and some
of the best digital marketing tools
we'll also have a look at what is seo an
seo tutorial 7 tips and tricks for seo
how to perform keyword research how to
rank number one on google and google tag
manager greetings everyone this is rob
sanders and today we're going to talk
about what is digital marketing so
thanks for joining us here at simply
learn and let's get started let's start
talking about why digital marketing is
important so let's start there on the
why so we're just a fly on the wall and
we're in an office environment we're
looking at two friends having a
conversation about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digital marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know what traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure that's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking about 2 000 people maybe just to
be generous well digital marketing we're
promoting an event we can promote it to
a whole lot of people depending on the
platform so 2000 is nothing when you're
targeting an audience on facebook or
google search traditional marketing
non-versatile
and with digital marketing very
versatile so again going back to our
flyer printing an eight and a half by
eleven okay that's it you know with with
digital marketing you're running display
banners you have 468 by 60 200 by 200
250 by 250 300 by 300 i mean the list
goes on on the types of different
display sizes not to mention text ads
not to mention video or multimedia uh so
there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
go to analytics you can look at
real-time reporting okay so we could see
real-time results okay traditional
marketing can be very costly i mean if
you're not only doing postcards and
printing postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
where with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient i mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to target when you want to target where
you want to target what you want to
target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend so
that to me is one of the biggest
advantages to digital marketing not only
do you get real-time results but you can
control costs and then obviously
optimize based on the amount of cost
you're spending based on those real-time
results with traditional marketing it's
difficult to reach a target audience you
know with digital marketing it's easy to
reach a target audience i mean you know
i don't wanna bash traditional marketing
too much i mean if you're gonna put a tv
ad in place you know you're gonna do it
on a tv show that tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing is just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so
we know because of the benefits in
digital marketing you can promote your
campaign on different platforms okay so
all those benefits we mentioned about
instant real-time results cost
efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located in
the us market google tends more has a
large market share so you want your
pages on your website to be found and
clicked on organically and so that means
that somebody types in a keyword you
want that relevant page to show up first
on google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people
specifically in the us but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's seo okay and here's an
example so you type in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're gonna get
to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example
if you want to be found for keyword you
don't have to worry about organic if
you're willing to pay for it you just
bid on that keyword and voila you have
the opportunity to appear number one in
the search results at the top of the
page for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay google
if it's google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping
well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem's such a popular choice for a
lot of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live in say the southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out if you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase the product and if you purchase
it you're gonna get 30 off and you can
put the coupon code right in there with
a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that web page and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so
that affiliate could likely be a
merchant him or himself and they can
basically be a good partner of yours by
publishing your product or service on
their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you can
see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchase for example or
joined you could pay off that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know i would say it's
fairly new i mean if i think about it
we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006. so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile
and desktop and you obviously have the
opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you could post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an
infographic or it could be an image okay
there are lots of ways to create content
these days especially in digital
marketing and the great thing about
content marketing is you're writing
content for a targeted audience so
if you're trying a targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're gonna post on there so
it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube
you can see this video here about
digital marketing certified associate
well hey you don't need to always write
the content you can produce the content
in the form of a video and post it on
youtube this is a form of content
marketing so that's content marketing
and then let's talk about mobile
marketing so content marketing again
different types but if we go now to
mobile marketing you can kind of segue
from content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on
mobile phone it's not desktop so
mobile marketing is really a strategy on
its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically sms or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension
so there's lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to know we want we
know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're going to talk about first so
we're going to talk about different
stages of the customer life cycle okay
and the first one is the awareness stage
so we need to get our customers aware of
what we're selling or what we're
promoting okay so the awareness stage is
really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
going to become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does a customer need it
and what solution does it provide okay
those are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do i really need this is it gonna help
me in my life okay and who who is
selling this i mean who is this brand i
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on google
for example basically we can be right at
the top of the search results and so
somebody can actually see when they do a
search because we know millions of
people you search on a daily basis you
could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you can focus
on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you can focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on in the awareness stage okay so
content marketing you must create a high
quality content that people are
searching for without content it's hard
to get found and so to me this is you
know where the blog comes in seo take
that content get it optimized okay sem
if we're not ranking organically we can
make sure we're at the top of the paid
search results or the the search results
for a particular keyword we want to be
found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training like simply
learn does you know linkedin is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you could still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention-grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your posts from all the other
posts that are in somebody's facebook
newsfeed okay so you really have to work
hard to really convince somebody to get
their consideration towards your product
or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer those questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really get them to take that next
step okay with display you can even do
remarketing so if somebody's been to
your site because they're aware of your
product they're curious you can cookie
them and remarket to them via display so
display to me is a good a good channel
to use here okay so you have email
mobile display you know sem these are
all you know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's site okay so blogging
works both ways it's ways of of showing
yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you
and now we're on to the purchase stage
so the questions we want to really make
sure we address here are how are my
prices compared to my competitors and is
my brand more credible than others okay
so they're considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do
your due diligence
and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or trip
advisor or whatever it is you're trying
to sell they're going to be able to see
those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring
negativity okay just those small things
that can get people to change their mind
now with the purchase stage according to
e-consultancy 83 of the online audience
require encouragement to complete a
purchase encouragement what does that
mean well it could mean providing a
promo giving them that extra incentive
you know if you don't offer promo
consider it especially on the email and
the example we looked at earlier sending
in an email means that if the promo is
going to end at midnight send that email
out and tell people they have until
midnight and if they purchase today
you'll even increase it to 20 percent
and email's a good channel for that
mobile can reach a lot of people through
sms okay social media reaching people
instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives pro prospects an
offer to help them make that purchase so
you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to
not push a product on your customer but
think about how you can complement that
purchases that purchasers or customers
product and then how to improve the
customer buying experience
so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know it's me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media you know you can
thank your community for supporting you
on this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throw in an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase is a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know
promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you could even post a poll on
facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your product and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you can say hey
look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look i
really like this product and they're
giving me 10
i'm going to go ahead and purchase from
these guys again so give those discounts
to those active customers or on the
affiliate network give referral
opportunities to your customers so if
it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're gonna write to
give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance uh what they purchased so
hey you just purchased this product
thank you very much did you know you
could do this this and this with it and
so that's the idea of a post-purchase
stage is to maximize these channels to
be able to answer those essential
questions about what else could they
purchase you know do they like how do i
get these people to become loyal
customers okay so with the first
purchase stage if a customer has bought
a pair of sports shoes for example
running shoes you can recommend cross
product sale a cross sale it could be a
pair of shorts or a water bottle or an
accessory with an exclusive discount so
that's another example what you can do
on the post purchase stage so in today's
world everywhere you go it's all about
digital so today this lecture is going
to be about all the different marketing
channels available
piece them together kind of put together
a little digital marketing course for
you so
first off before we get started we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing and really digital marketing
covers a lot of areas it's very broad
and really what it refers to just
marketing
that
a company does a person does an
individual a group an organization and
they do it in the form of an electronic
device or with the aid of the internet
that's really what digital marketing is
it's just having something digitally not
something tangible like a billboard or
newspaper or tv and with that there are
lots of places where you can apply
digital marketing and so
electronic devices we think of mobile
devices and so you could certainly use
mobile as a form of digital marketing or
to help you with your marketing efforts
digitally okay you can create apps you
can run advertising on mobile you can
communicate with different people your
target audience
via different devices like whatsapp and
messaging okay uh there's also search
engines search engines is where a lot of
people get their information from at
least start to do their research to get
information you got social media lots of
different social media platforms all the
way from you know tweeting to blogging
to
social sharing to social content okay so
a lot of of platforms under the bucket
social media you also have traditional
forms of digital marketing like email
you can use different email platforms to
send out emails so
lots of different ways to communicate
your product your service your message
to a large number of people that are
really targeted to your efforts how is
digital marketing useful well we know
provides different metrics why do we
know it provides different metrics
because it's all digital okay so anytime
you send out an email or post something
on facebook you're going to get data
back when you get data back you could
take that data to determine how well
that post or that email performed and if
it didn't perform up to expectation you
can make changes to improve performance
that's called optimization okay so
that's the great thing about digital
marketing it's useful in that we get
data in some cases instantaneously and
we're able to make changes in order to
optimize that campaign we can also
you know provide personalized user
experience so meaning if we know who our
target audience is on say twitter or
linkedin or facebook we can really cater
our messaging to that group probably
most importantly is that digital
marketing compared to traditional forms
of marketing allow us to really reach
a global audience very easily very
easily at a very low cost that's the key
so if i want to target people in india
or nepal or pakistan i can certainly do
that and i can do that with the snap of
a campaign and i get data back and based
on the data i can tailor that experience
even better really just allows us to
really hone in on a particular audience
anywhere in the world very quickly so
these are just three of the main reasons
why digital marketing is useful some
other experiences or uses for digital
marketing again it provides a
cost-effective alternative to
traditional marketing so
you know for those that are familiar
with purchasing advertising on say tv a
radio you have to pick a spot you have
to pick a program and then pick a time
slot associated with that program so
somebody's watching a program and and
that program tends to draw on a specific
target audience then you want to show
your ad around the time when that
program is slotted to air on tv
because you know you're likely going to
reach your audience however to purchase
that time slot could be competitive and
could be very costly where there are
forms of of advertising and paying for
advertising digitally and those forms
are cost per click or cost per
impression and so using a cost per click
or cost compression model allows you to
really go head-to-head in kind of an
auction style format where you can
control how much you pay and potentially
get that prime spot in front of your
target audience so it really does become
cost effective and it allows you to make
small investments to get a really
substantial return on roi so let's just
say your cost per click is only 10 cents
but you're selling a product for 10
well all you need is one click and one
sale to generate a very substantial
return on investment and so knowing that
you get metrics back on a campaign you
could slowly or quickly optimize that
campaign towards a very positive roi and
then another use for digital marketing
just enables targeting users based on
their actions and preferences so again
we can really hone in on who we want to
target it really depends on the platform
but if you take google ads for example
and you want to target the display
network well we know we have
demographics we know we have topics we
know we have interest we know we have
retarget audiences in segment audiences
we have age we have gender so you have a
lot of options available to choose from
to really hone in
on who you want to target and we talk
about remarketing is another form of
digital marketing so you can set up a
marketing campaign so if somebody comes
to your website and does not purchase
the product or service that you're
offering you could take action on that
behavior so i can retarget a group of
people who didn't purchase that's
retargeting or you could do it via
remarketing and
basically that's the beauty of digital
marketing allows you to really target
users based on their actions some other
uses for digital marketing it helps
build brand awareness and reputation of
your business so when we say brand
awareness if you're just launching a
company and nobody knows who you are if
we use google ads as our preferred
method of digital marketing and
establishing campaigns we can choose
that display network that display
network on google ads reaches a large
amount of people so you can really get
your name out there and really target
your attended audience and allow that
targeted intended audience to really
understand who you are because they're
going to see your ad in the form of a
banner or in the form of a video or in
the form of text and so that's the
beauty of digital marketing you can
really reach a lot of people and a lot
of people who might be interested in
your product or service and then digital
marketing provides a platform for you to
be interactive with your audience
helping you stay relevant and
competitive and the best example i can
give here is youtube and so youtube's a
really it's a search engine for videos
but it's a video sharing platform and so
if i upload a video then i can entice
people to comment on that video or like
the video or share the video and i can
really interact with that audience by
responding to their comments or
you know putting together a playlist or
giving them more videos okay so i can
really interact with my audience and i
could do that on multiple platforms not
just youtube and video i can blog and
and interact based on somebody's
comments i can have a website and have
live chat and interact with my audience
so there's lots of different ways to
interact with an audience and that's
what digital marketing provides so i
already mentioned a few examples based
on the uses of digital marketing i
mentioned google's display network i
mentioned youtube and blogging and
social media platforms like facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today we're going to start with
search engine optimization and so search
engine optimization
as you probably know from the name
involves search engine and it involves
really making your site relevant in the
eyes of that search engine so if you're
in the united states you know that
google has a large market share meaning
a lot of people use google on a daily
basis so we want to make sure we do
everything we can to optimize our site
in order to make our site relevant for
those coveted keywords now why do we
want to make ourselves relevant for
those coveted keywords that we want to
be found for on search well because a
lot of people use search and when a lot
of people you search and you're found
for those keyword queries then it's
going to increase the flow of organic
traffic to your website so the higher
you rank in theory the more traffic
you're going to get and so when we
talked about optimization okay how do we
optimize our site in order to be
relevant in the eyes of google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page seo you have
off-page seo on-page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off-page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of google so that's off page seo so
seo is always going to be two prong what
you do on your website and what you do
off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is dot com or dot org is relevant in the
eyes of google and so let's take a look
at on page seo first so like i mentioned
it involves optimizing your website and
when we say optimizing your website
there's a lot of things you can do on
your website to make it relevant in the
eyes of google and we can look at the
content okay we can look at the source
code and so there are a lot of different
components to be looked at here so you
have the header tag you have the meta
description you have the alt tag you
have how fast your page loads you have
internal linking you have a site map you
have a lots of different things going on
here and so for me
one of the first things you should do
when you create a page on your website
is to make sure the title tag is unique
and includes those key words so if we
look here at this example the title tag
is important because that's what shows
up in search results here you can see
the title tag on google is up to 65
characters so you always want to include
that keyword in the title tag then you
have your url and then you have what you
call a meta description so that's
underneath the url underneath the title
tag and again this is in search results
so organic search results somebody types
in a keyword you want to be found and
you want your title tag to stick out and
you want your meta description to
specifically describe what it is you're
offering okay so again if somebody's
looking for
stock imagery then you want to make sure
that you know that person who's looking
for stock imagery can come to your
website and they can in this case search
for millions of royalty free stock
images photos videos and music and so
you want your description to really get
that person to click on your listing an
organic search that's the whole point so
that's the point of a title tag and a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called site links
and site links are just other are links
to pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
google so if google wants to offer up
site links underneath your title tag
meta description they will add them and
it's based really on the amount of
content you have and that goes with site
search so you can see also their site
search there underneath the meta
description all of that is contingent
upon your website do you have a lot of
content and if you have a lot of
relevant content then google will
naturally add in site links underneath
your organic listing to links to other
pages on your site so that's on page seo
and now we're going to look at off page
seo okay so off page seo involves using
promotional methods beyond just
optimizing your site for example
optimizing your title tag amount
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do
some link building we need to get our
name out there on other websites okay so
we need to be able to establish some
external links or backlinks from high
quality relevant sites to our site and
it may not just necessarily have to be a
link because google recognizes linkless
backlinks so just having a reference on
a high quality site may be good enough
to get you in the eyes of google to
become more relevant okay so that's off
page seo in definition so really what we
want to do is we want to establish a way
to get links from other websites to our
own or references on other websites to
our website we want to build those links
to help us gain in ranking so there's
lots of ways to do that you have social
media again you have social content
sites like reddit medium quora you have
blogging okay there's lots of ways to
establish yourself out there on the
internet you just need to make sure
they're quality sites and you need to
make sure they're relevant and so when
you do get a link on an external site
pointing back to yours you want to make
sure it's a follow so you want to make
sure that google knows to follow that
link from that site to yours so if
you're out there establishing content on
a third-party website or another website
and they're going to link back to you
just make sure that it's a follow do
follow not a nofollow okay and i'm gonna
show you an example of what that looks
like here so if you're not sure what the
difference is here i'm on backlinko.com
and
really a no follow versus they do follow
is simply in the href so
in the href if you don't have anything
in there other than the link then
the search engines are going to follow
that link from that external site to
yours and
if you have a no follow in that link
then the search engines are going to
ignore the link so you're not going to
pick up the backlink or external link to
your site and that's simply that site
just adding the rel equals nofollow okay
so if you see that in the link pointing
to your site from that external site
then that means you're not going to get
credit for that backlink so you always
want to shoot for
a do follow link because that means
you're going to get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow searching and crawlers to follow
the link and if they can follow it
you're going to get what they call link
juice and that's going to establish some
reputation to your domain a nofollow
link basically doesn't allow the search
engines to follow that link so
it doesn't pass on the link juice now
again search engines like google are
smart enough to pick up the association
between
a website that talks about your website
and your website so meaning if you don't
have a link and you don't have a if you
have a nofollow link on that site don't
fret because you know google has come a
long way they're not necessarily focused
on links though it does help so for
example if you are on a very prominent
site and there's no link then you still
may get credit because google does
recognize linkless backlinks and that's
what they call a linkless backlink it's
just having a reference on that site but
you always want to try and get that
follow not the do not follow okay so
here you can see an example of off page
seo okay like tripadvisor would be a
good example a link that redirects from
tripadvisor to
you know the oprah magazine as an
example so the oprah magazine is going
to get a
back link from tripadvisor to the site
so if google crawls tripadvisor then
they're going to be able to see this
link and if it's a follow link they're
going to give the oprah magazine that
domain credit from tripadvisor so for
seo because there's a two-pronged
approach involved you have on-page and
off-page a lot of tools here a lot of
tools so let's take a look at some of
these tools we're gonna look at google
keyword planner we're gonna look at moz
ahrefs look at some tools that will help
you with both on-page and off-page seo
so let's start with google's keyword
planner so why are we using google's
keyword planner because we want to find
keywords okay so we can't do on-page seo
we can't optimize our title tag and meta
description without a good keyword that
we want to be found for so what we want
to do is we want to go into google ads
now that's a pay-per-click platform okay
so if you want to be found via paid
search you're going to use google ads
but from an organic search perspective
we can use google's keyword planner so
we need a google ads account we have a
google ads account then all we need to
do is go to tools then we need to go to
keyword planner and the keyword planner
is a good tool because it allows us to
find those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're going to do so for example
we're going to find you know use the
keyword mail delivery if we have a
business that delivers mails to people
what keywords do we want to optimize for
so we're going to be in google ads we're
going to go to tools we're going to go
to keyword planner we're going to
discover new keywords and we're simply
just going to type in a keyword so we're
going to click get results and google's
keyword planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we chose was mail delivery and they're
telling us that on average over the last
12 months there's 22
200 search queries on average over the
last 12 months okay so i could see if i
click hover over the graph here i'm
going to be able to see
the average over 12 months okay so here
i can see the average over 12 months
from july to june 2019 so here what do i
want to do i want to look for trends
because here i can see the averages go
up and down a little bit but 22 200 is
the average over 12 months and then
google's keyword planner also
tells me how competitive that keyword is
so
if it's highly competitive but it's got
a lot of search volume it could be a
keyword i may want to cover it but the
beauty of the keyword planner is that
they also give you other keywords to
look at okay so mail delivery service
that's 49 500 okay so here you got some
other ones best food delivery service 9
900. again some of these are very
competitive but some of them aren't and
so you want to be able to
do your due diligence do some analysis
and figure out
what keywords work best for you that
aren't going to be competitive but at
the same time give you some search
volume so if you do rank for that
keyword you should expect x amount of
clicks on that keyword based on the
volume so that's google's keyword
planner alternatively you can use a tool
like moz.com so if i log into moz they
have a tool called keyword explorer and
so here i can just type in that same
keyword mail delivery
targeting the united states in english
and moz is going to give me some
information on the keyword so here
they're going to give me a range in
terms of the monthly volume and they're
going to give me a difficulty score so
they're going to tell me how difficult
this keyword is so out of a score of 100
it's 53 and they're going to tell me
what my expected click-through rate
could be if i'm ranking for that keyword
more importantly they're going to
give me some other keyword suggestions
just like google's keyword planner so
here i can see prepared mail delivery
mail delivery service mail delivery
companies so there are a lot of
different suggestions of keywords that i
can choose from and if we scroll down we
could see basically some mansions we
could see the analysis who's ranking for
these keywords so we can really get some
insight as to who's ranking how much
volume how difficult it is what my
estimates could be if i'm ranking et
cetera so a lot of information built
into moz's keyword explorer tool so
maz's keyword explorer tool could be a
good option for you if you don't have
access to google ads and google's
keyword planner so if you're working on
seo for a website and you curious is
about
what the off-page seo situation looks
like well you can use a tool like ahrefs
it's free tool you can go here if you're
working on a specific domain and you're
focused on off page you could simply
type in that domain here and then you
can check the backlinks for that domain
okay so i'm going to go ahead and type
in my my domain and now i'm going to get
a sense of what my backlink profile is
for my domain so here i can see the
number of backlinks the total backlinks
and notice 85 of them are do follow
links so google is able to recognize
those links and then i could see
referring domains so i have 124
different domains pointing to my website
and so here i can get a snapshot of the
top 100 backlinks pointing to my website
and so this just gives me a snapshot of
what's going on with my off page seo
performance again it's a free tool
it's good to use because it gives you an
idea of what your off-page seo situation
looks like okay another tool you could
use is pingdom okay you can set up a
free trial here it's good for 14 days
and it allows you to
you know look at page speed it allows
you to monitor the site itself in terms
of you know visitors maintenance etc so
you can use pingdom as well
however it's only a 14-day free trial
but it does give you some good insights
into seo now page load time is one of
those on-page seo factors and so if
you're doing on-page seo for domain you
certainly want to go into google
analytics and you want to measure the
page load performance of the pages on
your website and so here if i go to
google analytics and then i go to
behavior and i go to site speed and i go
to speed suggestions here i can see the
pages how many pages i've received over
a period of time and then the average
page load time now if you see the
average page load time is slow
and in my opinion anything over two to
three seconds is going to be slow you
need to be able to
take action and so the great thing about
google analytics the page load time
reporting is it actually gives you some
suggestions so page speed suggestions so
all you need to do is click on the link
here in this case this particular link
or url on my website it has seven
suggestions if i click on that then page
speed insights is gonna open up and
what's gonna happen is google analytics
slash page speed insights is gonna
analyze this page and give me some
feedback on how the page is performing
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well and so here i can see if i analyze
this page i can see
some of the opportunities to improve the
page load time on desktop and again on
mobile here so here you can see a lot of
the opportunities and a lot of the
issues i have that i can address now if
you're going to manage seo for a website
then you're going to need an seo
platform so again moz is a good example
because we showed you the keyword
explorer but they also have many other
tools available built right into the
platform for example rankings okay you
can get crawl information so when the
bots crawl aside what kind of errors are
coming up here i can get some page
optimization so i can choose a keyword
and
i can choose a page and moz is going to
be able to give me feedback to see what
more i could do to improve my on-page
seo performance okay we mentioned
keyword explorer in terms of looking for
keywords okay you also have something
called link explorer as well so if i go
back and choose link explorer from my
list here then i'm going to go to a link
explorer and i can type in any domain
again just like on the h wraps except
mods goes a little bit deeper here okay
so they're telling me how many linking
domains and what my keywords are ranking
okay and then i have some other reports
that i can leverage for off-page seo i
can look at spam scores for certain
websites that are linking to me because
you can disavow yourself from us being
associated with those sites here you got
a link intersect tool so you can compare
one domain against another
to what links are pointing to that other
website so a lot of different
reports and tools available to you for
off-page seo under moz's link explorer
so moz has a lot of different tools
available and again my recommendation if
you don't use moz there's sem rush
there's bright edge there's a lot of seo
platforms out there to use but if you're
going to focus on seo you are going to
need
an seo platform now if you have any more
questions on seo you feel free to go to
simply learn's youtube account you'll be
able to find a video there for seo
tutorial for beginners you know take a
look at the video it goes really in
depth about everything we just covered
about on page and off page seo so take a
look at the video
and if you have any comments about
everything we covered with seo feel free
to comment underneath this video here
and we'll be sure to respond accordingly
especially if you have any tips and
tricks that you do for seo so let's move
from search engine optimization to
content marketing and so content
marketing is a form of marketing that
involves
simulating interest in a brand's
products or services by creating and
sharing online material so we talk about
online material that can come in many
forms or assets say some examples are
blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
ebooks all of this is content generated
it's just in different forms and so you
want to be able to take any one of these
forms of content and be able to
distribute that in some form or fashion
okay so for example blog can be part of
your
website a video could be something you
upload to youtube an infographic could
be something you actually share on
linkedin so all these other assets could
be integrated throughout they could be
shared or used on your website okay for
people to grab and share and use and
comment on okay so that's what content
marketing is you need to be able to
push out content so that people have a
better understanding of your product or
service the process of content marketing
is you really want to decide what goal
you want to achieve with your content
marketing campaign you want to define
your buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so what are you creating who's it
for and then you want to run content on
it to determine the best type of content
that can be used and when we talk about
content audits we're talking about you
know content that's already been posted
are people sharing it are people
downloading or people viewing it and so
you want to be able to understand over
time what people are reacting to so that
you can reuse or continue to use that
content that seems to resonate with your
target audience so you want to choose an
appropriate content management system so
if it's a blog you want to use wordpress
maybe so you want to start brainstorming
for ideas for new content ideas so in my
opinion maybe put together a content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to create and then you want to be able
to publish and manage your content so
some top popular tools used for content
marketing you have buffer you have
buzzsumo followerwonk hootsuite so let's
go ahead and take a look at an example
of a content marketing management system
and
we're gonna use wordpress and so if we
go into wordpress here on the backend
we're logging a login and so the reason
why we use wordpress is because we can
post blogs so
in wordpress if i go to post here i'm
going to be able to see all the
different posts that have been posted
over a period of time and the great
thing about wordpress is you can
optimize it for seo so if i go in here
and look at this recent blog post that
has been posted i can go ahead and edit
it and when i edit it okay i'm going to
be able to
look at this blog post in a visual
format and i can also look at it in html
form so notice i the great thing about
wordpress is i can use imagery i can
insert videos i can insert infographics
i can attach a white paper case study to
it and then again we have something
called yoast seo plugin so we've
installed a plugin here so that'll help
us
with optimizing that particular blog
post for that particular keyword we're
trying to target and so here you can see
our focus keyword is remarketing and
retargeting okay so we have that in the
title tag okay we also want to make sure
it's in the meta description and so here
we have an internal link we have it in
the introduction okay we have it you
know spread throughout the content so
yoast does a good job of allowing us to
make sure we're integrating that keyword
into our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience in
this case with a blog post we can ride
up to you know 500 to 3 000 keywords and
the whole point is we're trying to
introduce our audience to a particular
topic that resonates with our product or
service and so that's the great thing
about blogging that's the great thing
about wordpress is that you know very
easy to use uh you can integrate it with
seo
you obviously have commenting you have
different plugins that you can add in
there uh very easy to edit and so a lot
you can do here with wordpress and
blogging so another example of content
marketing is video so with video you
have the ability to upload this video to
popular video sites like youtube or
video and you can optimize
that particular video with title tags
and and hashtags and descriptions and
you could see the interaction here so
you can see how many views how many
likes shares the ability to share the
ability people for saving it and there's
just a lot of interactivity when you
have video you can also use video as i
mentioned on your blogging platform if
it's wordpress you can also use video
and social media platforms like twitter
linkedin and facebook so video is a very
popular form of content marketing lots
of good video tools out there to create
a video a high quality video is what you
want to put your product and service in
the best forefront okay so that people
can react they can share they can
comment they can follow they can like
okay so that's what you want to do is
think about video because video is very
versatile and powerful in terms of
getting your message out there so let's
move from content marketing to social
media marketing and social media
marketing really involves creating
content if it's that blog if it's that
video that you created for content
marketing and really using different
platforms to increase your visibility
whether that be traffic whether it be
engagement whether it be brand awareness
or any other marketing goals that you
have that's what social media is good
for because social media will take that
content take what you're trying to get
out there and really allow you to hone
your marketing goals against that okay
so if it's facebook and you got some
videos that you want to post up there
okay what's your goal is your goal to
then post the video to get traffic to
your website or to build brand awareness
or to just get people to react by
sharing or liking and so that's what
social media is good for it's really
good for taking content and really
distributing it to your target audience
okay so
uh sharing content allows you to you
know generate user generated content or
it allows you to create interactive
content and again you can use
infographics or you can apply content
with imagery or post videos or do things
that are interactive like polling and
contest so a lot of flexibility in terms
of the content that you could share on
social media and so you want to
establish a process for social media
marketing so this is the digital
marketing course of it so you want to be
able to have a process and you want to
be able to set up goals that you want to
achieve with your social media campaign
because just posting content for content
sake is really not going to generate
anything for you so you want to set up
those goals ahead of time then you want
to understand what content would be best
suited for your target audience so if
our goal is to generate brand awareness
then
maybe
an infographic is what we want to do
okay maybe that's the best choice of
asset for our target audience based on
the platform with social media we also
want to research what the competition is
and find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on facebook
you can always go to your competitors
website and you can always see
you know what they're posting and what
kind of reaction engagement they're
getting for a particular post so it
doesn't help before you go live to do
some due diligence about your
competition you can also conduct a
social media audit again what we mean by
audio just like on the content side we
want to be able to see what's worked and
what's not worked in the past and with
digital marketing recall you can get
instant metrics back so if you posted
something last year and you're thinking
about posting it again you probably want
to do an audit to see
over the past year what posts have
worked and have not worked for you then
you want to pick and choose the social
media channels or platforms and to find
a strategy for each of them because if
you have a video
then the video may work on say youtube
or instagram but may not necessarily
work for linkedin and twitter and so you
want to be able to pick and choose the
asset the strategy and align it with the
appropriate platform then you want to
take inspiration from case studies and
other famous brands so again continue to
learn i mean that's the beauty of social
media marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well are
out on social media so take a look at
some other companies that inspire you or
some other companies in your industry or
even again your competitors and see what
they're doing and what they're posting
and what kind of engagement they're
getting so you should always you know be
able to seek out what others are doing
on social and to me this is important
create a social media content calendar
and this isn't necessarily
the very end of the process this goes
back to the beginning of the process so
when you're establishing goals and
you're establishing what kind of type of
content you want to use that should all
be part of a social media content
calendar and i'm going to show you an
example of one here shortly and then
again you want to be able to
test evaluate and adjust your strategy
because again you're getting metrics and
if you post a video on facebook and it's
taking off then meaning in terms of
likes and shares you probably want to
consider maybe doing another one that
complements that so here's a broad
example of a content calendar again it's
in a spreadsheet again by no means
there's one size fits all but just to
give you an idea if we're blogging what
we want to do is we want to pick our
target audience maybe that be country or
particular demographic and you want to
come up with some topics ahead of time
here and you want to maybe put the
status up there of you know it's just a
draft or an idea when it actually does
go live you want to turn it on live you
want to pick your date add some comments
okay create your content and you know
what's good about a content calendar is
you can also work in seo so you can
assign keywords and then you could add
those keywords to moz for ranking uh you
can create your title and meta
description then you can carry that
content forward and choose a particular
social media platform to post to so
that's the beauty of a social or excuse
me a content calendar is it allows you
to think about things up front and then
prepare the content accordingly so you
can optimize it for organic search and
post it on social media for off page seo
and for social media marketing and so
you just want to get organized ahead of
time using a spreadsheet in this case
google sheets to lay out the topics
ahead of time so you can write the
content for your intended audience that
to me is the way to go now remember
there's lots of different forms of
content that you can use with social
media marketing here we have video
so you can see this video can be posted
on youtube or linkedin or wherever and
the whole point is you want to be able
to measure engagement here you can see
this is just an image it's just a file
and this has been posted on facebook so
here we can see many likes and comments
and then shares and so you want to be
able to leverage different forms and
different assets across social media to
see actually what works and what doesn't
work and again look at what other
companies have done whether they be
competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there are lots of
tools available okay you got buffer
hootsuite sprinkler post planner later
sprout social i mean the list of social
media marketing tools is endless and
just like seo you will need a platform
to work with so with seo we showed you
moz as the seo platform with social
we're going to show you sprout social
because with sprout social if you have a
content calendar if you have a lot of
different assets you want to be able to
organize those assets and content across
multiple channels and the great thing
about using a social media calendar is
yes you can publish and organize
your post accordingly you also have most
social media platform tools have
listening so you can listen in on
keywords and audiences different brands
and industries and conversations that
are being had about a specific topic
okay and again most social media
platforms if not all
have reporting and so this is important
because you can actually see
you know what how your post or different
assets are performing in terms of
engagement and so to me that's important
if you're going to focus on social media
as a platform as a channel you want to
have a social media platform tool that
will help you organize your content
publish it accordingly listen in and and
get that report to help you figure out
what's engaging and what's not engaging
again so that you can you know react to
the content that you're using and
sharing so that's sprout social as an
example but you will need a social media
platform now the other benefit to
social media is in some cases you can
actually pay to have your post out there
and so for example on facebook we could
set up a paid campaign to target our
intended audience and so
with facebook facebook owns instagram so
you have the ability to really put your
content out in front of your target
audience on facebook and instagram and
so
what you need to do is go to facebook
ads manager and simply just create an
account or campaign um you want to be
able to create a campaign and by
creating a campaign that means you're
going to have to go
through a particular process here so
if we first we want to do is choose our
objective okay so you always want to
have an objective for your campaign so
is it going to be brand awareness is it
going to be to drive you know traffic
is it going to be to drive conversions
so you want to choose a goal or
objective if you're advertising really
on any platform then you want to be able
to choose your audience so who are we
trying to target so with facebook you
know you can target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do single image or video you can
do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile news feed
facebook in-stream video
you got instagram feed you got even
messenger so you have a lot of options
available to you on where your ad or
video is going to be shown and then you
can support that with a headline
description and
you can send that traffic back to your
website you can even test call to action
buttons okay so you can
pan your ad with a call to action button
and so you can do a lot here this is
just facebook you can really do a lot of
specific targeting now with facebook
advertising it's a cost per click model
so anytime somebody does click on that
ad you're going to pay but it allows you
to really
get your content out there in front of
your intended audience if you're not
doing it organically meaning you're not
posting on facebook on a regular basis
or maybe you want to supplement those
organic posts then
doing this is a good way to really get
your brand out there if it's awareness
if it's to drive traffic or to convert
facebook is a good option linkedin
twitter all these social media platforms
offer that up that option up to do paid
advertising now if you want more
information about social media we have a
great video on youtube already how to
start social media marketing it really
goes into the details about organic
social and what i just covered with paid
social specifically on facebook so take
a look at that video and again if i
missed anything on the social media side
feel free to comment or add in your best
practice whether that be part of the
process or a different platform that you
use for social media okay let's switch
to our next digital marketing channel
and search engine marketing so search
engine marketing is an advertising model
that is good for driving traffic to your
site because you're paying each time
someone clicks on your advertisement now
how is that an equal trade well because
you can advertise on channels like or
search engines like google or bing or
adroll which has a a big network that
includes google you can actually pay
your way to the top of search engine
rankings and so if you're at the top for
paid search and somebody searches
something like uh shoes or something to
that effect your ad can appear at the
very top even above local search even
above organic search and so the
visibility is there it's a good way for
you to then
get that traffic that
that you you covet for certain keywords
and because you're getting traffic or
have the potential to get traffic you're
going to pay each time somebody clicks
on these ads so
you have multiple choices on the type of
asset you want to use including text
image video etc so
there's more to it than just google bing
ad role i mean you have linkedin you
have twitter you have facebook you have
lots of different ways to advertise and
get your ad in a more prominent position
you just have to pay for it and i just
showed you that under social media
marketing facebook you can create an ad
have your ad targeting your audience and
in return you're going to pay facebook
works the same way for most of these
networks okay so when you actually set
up a campaign like anything you do when
you set up a campaign you want to
determine the goal you want to achieve
for the campaign you want to do that up
front especially when you're talking
about pain per click if you're paying
per click then you definitely want to
make sure you determine what your goals
are so you can measure them accordingly
then you want to choose in this case a
relevant list of keywords you could do
it for your brand meaning you could
choose your own brand keywords you could
choose keywords related to what your
brand is trying to offer whether that be
a service or product and
once you choose a relevant list of
keywords you can finalize those keywords
and then bid on them so
once you start bidding on them then what
you're going to do is align those
keywords with a headline so it's all
done within the framework of any
platform you're advertising on really
the key here that i want to really
emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you need
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and launch the
campaign and start paying google or bing
or whomever
it is you're advertising with you want
to be able to measure those goals so
that's really the important part here
because
regardless of where you advertise you're
going to be able to monitor campaign
results and so with google you can even
import conversions into the campaign so
for example if i go to google ads for
example
if i go to tools okay you can see i'm
running campaigns what am i trying to
accomplish with these campaigns well in
this case i'm trying to get donations
people click on donations so i can go to
tools click conversions and then i can
see what conversions are added to my
account and that way i can measure my
campaigns against these conversions okay
if i don't see a conversion error i can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case google analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns
with your conversions and then just as
important you want to be able to
optimize your campaign because if it's
not performing if you're running a
campaign you're running up costs and
you're not getting conversions you're
probably not going to be continuing to
run those campaigns so you want to
optimize your campaign and retarget
potential customers so retargeting is
always a good option retargeting is
targeting someone who that went to your
website and basically
acted in a certain way meaning they went
to a certain page or abandoned the card
or actually purchased or downloaded
something okay you define what action
you want that audience to take in order
to retarget to them okay so the whole
point is you can configure your
retargeting campaign based on certain
behavior on your website and the whole
point there retargeting is you're
pulling people back to your website so
in addition to optimizing you know
search campaigns you can one of the
benefits of search engine marketing is
you can run retargeting campaigns so
here's an example of an ad okay so here
you could see
it's a good ad in the sense that
it's using everything available to it so
for example here i could see three
headlines so google in this example
allows you to add in three headlines so
here you can see simply learn official
site get certified get ahead then you
can see simplylearn.com
so they're taking advantage of three
headlines and then here you can see two
description lines and so each
description line you can have up to 90
characters and so you want to be able to
take advantage of what google gives you
the more information you can add the
better well here you can see some other
types of ads here you can see a banner
ad for slack okay here you can see
betterment.com running an ad okay so
this looks like an ad that is on youtube
so because you can see
after a few seconds you can skip the ad
okay so here's a video ad here's an
image ad here's a text ad so depending
on what platform you advertise on you
have an option on what type of asset you
want to use you know the one thing i
like about facebook is they offer up a
multitude of options in terms of assets
so you can run a single image ad you can
run a carousel meaning you get a
multiple images you can run a video you
can run a combination video image you
can obviously run text okay with a
thumbnail so you have a lot of options
in terms of the type of ad you can run
so before we move into our next channel
let me just show you an example of you
know how an ad actually looks on a
particular website so here you can see
i'm on buzzfeednews.com
okay here you can see
uh volkswagen golf is running an
advertisement in spanish on this
particular site so
they're either using google or some
other platform and having that platform
if it's google post their ad on this
particular site so here you can see it's
a banner ad and if we're in google ads
and you're setting up a text ad let me
just run through you with the text that
it looks like remember you want to
always take advantage of what's offered
to you because especially text ads you
have very few characters and with very
few characters it's hard to get your
message across so with google you have
your final url which is where people are
going to go to after they click on your
ad but you have one not one not two but
three headlines that you can take
advantage of so we're talking about help
and child hunger help today you know you
can always add in visit our website for
more info i mean you want to take
advantage of what's available to you now
again here you can see in this example
i'm only allotted 30 characters and so
if you go over then your ads not going
to get approved so you really have to be
cognizant of the character counts and
getting your point across because
writing text ads is not the easiest
thing to do when you're limited to
characters now with google you have what
they call display path so after the
domain you can add in a couple of
keywords in there and then you have
description line one and description
line two so again take advantage of
what's available if you're not sure what
copy to write grab some from the website
and paste it in there you want your ads
to be healthy and to have as much
information as possible and then the one
thing i will say about google ads is
they also have extensions so extensions
are exactly that they're extensions to
your text ad so here you can see i have
four extensions these are actually site
links so google ads offers up something
called ad extensions so it could be call
outs site links could be location
extensions app extensions they have a
number of different extensions that they
can append to your ad so take advantage
of that as well remember the whole point
of ads is to make a compelling case for
your product or service so that somebody
can click on the ad and go to your
website and then perform the action you
want them to perform now if you have any
more questions about google ads feel
free to check out our in-depth video
about google ads it covers everything a
to z on google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learn youtube
playlist for facebook uh twitter social
media marketing so if you're curious to
know a little bit more about search
engine marketing you know check out any
one of these videos that we have listed
on our youtube channel okay so let's
move over to affiliate marketing now and
so with affiliate marketing
really it's interesting and unique and
that affiliate marketing involves paying
out commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service okay these
people who are selling your product or
service on your behalf are going to get
commissioned or incentivized based on
whatever action you put out there so it
could be registrations just getting your
affiliates to help you with
getting people registered or signing up
for your email or
you know for a lot of you conversions
you're trying to sell a product so you
want help in selling that product or it
could be subscriptions okay signing up
to something okay so
you determine what it is you want to
incentivize your affiliates for you also
determine how much you're going to
incentivize them and that's the great
thing about affiliate marketing it's
it's no different than having a sales
team um to support you what are the
steps for affiliate marketing well you
need to find a platform there are lots
of different affiliate platforms out
there you know commission junction or
cj.com comes to mind because these
platforms are going to help you find
these affiliates or partners okay so
they're the broker and all this and
so once you set up your platform you're
going to establish rules guidelines post
images and banners and assets for those
affiliates to use on their websites and
more importantly again you're going to
establish the commission so the
commission doesn't have to be the same
for all affiliates it could simply be
you know your top affiliates get a
higher commission as opposed to just
some other affiliates who get a starting
commission you establish everything on
the platform the affiliate platform that
you choose now affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf so they're
gonna say hey i'm interested in selling
your product or service so you're going
to use that platform if it's commission
junction to approve or disapprove the re
affiliates request to advertise on your
behalf and really what you want to try
and do is leverage the platform as best
as you can a lot of these affiliates are
out to make money and some of them are
really good you need to be able to
choose the affiliate that is going to
represent your brand product or service
the best so it's simple customer clicks
on an ad or link okay on that affiliate
website and they go to your website and
they perform an action so that could be
a purchase a registration a subscription
a download an email sign up you
determine that and the great thing is
these affiliate networks the cj's
commission junctions of the world will
record everything they're tracking not
only traffic from the affiliate website
to your website but they're also
tracking the conversions the transaction
is validated and credited to the
affiliate by the broker and then the
affiliate has paid his or her commission
so that's how it works so the more the
affiliate sells or converts on your
behalf the more they're going to make
and that's the beauty of the affiliate
network so here's an example of
affiliate marketing okay here you can
see
uh an advertisement here okay so you can
see profit from our experience earn up
to 12 advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce list leader so somebody
clicks on that link joins and then this
person is going to get a commission
based on somebody joining
for free again i mentioned commission
junction there are also some other
affiliate marketing tools out there
uh
amazon associates a win trade doubler
max bounty i mean there's there's
there's a lot out there
cj.com is the one i've used in the past
but you know give some of these other
platforms a chance okay it doesn't hurt
to even be on multiple platforms you
have nothing to lose okay when you're on
a platform basically the platform again
is acting as the middle person they're
introducing you to affiliates and so
every time you actually pay an affiliate
a commission they're going to get their
cut of it so they're going to get a
small percentage as well so just keep
that in mind but you know give it a try
try one or two of these affiliates if
you find you're getting quality
affiliates that are selling your product
or service great if you don't then you
know feel free to change you know
affiliate networks it's that simple but
the key here is find the affiliates you
think are going to best represent your
brand product or service because those
affiliates are likely going to be the
ones to convert for you and if your
small business starting out and you need
some help affiliate marketing is the way
to go okay let's move over to native
advertising okay so native advertising
so negative advertisements means that
your ad is showing up next to content
that basically
naturally fits so these are advertisers
that are featured on a platform
alongside the content okay that isn't
paid for okay so for example here you
can see a paid post okay this is by
spotify okay this paid post okay was on
buzzfeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about your
bands that probably won't exist without
led zeppelin okay so for spotify
you're using native advertising allows
them to put their ad next to content
related to their ad here you can see
another buzzfeed article okay 11 great
amazon deals that will be music to your
ears if you're an audiophile here you
can see
an advertisement next to the article so
you can see the ad about led zeppelin
and here you can see the actual article
is about music so the whole point about
native advertising is making sure
there's a connection between the ad and
the article so spotify is advertising
okay their product and service on an
article on buzzfeed which happens to be
about music so a good example we used
buzzfeed just a second ago so if we go
to buzzfeed here you can see i'm on tv
and movies and here you can see got an
ad here if we scroll down uh keep
scrolling down we can see another ad
here for hbo and so this ad makes sense
because it's placed on tvs and movies so
people who go and read the content are
going to see an ad related to that
content so that's generally what native
advertising is you need to be able to be
able to place the ad on the right pages
okay so you're going to need it and
network for that so we talked about paid
search advertising we talked about
google ads so google ads has the ability
to place your ad natively on particular
pages that are relevant to that ad so
that's really what native advertising is
all about making sure that your ad is
placed next to content that's naturally
relevant so if you need more information
about affiliate marketing feel free to
visit simplylearn's youtube channel we
have a nice uh in-depth video about
affiliate marketing to get more
information about the platforms how it
works and all the tips and best
practices about how to run a successful
affiliate marketing campaign so let's
turn our attention to email marketing
now so email marketing very traditional
form of digital marketing it's been
around the longest it's kind of the
grandfather of all digital marketing
channels so email marketing really is
used to personalize emails in order to
convert that recipient or that
perspective user into a customer and so
like all the other digital marketing
channels we want to follow some type of
flow or process or methodology and the
first step in email marketing is you
have to identify your target audience
okay when you identify your target
audience you're going to create a
segment okay so in other words you don't
want to send one email to everyone
because not everyone is going to be
interested in that email so in order to
get somebody interested you need to be
able to send an email tailored to that
audience okay so that audience can
respond and react accordingly so once
you target that audience and create
segments email segments you're going to
create the campaign and set up an
appropriate call to action one note here
is when you create the campaign and set
up that appropriate call to action that
call to action is going to be aligned
with your goal so what is the goal of
the email campaign is it simply to get
people to click on something and
purchase or is it simply to get people
to click on something and sign up or
watch something or submit some
information or download or whatever the
case you need to establish that up front
just like you would with a search engine
marketing campaign or any other type of
campaign you want to run so
there are lots of tools out there just
like with affiliate marketing you want
to choose an appropriate email marketing
tool there are plenty to be had each
work in a very similar nature
some
offer different pricing models meaning
you know you can send an email to x
recipients for flat fee or you pay a
small amount per email address each one
is slightly different in terms of how
they price but in terms of the features
they all work in a very similar fashion
and we're going to show you an example
of one here shortly so when you choose
that email marketing tool you're going
to test your emails before you send them
out and then when you test your emails
you're going to use that email marketing
tool to actually send the campaign after
it's been tested okay so you want to
send the campaign you can immediately
send them out or you can schedule them
now a best practice with an email is
when you actually send one out you're
sending an email out to your target
audience you want to create probably two
emails per segment audience why because
you want to add an attractive subject
line and copy to the email but if you
send two emails to the same target
audience then you want to test the
subject lines you want to be able to see
what subject lines going to entice
somebody to open the email okay that's
the beauty of email marketing is you can
do that okay so you can set up your a
design based on your target audience but
it's always the subject line that people
see first so you want to write an
attractive subject line and copy that's
going to entice somebody to open the
email so why not send two emails to each
target audience that way you can see
what email subject line works best so
that's the whole idea about performing a
b test to test out different ideas it
doesn't necessarily have to be a subject
line it can be the same subject line two
emails but the difference being the body
of the email it's totally up to you but
the idea here is to always split out
your emails per target audience and just
like any other channel whether it be
affiliate or search engine marketing
organic search you want to analyze
performance and in the case of emails
it's always about open rates how many
people are opening then how many people
are clicking and then how many people
are actually responding are they
converting or downloading or whatever it
is you want them to do you need to be
able to monitor the behavior because for
example if your open rates don't work or
they're low then you know something's
wrong with your subject line so you want
to be able to make an adjustment so
here's an example of an email from
airbnb it's a simple email okay they're
just simply trying to get somebody to
click on that call to action to take the
survey okay that's really all it's about
here with this particular email so who's
their target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at
a airbnb property or it could be
somebody who used the app probably
airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example of a targeted email with
a good call to action that's getting
somebody to take the survey so they're
probably measuring how many people
opened it how many people clicked on the
cta the call to action and then how many
people actually filled out the survey so
you need to follow each step and track
each step accordingly okay so again some
popular tools used in email marketing
let's take a look at mailchimp here uh
but i will mention like marcato is a
good marketing automation tool
now owned by adobe marketo allows you to
send those drip campaigns so if somebody
doesn't purchase right away you can send
up follow-up emails like say one day out
or seven days out or 14 days out so
hubspot works in a very similar fashion
you want to be able to methodically plan
out your emails that's the point i'm
trying to make here so let's take a look
at mailchimp so if we go over into
mailchimp a very easy interface okay
here if we go under audience we can
actually see who our audience is and we
can break out our audience into
different groups you can have a simple
test list you can have people who
purchase people who subscribe to
something okay so you can break out your
audience into different groups okay when
it comes to campaigns you can see
campaigns that are already been built or
you can create your own campaign okay so
in the case of mailchimp we can actually
see
what campaigns have been dropped or sent
out already and then we can see
the opens the clicks and then the
conversions so mailchimp has some nice
reporting so you want to be able to
measure
the reports or how well the campaign
performed so here we could see
specifically how many people open
clicked how many people bounced or email
addresses bounced and how many people
unsubscribed from the list and here we
can see you know the top links that have
been clicked okay the subscribers with
the most opens did anybody perform any
social media activity okay what
locations open the email okay so you can
actually see a lot of good information
here right in mailchimp and you want to
be able to react to the emails you send
out so if an email is not performing
okay you want to learn from that so you
don't make the same mistake again great
thing i like about mailchimp too they
have a lot of nice templates to use so
if you're trying to create a template
here you got some templates that you can
leverage so that's mailchimp kind of in
a nutshell mailchimp you could pay
upfront buy credits and with those
credits you could send out emails to a
number of people okay so that's how
mailchimp works they do have a free
trial so you can set up an account using
the free trial now if you need any more
information about mailchimp for email
marketing in general take a look at the
email marketing webinar we have set up
on our simply learn youtube account now
let's finish up with online pr press
releases so we talked about seo and
social and search and affiliate and
email marketing and content native
advertising let's talk about online pr
here because with online pr
it really does involve working with
digital publications or blogs or other
content related websites for example
content related websites could be
newspaper digital newspaper sites like
the new york times okay the whole point
of
online pr is you want to try and get
some publicity on those on those
websites publicity means awareness for
the brand it means traffic to the
website and eventually some loyalty
future customers and conversions
channels that can be used to maximize
your online pr efforts for example you
can connect with reporters on social
media to develop a relationship so you
can just follow some reporters see if
they're covering specific
industries or verticals and if they are
similar to what you're offering then
it's probably a good idea to reach out
to them you can use engaging user
reviews to help humanize your brand or
you can respond to comments that help
generate productive conversations so
those are all certain things you can do
to generate awareness and buzz for your
brand so really the one thing i want to
point out about online pr is
basically you can also hire a pr firm
and they can do some of the heavy
lifting for you
or like i said you can reach out to
different reporters or different
influencers even to help push your
product or brand now if you're trying to
go at it alone on the online pr what you
could do if you don't reach out to
reporters or influencers or you're
active in trying to build your brand
through a conversation you can always
use a third party service like pr.com so
pr.com allows you to you know basically
create your own profile you know submit
content to your own profile or even
submit press releases if you submit
press releases then other news agencies
are going to pick up on those press
releases so it's a good way to get your
press releases out there likes of yahoo
and google might pick up those press
releases and give you some you know much
needed visibility you can also use other
tools like you know pr newswire for
example so it works in a very similar
way
again it's a press release distribution
network so you can go ahead and sign up
for an account get that press release
out there and they do the distribution
for you or you can also use aggregation
sites so there are lots of different
aggregate sites out there and so what
aggregate websites do
is they help disseminate and distribute
your
content so here you can see some of the
new aggregator websites of 2019 you got
feedly
panda tech mimi
metacritic e science news the morning
news so you have a lot of options
available
to get your content out there okay so
what these sites do is basically pick up
articles that fit their website fit
their theme fit their target audience so
you do have options in the form of
third-party tools as well okay so if you
don't hire a pr firm which could be
expensive you can certainly go at it
alone by signing up for any one of these
particular products or services today
we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so fasten your seat
belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools for not
only 2019 but ones that have performed
well in the past that are popular and
ones that we foresee as being the go-to
tools for the future so past present and
future digital marketing tools is the
way to look at this uh with a good focus
on a lot of different marketing channels
here so we're going to focus first on
seo talk about some of the tools related
to on page and off page we're going to
switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so it'll be good to kind
of see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so that's what we're going
to do the goal is to get you to better
understand some of the tools we're using
a little bit more detail and what we're
going to do is start out with search
engine optimization okay so search
engine optimization or organic search we
have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on seo you certainly
need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about seo you'll know
that using google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another seo
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here meal delivery so we're
going to just type in mail delivery and
get some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another key to it if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here i
get a
column for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
7.46
and at the top of the page high range
16.61
so that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna try and optimize for
this keyword i know it's competitive
because not only google is telling me
it's competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword on
page one of google so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner and
note that you could change some of the
settings here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer shorter period of time you
can even choose a specific location so i
chose texas i can certainly choose the
entire united states to get a sense of
what the volume would be for the total
us so you have settings that you can
change and manipulate to get you the
data you need to choose keywords so
that's the whole idea behind google's
keyword planner to find relevant
keywords high volume low competition now
alternatively i can certainly use
another tool to find keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask moz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from
eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between one and one hundred
and so i could see this is pretty much
right down the middle in terms of
difficulty okay so if it's zero it's an
easy keyword if it's if it's a hundred
it's very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use google's keyword
planner because maybe you're not running
google ads you can always use mazda
remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you can test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use mods we want to be able to
use google's keyword planner not only to
search for all those relevant keywords
available to you but we want to be able
to choose keywords with high volume and
low difficulty low competition we also
want to select primary and second
keywords wisely so remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword so you want to be
able to have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so moz gives you that
information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research for seo so take a look at that
video on youtube and to get more
specific details about using seo tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for seo so
let's talk about some other reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us well we want
to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic hrefs again moz let's take a
look at google search console and i want
to hone in on google search console
because it is free and it's a must if
you're going to work on seo you need to
be working in google search console and
so the whole key behind google search
console is you have a website and you
need to get that site verified once it's
verified when school can recognize that
you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so
here i'm looking at a website and what
am i looking at i'm looking at something
called coverage under index so what does
coverage mean well going back to what we
just said we want to be able to
understand how google's crawling and
indexing our pages and so what google
does is through this platform search
console is they're letting us know once
they go to our website and start
crawling it and they pull these pages
back to their server they're letting us
know
if we actually have any issues so here i
could see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a 4
4 you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i can
see submitted url marked no index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you know fall victim to this error
and so we can really hone in
on what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
okay so these are the errors i could see
they've certainly were able to crawl and
index
9115 pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54 000 plus pages and
then we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of
what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error an issue that they found if
we want these pages indexed we need to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they discovered via the sitemap
and so the whole point of a sitemap is
we want to be able to get and push the
urls to google not have google come to
our site and discover them so this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with google all the urls
that you have on your site that you want
google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report so google is a
staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish
a lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand
how your site fares
via mobile and when i say fares via
mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to google
standards and so if there are any issues
google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here i could see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are
and so here i can see for 206 pages text
too small to read click elements too
close together the viewport not set to
device width and then content wider than
the screen so there's 10 pages that fit
under this error and if i actually click
on it the error i can see what those 10
pages are and so when we're done we can
actually when we address the issues we
can actually have google validate
whether the fix has been made so you can
definitely use this as a means of
communicating directly with google
telling google look i see what the
issues are i'm going to fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
google's attention google's going to
validate them and get these pages
indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search console shows us
what pages have the most links okay so
here we can see the home page has 26 000
plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so externally
i want links from other websites
pointing to various pages on my site and
i certainly want my pages linking to one
another on my site and so i'd be able to
better understand what that structure
looks like using google search consoles
links report okay there's one more
report that i think's of interest in
google search console and that's the
performance report so the performance
report is a report that actually you can
link up with google analytics so you can
see the same report and analytics if
you're able to link up google search
console with analytics and you should be
able to do that all you need to do is
make sure you use the same email address
that you use for analytics and search
console so it needs to be the same email
address you could certainly link up the
two and have this data imported into
google analytics so what is this data
that we're talking about well it's
called performance so what we can
actually see is the queries the actual
queries people are typing in to google
so when they're typing them into google
we can actually see
how many impressions the keyword queries
received and how many clicks the keyword
queries received and then i can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here i can see for this
particular keyword on the first line i
could see over the course of the last
three months it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at le
or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result
of somebody typing in this query 209 000
plus times this site received 120 000
plus clicks so to get a sense of the
click-through rate all you would need to
do and google can obviously do this for
you is you would simply just divide the
209 000 297 into the 120 000 397 okay so
that's really going to give you that's
going to give you a click-through rate
and the click-through rate in this case
is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when
this listing appears for this keyword
okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many impressions and
clicks i'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
i can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now i
mentioned the beauty of the google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
google search console and then from
there you can choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so i can
see the same data that i see in search
console but this time i'm looking at it
in google analytics and so here i can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my impressions my click-to-rate bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
sitemaps to keyword research but we also
want to hone in on you know what domains
are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to hey maybe identify and disavow
poor backlinks so search console is a
great tool for that because if we don't
want to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on page
optimization but
for off page optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain i'm going to be able
to get what they call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 in 100 i'm able to
see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazd even takes it a step
further they also give me a spam score
so moz is able to measure how spammy a
website is so if i have a combination of
say a low domain authority and a high
spam score then i probably want to
disavow myself from that site and so i
can use this report here you can see
here as i keep going down for example i
could see this particular website has a
domain authority of 26 and it has a spam
score of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has
so many links pointing to me or it has
at least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i could get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority
spam etc everything you need to use in
order to measure off page seo so that's
the great thing about moz is they have
not only on-page seo tools but off-page
seo tools and moz is a freemium so to
speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash seo tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for seo but also for local seo
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so i use and lean on moz a lot for
all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner uh moz and google search console
okay let's switch over to email
marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at mailchimp but there are certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool you know marketo is a
good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's hubspot a very powerful tool it
does a lot from creating landing pages
to a b testing to social
to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma you know
feel free to to note that in the comment
section below this video i'm curious as
to how many people actually use you know
different tools because there are so
literally so many email marketing tools
out there why because email marketing
has been around probably the longest
amongst all the other digital marketing
channels and a lot of people use email
on a daily basis so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you can certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around
that particular audience so you know you
have a good tool when you can do that
when you can really segment for your
audience okay you want to be able to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of recipients clicked on your email what
links do they click on you know which
which emails bounce so you want some
detailed insights right in the platform
that you're using it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want to create
those smart automated campaigns meaning
you don't even have to send out the
email and then you want to be able to
have some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time of day
so these tools also allow you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multi-variant
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email again this is
important because with email marketing
you want to be able to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience
but i really like the reports that they
have to offer
so you know here you can see there's
some lists that we've sent to
and
we choose one of our audience list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so
here i could see this email that was
sent out in june i could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers i saw 2000 plus open it and
157 clicks so i can view this report in
more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so i
can get down really to the nitty gritty
i can actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here i'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16
i only had an open rate of 2.5 percent
so the industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with a
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products
and somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp and summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters
so the first one is campaign source so
what's the source of the campaign well
we could certainly identify
mail champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lowercase so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using
you know constant contact or vertical
response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email
i would certainly recommend that you use
the campaign content parameter and why
do i say that because if we're sending
an email out to say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's gonna get
subject line one
and one segment that's gonna get subject
line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is
in the campaign content field so now i
have four parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields i now have a
revised or appended url so my original
url was visit florida.com
ian-us
florida-beaches.html
my original url i've now appended that
with some utm parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with the utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with
my utm parameters appended to the url so
that's for the first subject line that's
for the audience that's going to get the
first subject line i want to do another
one for the second subject line so now
i'm going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
i'm going to copy that url i'm going to
check it
okay so i can see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do i'm going to use
the first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link that i have in this case i'm
using subject line two so for the email
with the second subject line going to
that segmented audience this is the link
i'm going to use in the email so if you
have one or two or three links in the
email this is the url you're going to
use because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics
so if i jump over to google analytics
after i send out my email i'm going to
go to acquisition i'm going to go to
campaigns i'm going to go to all
campaigns now based on the variables i
put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm going to look for in google
analytics so we could start with source
and medium so if i click on source and
medium as my primary dimension
here i can see mailchimp and the actual
date was used as part of the variable
for for source and then i will can i see
the medium being email so now i can see
for this email that was sent out in
mailchimp in may i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the url
builder again you're taking a url that
you're going to use in email and then
you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended url which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that medium of that
content i.e subject line and so that's
why
the url builders so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but
what we really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to use the url builder with
whatever email platform you're using so
let's move on to web analytics tools and
this is an important section because web
analytics tools kind of the central
focal point of all digital marketing and
it starts really with google analytics
google analytics is a freemium meaning
that they have a free version that you
can use there is also a paid version of
google analytics but given the advent of
google its popularity especially in the
united states a majority of users are
using the free version of google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just google so we have adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
youtube analytics which is
part of google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well again we want to really
measure behavior we want to measure
what's going on with our website so we
want to be able to identify the location
of where our website visitors are coming
from and a lot of these analytics tools
use ip address to identify the location
of a website visitor so if you're trying
to target a specific country then you
want to be able to see that the visitors
to your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between
50 new and 50 returning because you know
returning visitors are loyal there's
some loyalty to that they already know
your brand they're coming back to your
website new visitors are curious and you
want new visitors because that means
more traffic so you want a nice balance
between that analytics tools will help
you measure that you want to be able to
measure organic traffic whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics will help
you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do we want to look
into each one of these sections so let's
start with audience and so audience and
google analytics tells us who is coming
to our website now they're not going to
specifically tell us hey rob sanders
came to your website but they are going
to say that somebody from san francisco
california came to the website and these
are the pages they looked at and this is
the language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning user so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i
got a demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that
63 of my traffic and again this is year
to date that i'm looking at is coming to
my website so two-thirds of my traffic
is female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so i'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well i can
also look at geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
i go to location under geo i'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
i can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here i can see
united states is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the us
and then 16 from argentina 13 from
mexico 10 from india so we have a nice
mix of traffic from different locations
in the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i can see
year to date i can see 62
are coming from desktop 35
are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email social then i
could see more paid search broken out so
these are the different marketing
channels now analytics allows you to
look at a specific source and medium so
the source would be the actual website
or search engine and the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or did they
come to the site via organic search and
so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and medium and we can
see specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here i can see
google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16
of our traffic so then i can look down i
can see email in here being organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources and mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns all campaigns
and we'll be able to see the campaign
performance if we look at source and
medium we'll be able to see what
campaigns drove traffic to the website
so here i can see vertical response
email as a driver of traffic so that's
the campaign reporting and then also if
you have search consoles so we looked at
search console earlier we talked about
seo tools well remember i said you can
link up search console with google
analytics well here's search console and
we could see queries devices landing
pages countries so all the performance
metrics that we could see in search
console because we have it linked up
with analytics we can see it right here
so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're going to get so that's
the idea behind it we want to make sure
that we're ranking for our coveted
keywords and if we are we want to be
able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about
you know google they have a family of
products and those products tend to talk
to one another in the form of google
search console and google ads you can
connect them directly to google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so
here in behavior
we have a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique pages which is
equal to sessions so i could have a
session come to the website and look at
a page multiple times in that session i
could see the average time the person
has spent on a page and i can also see
the bounce rate so a bounce rate
indicates that they arrived on the page
and didn't go any further they left the
website from that page that they arrived
on and so i can also see percentage of
exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page not
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe load time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see
if i scroll down this is desktop and
these are some of the opportunities that
i can address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here i
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized i can remove unused css okay
so there are a lot of different things i
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop i can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift and page load time
we see lift and page load time we're
going to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here
we could see for our particular website
we have categories already set up for
event tracking so here for example i can
see on line six video i can see how many
people actually watched our video okay
so here's the action video start okay so
over this period of time i could see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always report to
label and that'll tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to set up your events through
google tag manager which is another
google platform but you certainly want
to do that so that's where you set up
your events when you set up your events
for your website with a category an
action and label you'll be able to
measure those events in analytics under
behavior under events and the important
thing here is you'll be able to measure
engagement so i'll be able to see how
many people came to the site and how
many people clicked on a button
downloaded a pdf uh submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because
we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if i go
to admin down at the bottom and then i
go to goals i could see that i have four
different types of goals that i can use
now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so if somebody goes to a specific page
like a confirmation page we can turn
that into a goal so here i can see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i could see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
gold type so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter signups
156 donate click buttons i have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if i want to look at for
example
how many people from organic search
clicked on the donate now button i could
see that i could see year to date 10
887 users which meant 11 000 sessions 76
clicked on that donate now button and
that comes out to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign mobile
device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see
in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the baited the
studio version of youtube and then from
there
i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and
i've netted 48 subscribers and this is
an overall
okay so i can actually see when i
publish videos and i can see the date
they were published and here i'm looking
at you know total views over this
particular date range i can also see
specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here i
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here i could
see 25 came within youtube itself i
could see how many times a video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so i could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here i could see
externally how people were able to find
my videos and i could see 46 percent
found it via google search see some lots
of information here
about sources of traffic how the traffic
got to these videos
so i could see then once the traffic
found my videos how many times they
actually saw it and viewed it and then
watched it so that's how many times i
was able to reach viewers via different
sources and then their reaction to that
how many times they saw it and watched
it here i can click on interest viewers
so again i could see the top videos in
terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partners playlist
was the top playlist so i can see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
youtube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here i can see 88
of the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via youtube search i could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it i could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to hone in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool social blade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well moz we
looked at moz earlier for keyword and
organic moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simplylearn i use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because seo organic search is a
long-term strategy on-page off-page
website very technical and creative
there's a lot going on with seo a lot
going on and
sometimes it takes a long time to rank
for something and a lot of seo does
depend on relevancy relevancy being how
many quality backlinks are linked to you
so it's always good to leverage what
your competitors are doing so you can
see how you stack up and so that's why
this is up there as number one we want
to be able to really take a look at what
our competitors are doing another
example would be
hey how much uh traffic a competitors
gaining on certain keywords this could
go either way for paid search organic
search what are competitors bidding on
are they really getting traffic from
those keywords so there are tools out
there that help us leverage what our
competition is doing okay we can also
identify our competitors top performing
content for relevant topics okay we can
determine what our competitors website
referral traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with sprout social
and sprout social is a tool i use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
posts that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example rv rentals in twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about rv rentals so we could do this for
twitter we could do it facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on sprout social is to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
rv rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go rv
rentals cruise america rv we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword rv rentals now if i
want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so rv share so here i can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting to or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay i can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
i can scroll down and i can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and i can see a lot of
people are as an example retweeting this
particular giveaway and so to me it just
gives me a sense in this particular
example on twitter as to what are
competitors doing okay let's turn our
attention to seo so remember that first
bullet point we want to get a sense of
what our competitors are doing when it
comes to backlinks and so moz has a
great tool called link explorer and link
explorer there allows us to actually
compare link profiles so for my domain i
can go ahead and put my competitors
domains in there and definitely get a
sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
sense of the domain authority i can get
a sense of page authority linking
domains so i can really do a
comparison across my domain and my
competitors domains to get a snapshot of
how i compare against my competitors so
this gives me an overview of everything
i need to know organically now moz also
has another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors really have a
number of external links and domains
pointing to their site and they have a
better domain authority and page
authority then you know i want to be
able to you know see what they're doing
where they're linking who's linking to
them i want to get be able to get a
snapshot of why is their domain so much
better than ours in terms of authority
and so the link intersect actually
allows me to do that so i can go ahead
and put my competitors domains in there
and then i can find opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
can see where
my site intersects with their site and
if it doesn't actually intersect then i
have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then i have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the link
intersect tool is in moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where i'm
linking and where my competitor is
linking now what we can also do is also
take advantage of another report under
moz's link explorer and the discovered
and lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so
really within mods we can get a good
snapshot of what web sites are linking
to our competitors we get a good
snapshot of the overall links to our
competitor sites and specifically with
sites so the whole idea is if it's good
for our competitors meaning they're
linking from a site that has good domain
authority and low spam score then it's
probably a site i want to be able to
tackle as well okay so you have
discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in moz's
link explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in moz and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitors
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain authority
is page authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9 000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain authority i could sort
by domain authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here i can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking new york times
so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here washington post so i can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course i don't want to go
through 9 000 links i can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so i can really
filter it if i wanted to i can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as i
could see what url
is linking to this particular competitor
site what the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is so this
gives me a really really good insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if i'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on reddit
then we probably need to be on reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from reddit which has a domain authority
of 90 then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links is it just another
good report you can leverage in moz
under the link explorer reporting tool
now if i want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitors doing on search
exactly well look no further than spyfu
so spyfu is a another tool that you can
leverage from a ppc seo perspective you
know from an seo perspective you got
some back linking data as well just like
you did in moz from a ppc perspective
you can get some good keyword insights
and so here i just went ahead and typed
in the domain and what this is going to
do is just give me an overall snapshot
for my competitors domain so here
i could see you know how many organic
keywords they're found for the estimated
monthly seo clicks they're getting based
on the volume of those keywords okay i
could see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domain has been around a long time okay
so that's on the organic side flip over
to the paid side and i could see that
they are doing paid search i could see 5
000 plus keywords they're bidding on
okay based on that what they're actually
paying and then i could see you know
some of the other competitors listed
here from a paid perspective and an
organic perspective i could see the
shared keyword overlap okay now again
you can pay for this because it's
freemium and get some really good
insights as to how your domain compares
to your competitors so i'm using the
free version and here the free version
spyfu is just giving me some overall
data on the specific domain i entered in
and so i entered in my competitors you
can certainly enter in your own domain
to get a sense of organic keywords and
paid keywords so you can see top
keywords top paid keywords okay this is
google ads okay so this is what
recommendations as to what to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
google ads history i could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then i
can see some organic ranking history
here as i keep scrolling down this
overview report so i can see for rv rent
where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spyfu
gives you kind of an overview for free
some really in-depth analysis if you
actually pay for it and it just really
hones in on what your competitors are
bidding for paid wise and what they're
ranking for organic wise and so spy food
is a really good tool to leverage if you
just want to get a snapshot of how your
competitor
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to google analytics because in
google analytics under audience i can go
to benchmarking and
basically the benchmarking reports
allows me to see what the industry as a
whole is doing compared to my own
website now the caveat here on this
particular report is that it's all
anonymous data so i can't exactly see
what competitor is doing what in this
report but if i hone in on my industry
in this case autos and vehicles and i
hone in on a specific country or adjust
the size of the daily sessions that i
get then i could see hey analytics in
this case in this example i'm sharing 8
863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and i can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how i stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and
we can adjust our locale and if we do
that google is going to be able to
adjust how many web properties are
actually contributing to the report and
so when analytics makes that adjustment
we're going to be able to see in this
case just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and
we're going to go with 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so if we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so i find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a
keyword and we're gonna type in rv
rentals and now we're gonna be able to
see who's bidding on that keyword so we
could see we have a number of different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets okay and then i
can see some organic search results okay
if i scroll down i'll be able to see
some other companies bidding on that
same keyword meaning they're paying for
rv rental so if i clicked on somebody's
link here they're actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense of you know how
many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword so
that's all i did i just did a search now
from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now i could see i have 163 000 results
and what does that tell me that tells me
that i have 163 000 websites with rv
rentals in the title tag so if you're
trying to optimize for the keyword rv
rentals as an example then you know that
you have 163 thousand different listings
ahead of you that you need to jump over
in order to rank for the keyword rv
rentals so using the all in title syntax
and the keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of how many sites are actually
ahead of you for a particular keyword so
that's the whole idea so if i get rid of
the syntax and you can see for rv
rentals i have 132 million but that's
not really accurate because not all
these listings have the keyword rv
rentals in the title tag and title tag
if you're working on organic search is
one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag so that's the whole
idea behind using the all in title
syntax it gives us a good idea as to
what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here i'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and i can see our competitors okay so i
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one keyword every
keyword has a hundred percent impression
share how much of that impression share
are you getting and when we say
impression share meaning eyeballs when
we talk about eyeballs are we getting a
majority of the eyeballs or our
competitors getting majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position i can see how often i overlap
with my competitors okay i could see how
often i'm above a particular competitor
i could see what percentage i'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then i
can see how often i out rank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so i could see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords i am okay so this is if you're
running google ads okay so if you're
running google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find that the top navigation just by
clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on google bing linkedin you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so
you know if you're doing paid search
on say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage okay
and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have google ads keyword
planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so bing
if you're running campaigns on bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest through some reporting okay you
also have some third-party tools out
there that you also have to pay for in
word stream okay so
word streams a third
tool that you can leverage bing and
google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting now they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations and devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has
auction insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information in the case of auction
insights as to how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so that's on the
paid search side then you have display
okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example admiral okay curtillo celtra
is another paid version of or paid tool
you can use in wide orbit so these are
some of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor
whether we have the right keywords and
right customer engagement so when we
when it comes to display we want to be
able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple of minutes okay so we
want to improve our campaigns by
monitoring our competitors display ads
as well so there are tools available
that will help you do that and that's on
the display side and if we look at
social okay why what tools can we use on
social well you got facebook ads manager
okay you got ad espresso quiet tweepy
you got all these cool paid search tools
again i usually stick with where i'm
advertising so if i'm advertising on
linkedin or twitter i'm going to
leverage that platform but just know
that there are
other tools available for you so with
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights
in this example about facebook users how
are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run
for example if we're running
call to action test we can measure the
results that write in facebook and i'm
going to show you an example of that
here shortly so let's jump right into
google ads and look at some tools
available to us
from the search side of the house so if
we're running search campaigns right in
google ads we could see campaign data we
could see keyword data we could see add
data so for example if i want to see
what ads are performing i'm just going
to click on my ads and extensions okay
and here are my ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads uh platform itself now if
i want to look at specific keywords i
can do that so i can see what keywords
are driving traffic and clicks here i
could just sort by clicks and now i can
see not only what keywords are driving
clicks i could see what the
click-through rate is i could see the
impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that i'm bidding on i
could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality scores
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about
the keyword reporting is that there's
some other features available to me here
so here i can add negative keywords okay
just by clicking on negative keywords i
can also see a search terms report and
so when it comes to search terms i can
actually see what specific keywords
people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that i don't
particularly care to be shown for or i
want my ad shown for then i can go ahead
and just select it and i can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in google ads
okay and then you have the auction
insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what the impression
share is what their average position is
what the overlap rate is position above
rate top of page absolute top of page
right now rank and share so once we have
google has data then they'll be able to
share that information with you okay so
that's just keywords but there's a cool
tool that i really like and i leverage
it for seo and pay-per-click and that's
google's keyword planner so if you click
on tools and then you click on keyword
planner we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords
or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much i
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
i happen to click on that keyword i can
add it to a plan and then once i've
added to a plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure
what kind of volume i'm going to get and
how much i can expect to pay so now once
i've added my keyword to that plan i can
go ahead
and see how many clicks and impressions
and costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see
basically how much i can expect to spend
so that's the whole idea behind the
keyword planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many impressions you can
expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so
there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just gonna highlight some of
the more important tools and features so
i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mentioned this as
one of our key defining why would we use
it bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is right in google eyes
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then
my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i could see the ad
groups here okay so for example i just
wanted to turn off all these ad groups i
can just highlight them all and just
click status enabled to pause and i can
revert back if i want to okay so you can
make household changes so here i could
see the campaign the ad group level if i
choose an ad group then i can see some
key words and again i can make changes
at nauseum here i can copy i can paste i
can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes really quick right in google ads
editor and that's the whole point of
editor is to go ahead and work locally
while somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent changes so if i say get
recent changes to all campaigns what
google editor is going to do is contact
google ads in the cloud and download all
those changes so here i can see the
changes being download in editor from
google ads and when it's done it's going
to highlight all the changes that have
been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
write an editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
google ads you can do in google ads
editor and so that's google ads editor
to me i would recommend it if you're
experienced with google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on google ads and so that's google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform still
the same and some of the same tools are
available
from the search network as well as for
the display network right in google ads
so if i want to take a look at a
campaign and ad group on the display
network i can just click on that ad
group and i can look at the ads that are
running for that particular ad group on
the display network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
network you can only use text ads so
here i can look at image ads and i can
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i can
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click-through rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword ad
whatever the dimension is so here on the
display network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i could see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media
paid search advertising i just want to
remind you we do have you know a nice
tutorial on google ads okay so take a
look at the google ads tutorial we have
set up on youtube okay if you search for
google ads tutorial 2019 this is a good
uh tutorial on everything related to
google ads so check out this video
because in today's webinar we're just
mentioning tools across the board and if
you are advertising on google ads as
most people do
then you could see just how powerful it
is and all the different features that
are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complimentary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network
then feel free to comment below this
video happy to hear your comments about
what tools and reports and features you
specifically use in google ads so let's
move into uh facebook ads manager and
show you how the platform looks when
you're running ads on facebook so we can
look at all the different tools and
reports available here so here we can
see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the app and i
can see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so
now i can go in and i can go ahead and
look at the ad performance and go ahead
and change out that ad if it's not
performing to
my expectation so if i click on more
tools and then creatives i can just
simply click on creators and then i can
actually see the creators i actually
have running for that campaign i
selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has uh reap
different reporting so if i click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
i could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender
and then i can see all reports here
listed out by placement by placement and
device time of day country etc so if we
just look at age and gender we'll be
able to get a breakout age and gender
here so you can see by campaign i'm
looking at all campaigns here and i'm
looking at just age and gender i can
certainly deselect one of these and i
can look at a specific time range so now
i can see who's looking at my ad
specifically so here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad
a lot they're probably going to tune out
to it so that's what makes the frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and you know turn
off that particular age and gender if we
needed to and we could see how much we
spent so this just gives you some idea
of the type of reporting that's
available in facebook ads manager now
the great thing about facebook uh
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup uh my dimensions if
i needed to i could change the view and
arrange columns i can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here so i
have a lot of flexibility here on how i
review the reports you know you got
different metrics that you can pick and
choose as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics so i have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how i want to
you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the ad set that's
where a lot of your decisions are going
to be made including how you want to
drive the traffic okay what your budget
is okay you can basically choose your
audience here so you're going to be able
to choose what type of campaign is going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you right in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want some more
information about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on facebook
called facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they
having a freemium model meaning you can
have a free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are brokers per
se and when i say brokers like for
example with cj you as a merchant or you
as a publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning cj helps
bridge the gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so that's what really
affiliate marketing is and you really
need a platform to kind of put it all
together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify
you know affiliates inflowers employees
other advocates you want to partner with
so again you could be on the merchant
side you could be actually selling a
product and you're going to want
somebody to help you sell that product
somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand etc
so
you need somebody to help you introduce
you to these sites okay so cj and some
of these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you could set up
with terms and conditions for say 10 off
all sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics okay
so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click epc as an example
most platforms measure epc from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
impressions and conversions so
any affiliate platform worth its weight
is going to help you understand you know
how many pressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product
does somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately
cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole the idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over a seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
month to see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm going to repeat it
is you want to get publishers you want
to start building your base of
publishers because the more publishers
you have the more chance you are to sell
your product remember if nobody clicks
on your product then nobody's going to
buy your product so if you have
publishers who are promoting your
product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up the social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay
the first one i can think about here is
hootsuite hootsuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here you basically a base account
and then uh you can use hootsuite to do
a lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffer is a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweet
decks been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're going to take a look
at that here in a couple minutes okay
and then you got sprout social sprout
social is another social marketing
platform similar to hootsuite do a lot
of reporting a lot of publishing you can
a lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout chelsea today as
well before we do that
let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place
and that's what social media marketing
tools do they allow you to manage
everything in one place so if you could
manage everything one place then these
social media marketing platforms need to
be able to make it easy for you to add
and manage different accounts okay so a
lot of them have the ability for you to
add you know not just one twitter
account but multiple twitter accounts
and not just one social media platform
but multiple social media platforms and
a good social media marketing so worth
its weight will help you monitor the
results so monitor social media posts
that help drive leads and sales in other
words you're going to have a lot of
different metrics associated with each
social media marketing platform okay
which one is actually doing its job okay
so you want to be able to easily manage
these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform is log into one place get a
sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and
customize a post depending on what that
post is depending on what the product is
what time of day what target market what
target audience so customization is a
lot easier using these social media
marketing tools you want to be able to
engage with brand advocates so listening
is a good thing with social media
marketing tools using the listening
functionality so you can actually see
who is a brand advocate who's not a
brand advocate who's an influencer who's
not an influencer and then of course you
want to analyze the behavior of your
audience and optimize individual posts
on real-time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on facebook or
you're posting on facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example facebook has
something called facebook insight so
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent post so just to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads hey you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so
i don't have to log into facebook
directly i can see you know the
impressions the engagement the clicks
over a period of time i can see my
audience growth i can see my publishing
behavior how often my publishing i could
see the top post individually i could
see impressions by day you know a lot of
this same
material same information is already in
facebook insights so if it's available
on facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as i mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you can schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila scheduled so this is
on twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on when something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that i like
about it's about social hootsuite a lot
of these other platforms do it really
well you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location or radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout social's
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar sprout social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so i could see
today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account so i can pick and choose the
profile that i want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
right in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
can see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i can see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular platform's
performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach a lot profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something i
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if i wanted to i can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
discovery actions
comments saves etc so later.com goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hashtag you
can actually see how many times the
hashtags been used or saved how many
impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweetdeck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different
things that are trending on twitter
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
can see the you got the cricut world cup
you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that
friday feeling in their tweets and so
the whole idea behind you know tweetdeck
it serves up a interesting overview so
to speak of not only your account but
you know a specific topic or what's
trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social
later.com you know facebook insights so
it does cover in more detail some of
what we covered on these social media
marketing tools so take a look at how to
start social media marketing so we
covered a lot of different marketing
tools digital marketing tools everything
from seo to email to social to paid to
affiliate to competitor but there's also
a few
other digital marketing tools that you
can use in different ways like video seo
for example so vid iq you know we want
to use vid iq to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube
you can see vid iq is a browser
extension or browser a plug-in if you
will
so i can go and take a look at a
specific a specific video and see how
many hours it's been watched how many
views minutes watch subscribers etc you
know the great thing here i can look at
the entire entire account so
i can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid iq extension into my chrome
browser so vid iq actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for video seo okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third-party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo
then they may pay dividends for you you
want to be able to make sure your
content is fully optimized to the
fullest according to you know google's
algorithms and so you maybe you know
want to invest in that third-party tool
so these are good tools to use for
content optimization you know there's
also other key reddit but you know
there's keyboard planner uh in google
there's also a word stream there's a lot
of different keyword tools out there so
you may not have a google ads platform
and so if you don't have google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
google's keyword planner so having a
third party keyword tool will pay
dividends well because those dividends
pay off in the form of not only
pay-per-click but also seo and if you're
heavily invested in content heavily
invested in social then you may want to
take a look at the keyword tool keyword
it and it's primarily used for reddit we
talk about page load time so we looked
at that in google analytics we know that
it heavily impacts seo so there are
other tools available you got a third
party tool here that's free solarwinds
pingdom you actually have page speed
insights by google so these are free
tools that you could take advantage of
in determining how you can improve your
page load time my favorite topic
conversion rate optimization so you got
a couple in here crazy egg and target
okay so i'm gonna show you another tool
called hot jar so here if you log into
hotshot.com you can set up an account
it's actually free and with the free
account you can have hotjar measure the
heat map not only the heat map but the
click mapping the scrolling of a
particular page and so here you can see
we're looking at a particular page here
so
hotjar allows me to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking
mostly if i switch over to move mode
then i can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
mouse and then i have my scroll analysis
so i could see you know how far down
people actually scroll on the page and
so again with a paid account you can
measure up to 10 000 page views with the
free version you can measure up to 2 000
pages and so 2 000 page use allows you
to get some insight as to what people
are clicking on or where they're moving
or how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so i definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hotjar so hotjar.com is a
tool i would recommend as well so one
final tool and i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention it and that's google optimized
so google optimize is a google platform
that allows you to a b test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see i have
an account set up and optimized you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page
the original didn't have the photos to
the top of the page and so we can go
into reporting here google optimize does
all the heavy lifting and so here you
can see we can look at bounces or we can
look at you know basically
a measure the test up against the metric
that's important to our business and
again the whole point is to improve
website performance and so definitely
take a look at google optimize
we'll have another webinar in the future
on the topic but you know to me google
optimize is free you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests and that means you have
the ability to really improve website
performance okay so google optimize is a
tool that i would recommend today we're
going to talk about why you would want
to rank using seo and seo is search
engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings where we're going
to talk a little bit about why you'd
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
optimization then we're going to follow
that up with how does google rank
websites so why
does it rank one website over another
and how do we get our website to rank
number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're gonna finish that off
with the do's and don'ts of seo so let's
get right to it and talk about why seo
so we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am i not
ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a longer longer
than you when they have more content and
more blog posts and more pages for
google to rank so that's usually the
number one reason the other reason is
improper usage of keywords and we're
going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is de-indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice cream blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just made mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called a meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed's
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say response to
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank website and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to
basically rank the those pages that
they've indexed from number one to
infinity depending on how many pages are
relevant to that search query so really
it's about crawling indexing and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and
what these bots do is they go to your
web server and they're going to crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links you might have
heard the term spydering but that's what
they call search engine spidering so
basically what google's doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following and so when they
can follow all these links on your
website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index so based
on this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i could see i have one million ten
thousand results okay and that's how
many results are showing up for simply
learn okay now they may not all be
simply learned pages but nonetheless
simply learned is ranked number one here
organically and there are 1 million 10
000 pages related to the keyword simply
learn now when it comes to organic
search we don't want to get it confused
with paid search so anytime you see paid
search you're going to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google is able to cross simply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going appear in the
search results so in the example i gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their pages the page load time is
fast meaning these pages load very fast
for the end user and google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in india the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the united
states why because google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
google search engines in india and
united states google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of seo now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're going to talk about on-page seo so
on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control
as an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do
is understand what keywords we want to
rank for in order to understand what
keywords we want to rank for we need to
do keyword research and if you do
anything in seo keyword research is the
most important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google is going to do
is they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that that appear
for both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 uh per month on average and so
what i want to do is get a more clear
picture of the competition and so what
you could actually do is type in the
syntax all in title and then colon and
then your keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist and when i
do that i get a different result here i
can see only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see
every one of them how to become a
digital marketing specialist and why is
that important because now that tells me
i only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
call and title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
bolder than anything else google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and the
meta description is simply just a brief
description
up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keywords you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist learning
path explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation is basically
links from one page on your website to
another and so here we can see on this
particular article how to become a
digital marketing specialist there's
also links to
other pages on simply learn's website
and so for this particular content it
also links to seo specialist ppc
specialist social media marketing
specialist and digital marketing
specialist so the whole idea behind
internal linking is to link from one
page to another where it's relevant and
in this case it's relevant because we're
talking about how to become a digital
marketing specialist that's what the
whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when i say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other key words in the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
on page seo is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there do
two types of sitemaps one is an html map
and that's designed for humans so if you
have a website with a lot of content at
the footer or the bottom of your web
page you probably want to have a link to
sitemap so if somebody clicks on that
site map they're going to be able to see
all the pages on your website structured
in an organized manner well an xml
sitemap and xml is just a different
format it's designed for crawlers and so
the whole idea remember is google likes
to crawl content when they crawl content
they bring it back to their servers and
index it and so we want to be able to
create a site map for google or other
search engine crawlers and so xml is the
format so let me show you example of how
that looks so if i go to simplylearn.com
and simply type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example i'm going to get this
particular page and this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these
sitemaps are there for google to go
ahead and crawl and nothing more than a
list of all the pages on your website
and so this is a quick and easy way for
google to get a hold of all those pages
so that they can index them and that's
the whole idea behind seo you want to be
able to have google index all the
content you want to be found for for the
keywords you want to be found for so it
all starts with the sitemap so let's go
from on-page seo which in recap is
basically optimizing certain elements on
your website so that you are relevant
for a particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're gonna switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off page seo
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to off
page seo and so off-page seo is simply
the process of linking or promoting your
website using link building and so if
you remember i talked about this earlier
on there's two types of links internal
and external linking and so for on-page
seo we used internal linking for
off-page seo we're going to talk about
external linking and external linking
allows us to improve our website's
recognition or relevancy or credibility
and why do we want to improve our
relevancy and credibility and
trustworthiness and authority because we
want google to know that our web page is
trustworthy it is recognized by other
websites and it is relevant for a
particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off page seo is synonymous
with link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
authority is going to improve and when
our domain authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialists on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to
off-page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits its drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off off-page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website link back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to
vegetables or other items that people
could link from so the whole idea is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content that you could
share so you can share your content with
them they can share their content with
you and generally that's how it works
naturally anyway in the web sphere if
somebody likes your content they're
going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents are quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo what is on page seo what is
off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords for page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one or two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end user it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something i didn't talk about it does
take time to rank your content so
remember the process you're going to
write your content you're going to
choose keywords you're going to change
the elements on that page for those
keywords and all the while you're going
to make sure google can crawl that
content and when they crawl they're
going to index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page seo and off-page
seo then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's user
friendly and mobile friendly so we
talked about responsive content earlier
so remember most users today start the
process of search on mobile so we want
to make sure your websites are mobile
friendly search engine optimization
starts with the keyword because we want
to be found for relevant keywords and so
the first step
and search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research
so it is the most important step and so
what is keyword research all about well
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best italian
restaurants or italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
based on the factor of how much traffic
or volume a particular search engine
query has and it's based on competition
and really the underlying factor here is
that all keywords in your keyword
research should be relevant so you need
to understand what those keywords are so
are they relevant to the content that
you want to be found for if they are
then really the two factors you want to
look for is the volume how much volume
or traffic each keyword has associated
with it and then the competition how
many other websites are trying to be
found for the same keyword so those are
the factors involved with keyword
research you always want to choose
relevant keywords and then once you find
or choose those relevant keywords you
want to be able to find out exactly how
much volume and how much competitions
associated with each of those keywords
and so when you look at keywords you're
always going to choose relevant keywords
but there are two types of keywords
there are short tail keywords and they
are long tail keywords and we're going
to talk about both of these here so
let's start with short tail keywords so
short tail keywords are generic keywords
generally they're less than three words
in a keyword phrase for example italian
restaurants so
short tail keywords generally
have very high search volume that means
that if somebody types in italian
restaurants then there's going to be a
large amount of volume with that meaning
that generally a lot of people type in
the keyword italian restaurants however
with high volume always comes high
competition so
if you want to be found for italian
restaurants know that you are ranked
number one or number two or even on page
one of google you're going to get a lot
of traffic however to get to page one of
google or even position one or two it's
going to take you a while because there
are probably a lot of websites who are
in front of you who want to be ranked
and found for the same keyword so the
whole idea with short tail keywords is
it's a lot of visibility it's a lot of
traffic a lot of volume but also a lot
of competition and generally the
underlying factor here is that if you
are ranked for a very broad or short
tail keyword like italian restaurants
then chances are it's not going to be as
relevant so if you get the traffic to
your website then chances are the
conversion's not necessarily going to
happen because we don't necessarily know
the mindset of somebody typing in a very
short tail generic keyword like italian
restaurants they could be doing research
on italian restaurants they could be a
chef who's trying to get recipes for
italian food it could be a tourist
looking for italian restaurants in a
different city or it could be a person
just looking for italian restaurants
near their location or where they're
living and so there's a lot of different
factors with short tail keywords so you
just don't know because it's so generic
and because it's so generic if you do
get the traffic for that generic keyword
then the chances of the conversion are
going to be lower than say if it's a
more specific relevant keyword so let's
take an example
of a short tail keyword let's just stick
with italian restaurants so i'm going to
go to
a tool called moz and well moz has a
tool called the keyword explorer and
within moz so if you go to moz.com and
then use the keyword explorer you can
get an idea of how much volume and
competition are associated with a
particular keyword so in this example
we're using italian restaurants it's a
very broad keyword we could see that the
monthly volume is between 70 000 and 118
000 per month okay so that means for a
particular keyword in the united states
on a search engine you're going to get
about 70 000 to 118 000 people who type
in that keyword and so if we were to
look at the difficulty of that keyword
you could see
that it's fairly difficult because out
of 1 to 100 it's got to score 43 so it's
fairly difficult however if you notice
the click-through rate's very high so
moz estimates that we'll have a 40
organic click-through rate for that
keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to
longer tail keywords however if you want
the visibility then you want to use
short tail keywords if you want the
conversion then you want to switch over
to longer tail keywords so longer tail
keywords are more specific they usually
consist of more than three keywords so
tie in restaurants very generic if we
add a few more keywords that keyword
phrase it then becomes longer tail so
compared to short tail keywords longer
tail keywords are generally less
competitive and the search volume is not
as high case in point so if we go back
to moz and then we look at the keyword
explorer and we'd actually type in
italian restaurants and let's just say
orlando florida
moz is going to
generate some monthly volume for us and
they're going to allow us to understand
how difficult that keyword is and so
here you could see very very little
search volume in fact so little volume
there's 11 to 50 okay so that means on
average that this keyword generates 11
to 50 queries a month so very low
compared to our short tail keyword
italian restaurants the difficulty here
didn't necessarily lessen but it is less
uh
so if you're interested in conversions
and you have an italian restaurant in
say orlando florida then this is the key
word you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in the top in florida
branded shoes in florida something very
specific is going to generate probably a
higher conversion rate than something
more generic so that's the trade-off and
so when to use long tail keywords well
we want to use long tail keywords if
we're targeting pages with a product or
specific article so if we're interested
in that particular conversion then
longer tail keywords are likely more the
way we want to go versus something more
generic which means if you're using a
generic shorter tail keyword you're more
interested in the visibility and the
traffic not necessarily the conversion
how does a search engine work so let's
talk about that for a minute so we know
that millions of people use search
engines we know that we want to be found
on search engines but how do we actually
get our content in the search engine so
that's the important part that we need
to understand if we have our own website
and we have our content so these search
engines want your content in their
search engine index so how do they get
your content well they send out bots or
files and we'll just call them spiders
so they send out these spiders to crawl
your website and the whole idea behind
using the insect spider is because we're
talking about the world wide web and so
if google for example sends a bot to
your website they're going to crawl your
website in spite of your website they're
creating a web of pages so all they're
doing is following link and every page
and link that they hit they're going to
bring back to their server so these
spiders scan your websites they just
follow links and they take all the pages
and content that they're able to gather
when they hit your website and they're
going to pull all that information back
into their own index so if you think
about google they're crawling or
spidering millions and billions of
websites all those millions and millions
of websites are sitting on google
servers so when somebody does do a
search query google because they have
all these websites in their index are
able to quickly determine which website
is the most relevant for that search
engine query so that's generally how
search engines work so let's talk about
the types of seo so if we want our
website to be found on these search
engines and google or the search engines
have crawled our website then what we
want to do is we want to basically look
at it from a two-pronged perspective
it's a two-pronged strategy so the first
strategy we're going to talk about today
is on-page seo so those are on-page seos
defined as what we do on our website to
be relevant for search engine query on a
search engine so again on-page seo is
what we do to our own website off-page
seo is the other the second part of that
seo strategy and off-page seo determines
what we do off our website to be
relevant for search engine query and so
off-page seo generally is synonymous
with link building and we'll talk about
that a little bit more as we go forward
but really when you want to do seo when
you want to be found for
a keyword on a search engine you're
going to have to apply both on-page seo
and off-page seo so let's talk about
on-page seo and so this is the first
part of our seo effort we want to focus
on on-page seo first and so on page seo
is the method of optimizing elements of
web pages remember these are all the
items we want to do on our website to be
relevant for certain search queries so
it's basically the idea behind this is
to make our web pages more relevant
for specific search queries on search
engines and so there are a number of
different elements on our website on a
particular web page that we want to
manipulate or optimize if you will to be
relevant for search engine query and so
let's start around the idea that you
know you there's a number of things you
can do so let's start with schema first
and so schema is nothing more than it's
a collaborative effort between bing
yahoo baidu
google and the idea is really they want
to understand more about the content of
your website and so the idea behind this
is that you want to be able to provide
snippets of information to these search
engines so they understand a little bit
more about what your web page is trying
to portray or convey so that they can
find out exactly what's relevant to that
search engine query so it's nothing more
than micro data or bits of information
that you can add to your website or web
page in order to provide a little bit
more enhanced information to the search
engines so if you think about it's
collaborating with the search engine so
the more basic information you share
with the search engines the better off
they have to understand what your web
page your website is all about and so
the more information they have the
better of an opportunity you have to be
ranked for that search engine query and
so if you have a website with reviews if
you have a website with images if you
have let's say a website with products
with prices in other words you have an
e-commerce website and you're trying to
sell products well to me you want to
employ schema because again schema is
snippets of information that are
provided to the search engine so they
can better understand so
you can certainly provide snippets of
information in the terms of images or
prices or particular products and how
much is left in stock so all this
information these bits of information
you can provide to the search engine so
that they can better understand what it
is you're trying to sell how much it
cost how much is in inventory what
people think about the product etc so if
you have a website that sell products
you probably want to employ schema and
so when you do employ schema again
snippets of information provided to the
search engines the search engines are
going to better understand and then
they're going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have ratings and reviews you
can provide snippets of information to
the search engines the search engines in
turn are going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have positive reviews then
somebody typing in in this example shoes
they're going to be able to see that you
have positive reviews for your website
so that's the whole idea behind schema
is to provide snippets of information so
again it's not just related to reviews
also for images so if you have images
you can provide snippets of information
to the search engine so they can see you
know what the shoe actually looks like
when they type in in this example puma
shoes or like i mentioned inventory
snippets of information about your
inventory the search engines are going
to provide that information search
engine results so if somebody's looking
for women's training shoes or women's
puma shoes and they see your product and
they see oh this is in stock great let
me go to this website and purchase these
shoes so that's the whole idea behind
schema is making sure you present
information critical to your website so
that the search engines better
understand what your website's all about
it also helps with relevancy because the
more those search engines know about
your website the more relevant your
website becomes and the better chance
you have to rank for a particular
keyword there's also some other
information here involved with schema
and those are site links so site links
additional pages on your website okay
that show up in the search engine result
and so again the more information a
search engine has about you the better
chance you have to be found the better
chance you have to get a click so site
links are just additional links on your
site that appear in search engine
results and that's all a benefactor of
having schema so here you can see in
this example we have additional web
pages that show under a certain search
engine result and so by having more
links in the search engine results you
have a better chance of getting the
click so if you want more information
about schema i would recommend going to
schema.org so when you go to schema.org
you can actually click on a link that
allows you to see all the information
you need to get started
with schema.org okay so it's got a lot
of information available to you it
describes what it is you have to do in
order to
get your information and set for the
search engines to better understand
focus on for on page seo is title tag
and so title tag is what shows up in the
search engine results so if you've ever
done a search engine query meaning
you've gone to google typed in a query
using a keyword like italian restaurants
you're going to see specific search
engine results and the title tag is what
appears in those search engine results
so a title tag is important because it's
the title of a web page that appears in
those results and so the title tag is
something that's important because if we
want to be found for a specific keyword
we want to make sure that keyword is in
the title tag because that keyword is
going to describe what the page is all
about and so if we want to be found for
that keyword let's just say italian
restaurants in florida for example
that's going to be part of our title tag
so when somebody types in that
particular keyword query italian
restaurants in florida then we have a
good chance of showing up because the
title tag which is the title of the page
is going to have that particular query
in it and so you can edit the title tag
and when you edit the title tag you want
to be able to put that particular
keyword in the title tag so if we do a
search on google for example so if i go
to google.com and i type in italian
restaurants in florida
here i can see under the local search
results and here i can see italian
restaurants in florida central florida
italian restaurants and miami so you can
see that these are highlighted so the
title tag is not only stands out but
allows you to
you know showcase exactly what your page
is all about and it helps with the
relevancy of that keyword query so when
you're trying to optimize your website
using the title tag for specific keyword
you want to keep in mind a couple
parameters because title tags show up in
the search engine results but
certain search engines particularly
google has character limits around the
number of characters you can use in the
title tag and so we want to keep that in
mind so
ideally we want to format our title tag
appropriately and so to me the most
optimal way to optimize a title tag
using a particular keyword that you want
to be found for is to use that keyword
in the title tag and then separate that
with your brand name so if you actually
have two keywords then you can use the
primary keyword first then the secondary
keyword and then the brand name so to me
this is the most optimal format but keep
in mind there are character limits but
if you look at this format to me it's
the most easiest format to abide by
because it makes your title tag more
relevant you don't have to worry about
necessarily fitting in excess keywords
in the title tag because again the title
tag is character limits so if we take a
look at our example in google search
results if you go over those limits and
the title tag is generally between 60
and 65 characters long and so if you go
over those limits let's just say your
title tag is more than 65 characters
google in this case is going to cut off
the characters and so here you can see
the ellipses after the title tag now if
you follow the format that you know we
at simply learn recommend you could see
if our keyword is italian restaurants in
florida and then separated by the brand
name this gives you an optimal format
for the title tag it also makes it
relevant for the keyword query so you
want to keep that title tag probably no
more than 60 characters because if you
flirt with putting more than 60
characters then the search engines are
going to cut off that title tag and then
that's not going to look good and it's
going to also become less relevant so we
want to keep the character counts in
mind so if you abide by that format of
the keyword and then maybe the secondary
keyword if you have one separated by the
brand name then you should be good to go
with making sure your title tag is
relevant for that keyword query so let's
then turn our attention to the meta
description so the meta description is
just a short description about the
content on your web page so if the title
tag is the title of the web page the
meta description describes the page okay
so it's a description about what that
page is so the meta description appears
under the title tag and then the url so
if we go back to our google search
results we look here at italian
restaurants in florida maggiano's little
italy is the brand or the restaurant we
could see the url which is underneath
the title tag and then here we could see
the meta description and so with the
meta description you have a little bit
more room to work with in terms of
character count but the meta description
just like the title tag is just as
important because one it shows up in the
search engine results two it describes
what the page is all about and three it
allows you to optimize the meta
description so the meta description
becomes more relevant for that search
query that somebody types into that
particular search engine so the optimal
length for a meta description you can go
up to 300 characters but i would not
even recommend even flirting with that
limit because just like the title tag
search engines in the case of google
will actually cut off the meta
description so if we look here back at
our search results if you go over those
limits you'll see that the search
engines will cut off the copy of the
meta description with and they'll just
put ellipses so we don't necessarily
want to
go over those lemons so my
recommendation is to keep that meta
description probably 165
characters to to no more than 200
because we're trying to
describe not only what the page is all
about but we're also trying to optimize
that meta description so it becomes
relevant for the search engine query and
so you want to keep it short and concise
so if we look at our example here
italian restaurants in florida magiano's
does a good job it's a book and event
space make a reservation at maggiano's
in florida to enjoy delicious view maps
menus and more so
very concise meta description it
includes their keyword query that they
want to be found for italian restaurants
in florida and so to me it's short and
concise describes what the page is all
about and
uh
allows them to fit it all in within the
character limits so here in this example
we want to be found for amazon puma
shoes so the brand here is amazon so
amazon wants to include puma shoes not
only in the title tag but they want to
try and fit that into the meta
description however the whole idea
behind the meta description more than
anything else is describe what the page
is all about okay you want to be
relevant for the search engine query but
you also want to sound natural as well
you want to be able to
really the whole idea between the title
tag and amount of description is to get
people to click on your link because
remember there are nine other listings
on the google search engine results page
for page one so we want our meta
description and our title tag to stand
out so we want it to be relevant but we
want it to stand out so it's important
you write that meta description
according to what the page is all about
but you want it to stand out uniquely
and accordingly so once you've done the
title tag and the meta description you
want to focus your attention on the
header tag and so header tags are used
on a web page to really separate out
content and so you have headers and
subheaders and so ideally you want to be
able to optimize the header tag and the
subheader and so if we think about
headers there's a hierarchy for headers
so there's between a header one and a
header six and so we'll just shorten the
word header and we'll call it an h1 so
h1 is really at the top of the hierarchy
for headers and so if we use a h1 on our
web page then what we're trying to
explain to the search engines is listen
this particular
keyword phrase in our header is is a
header and we're empha we're trying to
emphasize what it is we're trying to say
and that's how really the search engines
interpret headers they see an h1 h2 h3
h4 h5 and h6 they know that if you're
using an h1 you're trying to really
emphasize something so if you put that
keyword in the header tag what you're
telling the search engines is hey i'm
really emphasizing this particular
keyword and so the search engine will
interpret that as important and if you
use your keyword in that header then
really what you're saying is hey i
really this keyword is really relevant
to that query so naturally the other
benefit of a header is it really breaks
up the page as well so
the header you can use subheaders and
subheaders are nothing more than say a
lower h tag so if you have a header
that's an h1 you can use an h2 and h3 as
a subheader and so forth and so on
because what you're really trying to do
is not only organize the content on your
web page but you're trying to emphasize
that for google so if something's an h2
or an h6 you're basically telling google
or the other search engines this is not
as important as say in h1 so if we take
a look at our example that we've been
using for italian restaurants in florida
and if we click on magianas we could see
that they're using headers so if we
click on maggiano's we could see that
this is a header here we want to bring
everyone together at maggiano's italian
restaurant in florida so they're using
that header to break up the text here
you can see they're using another header
here excellent italian food and an
excellent experience to match so that's
a header to break up the content okay
they're not using subheaders they're
used using headers but that's fine
they're really trying to emphasize the
content by putting in that header and so
headers help not only organize the
content but they help emphasize the
actual keyword it is you want google to
recognize so if we're not sure if
something is a header we could simply
just mouse over what we think is a
header and we can just right click and
if you right click on something you're
going to see a menu and if we click
inspect element then basically what that
browser in this case firefox is going to
do is show us the html of that
particular thing of that item that we
right clicked so here we could see in
this particular case this is an h2 tag
so it's an h2 so if we scroll down and
we mouse over this we could see this is
also an h2 as well so this particular
page is using h2 tags not h1 but in h2
so what they're explaining or trying to
convey to the search engines is listen
this is an h2 it's still
relevant we're still trying to put
emphasis on it but not as much so we
want to be able to use our h1s and our
h2s accordingly so remember in h1 is
you're providing the search engines with
information by telling them hey this is
the most relevant this is we're putting
emphasis on this keyword and h2 nuts as
much as an h1 and an h3 not as much as
an h2 so use your headers accordingly uh
not only just to break up the text not
only for styling but for emphasis for
the search engines so headers are very
important elements for on-page seo okay
let's turn our attention to the url
structure okay so url stands for uniform
resource locator and so our url is the
specific location of a web page on the
internet so basically if we're found in
the search engine results one of our web
pages are going to go along with the
title tag and the meta description in
the search engine results page so if i
go back to our search engine results for
italian restaurants in florida we could
see that the particular url in question
here is locations.magianos.com
florida so that's the url that shows up
along with the title tag in the meta
description so if we click on that link
that's exactly where we're going to go
so url structure is important for
on-page seo so why is it important
because not only does it show people
where they're going but we have an
opportunity to optimize that url for the
search engines to make our url more
relevant for that search query so just
like the title tag just like the meta
description just like the headers we can
also manipulate the url so if we look at
a url it consists of really the protocol
and the protocol means it's either a
secure site or non-secure site so in
this example we could see it's https and
that means it's a secure site and so
ideally search engines like web pages or
websites that are secure so after the
protocol you're going to see the domain
and then after the domain you're going
to see
subdirectories okay so that's generally
the breakout with
url structures you have the protocol the
domain and subdirectories and then you
may have more subdirectories so if we go
back to the example we've been working
with if i go back to maggiano's you can
see here this is a secure site https you
could see the domain in this case it's
actually a sub domain so
magianos.com is the domain but they
decided to put
locations.magianos.com and that's okay
we call that a subdomain and then here
you can see they have one particular
subdirectory after the domain and that's
florida so a well structured url not
only provides the users with information
about where they're going when they
click on your link in the search engine
results but more importantly it also
provides the search engines and some
information about what the web page is
all about so going back to our simple
example with maggiano's the search
engines know that hey if somebody clicks
on this link they're going to a page
about florida pretty simple the url
structure is pretty simple to understand
we know it's a secure site we know it's
maggianos.com and we know the subpage is
florida or the subdirectory is florida
you want to be careful like everything
else since and seo there are parameters
just like the title tag has parameters
up to 65 characters the meta description
tag has a limit of up to 165 characters
a well structured url also has character
counts but the idea here is we don't
want to get into numbers when we talk
about character counts for url structure
really the rule of thumb or the best
practice for url is to keep it short and
understandable okay if we keep it clear
and concise not only does the end user
know where they're going but the search
engines know what the page is all about
so the rule of thumb is always if you
don't understand the url or what it
means then the search engines are likely
not going to understand what the url
means we want to keep the number of
directors and subdirectories to a limit
so ideally here you can see in this
example xyz.com
if we want to optimize that url we could
put the targeted keyword in the url if
we'd like to but we want to keep it
probably to a minimum of one to two
subdirectories the shorter this the
amount of subdirectories the better off
we are because that means that not only
the end user will understand the url but
the search engines will understand the
url as well so we always want to make
sure that url is readable again for the
end user and the search engine and so in
this example you can see amazon.com
slash men's shoes slash sneakers slash
puma very easy understand as an end user
i know that i'm going to a puma page uh
for men on amazon.com now when you get
into urls with
dynamic parameters in them then ideally
you as an end user is not going to
really know where you're going to go so
in the example here the middle example i
can see that i'm going maybe to a shoes
page but i have no idea what the rest
that url means and in the other example
where you have a very low url
readability i have no idea as an end
user where i'm going to go so as an end
user i need to be able to have
confidence in knowing where i'm going to
go once i click on a link in the search
engine results so if i don't have that
confidence if i don't understand what
the url is then you then the search
engines aren't going to understand as
well and it's not going to bode well in
terms of relevancy and again the url
structure is important factor for being
relevant and if we're not relevant then
the chances of us are ranking higher is
not going to be as good because our url
is not readable so ideally what we want
to do is make sure we're using keywords
that the end user and the search engines
understand and if we need to separate
out those keywords in the first example
we could see men's shoes we want to
separate that out with a hyphen and so
ideally if you have a url that's
readable and it's short and concise then
again your chances of ranking higher on
the search engine results page bodes
better than if you have a very long
antiquated unreadable url so let's focus
our attention on
image alt text or alt tags if you will
so alt tags or text tags as they're also
known as allow uh the search engines to
understand a little bit more about
what's on the page in terms of images so
images are
a prominent part of every web page on
the internet unfortunately images are
you know usually files that are not
readable by search engines so we want to
be able to provide some alternate text
so that the search engines understand
what those images are all about so again
it gives us an opportunity to
communicate with the search engines so
that they better understand what the
image is all about to make the page more
relevant so generally if an image fails
to load on a web page as an example well
if you have an alt tag then the alt tag
is going to show in place of the image
not loading more importantly if we have
an alt tag and the search engines have
spidered our website and somebody's
actually searching for images then the
alt tag is used as a descriptor for the
image so it also helps us get found for
the images on search engine results
pages and so like everything else we've
talked about with on-page seo there are
character limits to all tags you know
generally the rule of thumb is 125
characters for an alt tag and the alt
tag is used in the html so we want to
surround our image with an alt tag by
putting in a descriptor and so ideally
if you're trying to be found for a
particular search engine query then you
want to use the search engine query as
part of the alt tag and so let me show
you an example here going back to
maggiano's if we look at their web page
and we actually inspect one of their
images on this web page if we look at
for example a pinterest or facebook we
can actually see in this example that
the image here
has an alt tag it's pinterest and so you
want to be able again to put in all tags
for all your images so it better
communicates with the search engines
what the image is all about it also
allows the search engines to rank images
in the search engine results based on
that alt text and what the keyword query
was so all tags play an important role
because again if the image doesn't load
on the web page for some reason then the
alt tag is there as a replacement it's
also there to help the search engines
rank those images and understand the
page a little bit better so you always
want to be able to put in the keyword
query that you're trying to be found for
in the alt tag and so be as descriptive
as possible you have 125 characters to
use so b is descriptive make it easy to
read because again this is what's going
to show up in the search engine results
pages for images okay let's turn our
attention to internal links so when it
comes to seo internal links also play a
vital role because basically an internal
link which is a link from one page of
your website to another page of your
website um allows google to or other
search engines really to follow the
pages as they index your entire website
so it serves that purpose of allowing
search engines to index so it definitely
improves the indexing but internal
linking also has many benefits and one
of the other benefits is it helps
spreads what we call link choose and so
link juice is basically a way another
way of saying you know this page is
important because it has links from
other pages on our website so
if we link i have a link from one page
to another and
a couple of other pages on our site
linked to that same page then search
engines tend to take notice and they
tend to note that you know if one
particular page has a number of
different links pointing to it then this
page may be important and so that's what
we mean by link jews it's a signal for
the search engine to determine what
pages on your website are important
because of the links that point to it
and so if we look at this example here
we could see that you know there's
usually a navigation on a website that
point two pages and
every page on a website tends to have a
link but if more than one page has
multiple links then again that signals
to the search engines that hey you know
this particular page seems to be
important because it has a lot of links
pointing to it our attention is sitemaps
so sitemaps basically allow us to list
all the web pages on our website so we
could do that in a couple of different
ways but when we do it it basically is
going to and help the search engines
find our pages easier just as i
mentioned a minute ago about internal
linking when you have one link pointing
to another page on your website it helps
the search engines find these pages
quicker while sitemaps do the same thing
except sitemaps are an entire list of
links on your website and it allows the
site search engines to find all your
pages in your website fairly easily but
it also helps the end user too so if you
have a big website like amazon has a
huge website with a lot of different
products well if you're looking for a
particular product you can do a search
for it or you can look at the site map
and the sitemap will list all the
particular pages on the site and so it's
also good for the end user as well so
when we talk about the end user and we
talk about search engines they're really
two different types of site maps you got
the html version which is for the end
user that's going to be nothing more
than a link on the website usually in
the footer and so when you click on that
site map link you'll get a list of all
the links on the website okay so that's
an html sitemap then we have the sitemap
for the search engines you know the
spiders that want to crawl our site so
that's the xml sitemap and xml is just a
different format it's just a way to
format all the links on our website so
the html sitemap is html written in
hypertext markup language designed for
the end user if you click on it it helps
the end user navigate the website
quickly because they can find what
they're looking for and so generally
that is an html now if we turn our
attention to the xml sitemap that's
basically designed for search engines
and thing about the search the xml site
map is we work with google to go ahead
and and and submit the sitemap to google
so google can quickly understand what
pages on our website so for example if i
went to a website let's just say
valleyfig.com
so if i went here and if i'm a search
engine i'm going to want to know all the
urls that are on this website well as an
end user i can also just type in
sitemap.xml
usually that's the xml file where all
the urls are located and here i can see
all of the urls on valleyfig.com and so
the idea behind an xml sitemap is we
want to communicate that xml file to the
search engines and so google in
particular has what they call a search
console and search console if you go to
google.com webmasters so search console
is a way to communicate with google and
one of the ways to communicate with
google is to submit a sitemap so we want
to submit our xml sitemap so if our xml
site map is located in the root
directory so after our domain
valleyfig.com
sitemap.xml we know that that file is
sitting in the root directory i can go
into search console and i can submit my
sitemap and when i submit my sitemap
then i'm basically communicating with
google telling google hey
google instead of trying to find all our
web pages on our website when you crawl
the website we're going to go ahead and
submit the sitemap to you so we're going
to tell you all the pages on our website
and so by doing that by submitting our
sitemap.xml file to google it speeds up
the process because google's able to now
understand all the pages on our website
that have been submitted and then once
we submit those pages then google is
going to quickly index a majority of
those pages if not all of those pages
and so that's the benefit of having an
xml site map for the search engines is
that we can quickly submit that file to
the search engine so our pages get
submitted and indexed quicker so
continuing on with on-page seo we now
turn our attention to page speed and so
page speed also known as page low time
of a particular page of a particular
website is important for seo why is it
important because
google has millions of users use their
search engine and google wants their
users to have a good experience and so
if google ranks websites based on
relevancy they also want to take into
account page speed because if a website
does not load fast or web page doesn't
load fast then it would be detrimental
for google to rank that page high
because what's going to happen is that
page is going to get a number of clicks
and then the user experience is not
going to be that great and so therefore
it's going to have a negative impact not
only in the end user but google as well
and so page load time then becomes
important for on-page seo so
really when it comes to page load time
we really want to pay attention to how
long it takes our web pages to load in
terms of seconds because if a page loads
slow then chances are the user
experience is not going to be good even
from an analytics perspective meaning if
i go to
google type in a query click on a link
and then it's that link takes me to a
website where the web page loads very
slow chances are i'm not going to spend
a lot of time waiting for that page to
load i'm going to leave that page and if
i leave the page then it's going to
cause up what they call a bounce so i'm
going to bounce from the page and that's
just not good for the entire search
ecosystem and so we want to pay close
attention to page load time because the
faster a site or page loads google's
going to recognize that and that's going
to help with ranking and so how do we
understand how our pages load well we
can look no further than web analytics
tool like google analytics for example
so if we turn our attention to google
analytics if i go to say valleyfig.com
analytics account i can look over the
last 30 days and i can see okay on
average our page average page load time
for the entire site was five seconds
around five seconds and ideally we want
our pages load as quick as possible i
would say the rule of thumb on page load
time is probably no more than three to
four seconds okay but there are factors
involved with page load time so a couple
of factors are the browser that people
use so some browsers load pages
differently than other browsers the
other factor involved with browsers is
the device so you could be on a mobile
device and say internet explorer versus
on a desktop using chrome and you're
going to have variation in terms of
average page load time so definitely
browser device plays a role but also
country plays a role the infrastructure
how much bandwidth is available so you
could be in say san francisco united
states and be on a high-speed network
versus another city or another country
where you're not necessarily on the same
high speed network you're on a lower
bandwidth or lower network and that's
going to affect the page load time as
well so in analytics you can actually
see the breakdown of time per country
and then of course the page itself so
when we talk about average page load
time for a website we're talking about
the average for the entire site but we
can actually look at in google analytics
the average low time for every page on
the site so ideally if you have a
particular page you want to rank
organically in the search engines and
the average page load time is not
suitable or it's very high then you want
to address what the issues are and so
the great thing about google analytics
is you actually have speed suggestions
so if i go to speed suggestions in
google analytics i'm going to be able to
see the average load time for certain
pages on the site and then what google's
going to do is actually give me
some feedback so for example i can see
that
the home page loads about
5.59 seconds and so if i click on page
speed suggestions then google is going
to give me suggestions on how to speed
up the page load time not only on
desktop but on mobile as well so when
you click on page speed suggestions
you're actually going to go to a tool a
google tool called page speed insights
and then page speed insights is going to
allow you to see how quick your page
loads and then it's going to be able to
give you feedback on what to do in order
to speed up the page load time not only
for the page but for the site and the
great thing again is you can see it for
desktop and you can see it from mobile
so page speed is important we want to be
able to keep our page load time low
no more than probably again three to
four seconds because if it's any more
than that google's going to take notice
the other search engines are going to
take notice and they're not going to
want to rank that particular page high
on google so some ways to increase your
page speed you always want to optimize
your images you never want to have
images that take a long time to load you
want to use a simple website design now
i know flash as an example has long been
disbanded but you don't want to use
other technology that's really going to
slow the page load time of course where
your website is hosted does matter so
the server it's hosted on could be
shared with other websites and so that
may eat into how quick the server
responds to people trying to load your
web page and so you want to keep that in
mind so server response time does play a
factor in loading and then of course
optimizing your code you want to never
have unnecessary code on your website
and when i say unnecessary code some
examples could be tracking code if
you're doing any search advertising
let's just say on facebook or bing you
try to want to minimize the amount of
extra code you put on a site because
that code has to execute and that eats
into the page load time so you want to
be cognizant of how much code you put on
your website because that will eat into
the page load time so let's talk about
featured snippets so featured snippets
is the search result that generally
shows uh up at the top of the search
engine organic results so it's
informational content and you'll see it
above organic results but you'll also
see it below search advertising and so
some of the common featured snippets you
may see are in the form of a paragraph a
table
or a list and so
paragraph snippets tend to be the most
popular and let me show an example of a
featured snippet so if i go to
say google.com and type in machine
learning here you can see some paid
search ads okay and why do i know
they're paid search ads because i can
see ad next to them but if i look below
the paid search ads but above the
organic search results i see a paragraph
feature snippet and this is nothing more
than again just some an informational
content about machine learning and
really
the whole idea behind
featured snippets is really they're just
informational and really it's
informational and and what google likes
to do is pull content in there that
really answers a question so if your
content doesn't necessarily answer
question then you can't expect your
content to show up as a featured snippet
so the whole idea is with the search
engines is really google searches
through a number of different sites to
find content that will best answer a
user's question like for example what is
machine learning okay so if we ask the
question what is machine learning we can
expect to find a feature snippet and so
really what users do a lot when they
type in a query they use prefixes like
how does or how do or how to or what is
and so those types of questions are
normally asked as part of the search
query so if you could answer those
questions then
generally google's gonna recognize that
and if it's relevant it's gonna show up
as a featured snippet so the whole idea
is to really create truly high quality
content so
about feature snippets is if you have
true high quality content that answers a
question then chances are your content
may show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is you know work to create
high quality content that provides a
really good answer to really basic
question it could be anything what is
machine learning what is a fig you know
how to ride a bicycle how do i surf all
these are related questions that content
can answer and google wants to make sure
as part of a featured snippet that they
provide content that answers that
question and not just content the best
content that does the the best job with
the most relevant information answer
that person search query so here we can
see our three examples you have a table
format so if we want to type in aviation
jobs we can see snippets of information
about the latest job listings for
aviation you can see in the middle
screenshot what is machine learning so
that's our paragraph featured snippet
and then if you type in something like
building a fence it's going to give you
a list of you know ways to go about
building a fence so these are all
answers to questions the query may not
necessarily be in question form but the
snippet is there just in case you want
to know more information about that
particular query so generally that's how
featured snippets work and the great
thing about featured snippets it's open
to everybody the key is to have quality
content if you have quality content that
provides answers to questions then
chances are your content can show up
above organic search results which will
give you more visibility drive a lot
more traffic to your site and quality
traffic because likely it's answering
somebody's question so let's do a a
recap of everything we talked about with
on-page seo so before we move on off
page remember on-page seo is what we do
to our website to enhance our website to
be found in the search engines for
relevant keywords so it's all about
relevancy and remember before you do
anything to your website you need to
start with the basics of keyword
research you need to find keywords that
are highly relevant that have volume and
low competition and so when you can
focus on your keywords and you find out
and finalize what keywords you want to
be found for then you're going to
conduct on-page seo on-page seo consists
of number of different factors some of
which we talked about today starting
with schema remember we want to have
structured data to better communicate
with the search engines what our web
pages are about then we talked about
title tags so title tags appear in
search results remember 65 characters we
want to make sure our keyword is in the
title tag followed by our brand name and
then we talked about meta descriptions
meta descriptions allow us to you know
talk specifically about what that page
is all about meta descriptions fall
under the title tag in the search
results we talked about headers h1
through h6 h1 being the biggest in the
hierarchy of headers and having an h1
tag with your keyword provides the
search engines with an identity of how
strong or how important something is on
a page it also organizes the page with
headers and subheaders and it breaks up
the content so it's easily
understandable by the end user we also
talked about alt tags so remember images
on its own are not recognized by search
engines so we want to surround those
images with all tags with words that
help the search engines identify what
that image is they also serve a purpose
in the browser if an image doesn't load
then we can actually see what the image
is all about with the alt tag we talked
about feature snippets there are lists
okay there are paragraphs okay there are
different types of snippets and really
the whole idea again behind snippets is
answering a question with quality
content we talked about page speed
identifying how quick our pages load in
google analytics so if your pages don't
load very quickly then google actually
provides suggestions to speed up the
page load time of a particular page and
some of the culprits that you want to
look at are making sure you have images
that are good quality but also not a lot
in size you want to make sure they're
optimized you want to look at your
server response time you want to make
sure you optimize code so there's a lot
of different factors of page load time
you just want to keep an eye on what
pages are are not loading quick enough
and remember we want to keep it as low
as possible but no more than three to
four seconds we talked about internal
linking internal linking to a particular
page from one page to another provides
link juice and link juice is nothing
more than an indicator for the search
engines to identify what pages tend to
be more important than another based on
the number of links pointing to that
page and then we also talked about site
maps so we talked about the two types of
sitemaps html and xml html is for the
end user xml is primarily for the search
engines xml generally is going to be a
file called sitemap.xml and we could
take that xml file and submit it to
google search console and so that
expedites the process of indexing your
site and helps your site not only get
indexed faster but will help google
understand
how many pages are on your site and then
get those pages indexed so that they can
be found so that you can generate
traffic so all these are factors with
on-page seo that you want to address
before you move on to off-page seo okay
let's
turn our attention to off-page seo now
that we covered all the essentials for
on-page we still need to focus our
attention on off page remember earlier i
mentioned that seo is a two-pronged
approach we have to focus on on-page seo
first and then to complement our efforts
and to continue our efforts and to
continue the effort of being relevant
for certain keywords we need to do what
we call off-page seo and those are our
actions we take that don't involve our
website directly meaning we've already
updated the title tag the meta
description the alt tags the headers etc
we want to do things off our website
that's going to allow google and other
search engines to recognize that hey we
are relevant these pages are relevant
for certain keywords on our website and
so really when we talk about off page
seo it's really the technique of
promoting your website using link
building when we say
technique of promoting our website using
link building that means establishing
links on other websites that's what we
mean by link building and so
establishing links on other websites
really
enhances our seo efforts because it
improves first and foremost it improves
the credibility of our website so
if we're on a
you know a very popular website that is
known to be reputable
then having a link pointing from that
website to ours just improves the
credibility of our own website
not necessarily in the minds of the
search engine but in the minds of the
end user uh the other benefit here is it
increases our domain authority and let's
take a minute to talk about domain
authority so domain authority is simply
just a score between 1 and 100 and so in
digital marketing even including seo as
a marketing channel everything's
measurable and we want to be able to
measure everything we do digitally and
so off page seo is measurable one of the
metrics involved with off page seo is
domain authority in other words it's a
score between one and one
for our domain so how does google how
does baidu how do these other search
engines see our domain how authoritative
is our domain how reputable is our
domain and so having links on other
websites pointing to our domain
increases our
reputability increases our authority and
so i'm going to show you an example so
if you remember back on on page seo i
when we were talking about keyword
research we use a tool called moz
moz.com and i would recommend using
moz.com to measure domain authority so
if we go to moz.com
and moz.com has a tool called link
explorer so if you put in your domain
using their tool link explorer you're
going to be able to see your domain
authority and domain authority is a
score between 1 and 100 and basically
it's simply just scoring your website in
terms of authority how does the search
engine see your site out on the world
wide web the higher the score the better
and so
recommend using moz.com link explorer to
measure their domain authority so the
more
links we have on external sites pointing
to our own site in theory the higher the
domain authority so we're going to come
back to
moz.com quite frequently as we talk
about off-page seo because we need a
tool to help manage our efforts so we're
going to come back to moz.com but let's
let's talk about some of these other
benefits to off-page seo so we know it
helps with the credibility and increases
our domain authority but what are some
of the other intangible efforts that are
also measurable well it increases our
referral traffic and by increasing our
referral traffic meaning if we're on a
reputable site that gets a lot of
traffic and there's a link pointing our
site then naturally we're probably going
to see traffic coming from that site and
we can measure that in tools like google
analytics we can measure referral
traffic and so that's an inherent
benefit to doing off-page seo because
we're trying to create the relevancy of
our own website we're trying to be found
for relevant keywords but yet at the
same time we can increase traffic to our
website and then certainly not lost in
all this
is improving our page rank so the idea
here is you need on-page and off-page
seo to work together to improve our
rankings and improving our rankings in
the search engine results will
inherently
increase our rankings and drive traffic
to the site from search engines and
that's ideally what we're trying to do
we're trying to accomplish traffic from
search engines by improving our rankings
but at the same time we improve our
credibility and we accrue improve our
standing in the search engine world and
we also increase traffic to our site
from all these other websites and so
there are a lot of benefits to off-page
seo um it's just let's talk a little bit
more about some of these other benefits
because according to a backlinko a web
page with more backlinks is going to
rank higher than a page with fewer
backlinks but let me just say this with
back linking especially from sites it's
all about credibility it's all about
quality over quantity so we want to pay
attention to quality over quantity so
let's harken back to moz.com
and here we could see
we have a domain authority of 35 but we
have a lot of links inbound links from
other websites pointing to our website
we have
575 domains out there on the internet
pointing to our domain valleyfig.com
and so if we want to take a specific
look at these domains we can just simply
click on linking domains and here we can
see all the different domains pointing
to our
website
now again it's about quality not
quantity so if we look at the domain
authority and that's a score that
measures the credibility of a website we
could see the domain authority on some
of these
domains like npr.org has a domain
authority of 93 and so to me
that helps boost the domain authority
for our own website our own domain it
also has the chance of driving that
traffic it also increases the
credibility but in the end having
quality links from other quality domains
is going to increase our own rank on
search engines and that's the whole idea
behind it so we could actually see that
we have quality
websites of quality domains linking to
our domain now you can also use another
tool i mentioned this earlier with
on-page seo when i was talking about
sitemaps so if you go to search console
so that's a google tool we can also look
at a link report and see what other
websites are linking to us so this is
google's way of communicating to us what
websites are out there linking to us and
so here i can see the top linking sites
to our website valleyfig.com
is the crumby kitchen has
1443 links pointing back to our site
cookscountry.com
whole foods magazine mayan perfect
kitchen these are all
sites with links pointing back to our
site so search console is a good tool
it's a good alternative tool especially
the links report is a good alternative
tool to get an idea of the types of
sites that are linking to your site now
what you're missing here in search
console is the domain authority but you
can use the link explorer tool in
moz.com to measure the domain authority
for any domain it's just a matter of
going to the tool itself going by going
to moz.com by going to the link explorer
report and just typing in the domain and
from there you'll be able to see the
domain authority so it's all about
quality over quantity i can't stress
that enough so when it comes to off page
really it's anonymous with link building
so it's the most effective method for
off-page seo and it's simply just
getting links from other websites to
your own so it's not as easy as it
sounds especially when we're talking
about quality over quantity but building
these links to our website will help our
rankings and that's the whole idea
behind off page seo we want to be able
to link from other websites to ours so
that we can help our rankings in
addition to some of the other benefits i
just mentioned so google recognizes
backlinks as one of their top ranking
factors so in addition to some of the
on-page seo tactics that i mentioned
earlier including title tag and meta
description and url structure and
headers all those are important but at
the same time it's a balance so google
wants to know hey yes we understand
you've optimized your title tag for
keyword but how does the rest of the
internet see your website are is your
website worthy enough to add a link from
a particular quality website to your
website so if there are a number of
quality links then your site must be of
quality as well and so that's the whole
idea behind link building being an
important factor because again it's
about from a google's perspective it's
about the user experience they want to
make sure that sites ranked on page one
of google are quality sites quality
sites that load well that have good
content that have fresh content not just
sites that have a gazillion links
pointing to them with
you know keywords stuffed into the title
tag so it's an ecosystem google's and
other search engines want to protect
that ecosystem with quality so that's
why link building is an important factor
and so they're different types of links
so when you have a link pointing from
one website to your own okay the link
could be a follow link or no follow link
and the whole idea behind
follow or no follow is simply hey we
know that google and other search
engines they're spidering the entire web
the whole idea is for them to collect as
many pages as they these search engines
can to bring them back to their servers
so they can serve them up in their
search engines well as google and these
other search engines spider these sites
they're following what they're doing is
they're following links that's as simple
as it gets they're following links from
one link to another so remember we
talked about internal links earlier on
on page seo internal links are just
links on your web pages pointing to
other pages on your own website well
when it comes to external links so links
pointing from one website to your
website
that website that's linking to your
website has an opportunity to say hey
google you can follow this link or don't
follow the link and so if they choose to
not follow the link meaning they put a
nofollow tag into the anchor text then
google's going to follow the link but
not recognize the link itself and what i
mean by that is hey if you have uh let's
just use valleyfig has a link from
wikipedia if wikipedia has a link
pointing to valleyfig.com but the link
itself is no follow then what google is
going to do is not recognize the link
itself they're not going to recognize
the link so therefore you're not going
to get credit or link juice as we say
you're not going to get any juice from
wikipedia to valley pig but if it is a
follow link then what google's going to
do is recognize the link and give you
credit for the backlink and by giving
you credit for the backlink that's going
to inherently increase your domain
authority it's also going to likely
increase your rankings so you want to
pay attention to the types of link
building that's out there no follow and
so anytime you try to establish a link
on an external website just make sure
it's a follow make sure it's not a no
follow because if it's a no follow link
then you're not going to get the credit
from the search engines and so the whole
idea behind
link building in terms of seo is to get
some credit from a quality website to
your website and so if we look here a
follow link in this example is one where
the ahref or the link itself doesn't
have a no follow in it but if a
hyperlink does have a no follow in it
then that means you're not going to get
the credit for the backlink so remember
no follows they don't allow search
engine crawlers to follow the link so
if that's the case it's not going to
pass any link juice when you don't pass
quote unquote link juice you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
so if you don't get credit for the
backlink then if we go back to our tools
that we have available for measuring
off-page seo so if i go back to
let's just say moz or even let's just
say search console you know i'll be able
to see
all these links here these links that
are showing up are follow links why
because google's recognizing the link if
they were nofollow then we wouldn't see
the link in here so that's something to
keep in mind as well and so just keep in
mind if it is a no file you'll see in
the hypertext itself the nofollow tag
and you can always check that the html
of any particular link and so
when we talk about link building we talk
about off-page seo really we're talking
about how to get links on quality
websites and how do we do that well i've
listed here a few ways to do that so you
could do guest blogging or blogging in
general is a good off-page seo slash
link building strategy and i'll talk
about more of that in a minute but we
can list our websites in reputable and
trustworthy directories i mentioned
wikipedia as an example even though
wikipedia may not be classified as a
directory but there are other
directories out there you could ask for
testimonials so if you're working with
clients or other websites you could ask
for testimonial or they can provide a
link pointing back from their site to
your site it's about relationships
really is what it comes down to it's
relationship building and that's what a
link is relationship building or you
could do content on social media so
these are just examples of ways to
generate links but let's go back to the
blogging part because blogging to me is
an essential part to off-page seo and
why is that because anytime you are part
of a blog you're generating content and
not only are you generating content
you're generating fresh content that's
likely to be interesting to the end user
and with that content yes you can
optimize that content but the beauty
about blogging is really anybody can do
it but if we want to connect blogging
with relationships if we're a food
blogger then we can write on other food
blogs as a guest writer and we can have
that blog post linked back to our own
blog as an example or we can have other
bloggers in the same industry write a
guest blog for us on their own blog and
point their link back to our site
blogging creates a lot of
opportunities for link building because
again it's a fresh canvas with
interesting content and when you have
interesting content then the opportunity
for backlinking is going to be there
because if you're writing about
something that's interesting the natural
you're going to want to link to
something else related to that that's
interesting and so that's the
opportunity that blogging creates so
again it's vital to get links from
authoritative web pages then multiple
links from low quality web pages so
going back to the link explorer report
we want to be able to pay attention to
those domain authorities or those
websites with low domain authority and
really you should pay attention to
really quality sites okay you want to
pay attention to quality sites and so
when we talk about links there's inbound
links there's outbound links we're
interested in those inbound links we're
interested in getting links from
high quality websites pointing to our
own website and again that could be in
the form of a blog it could be social
media it could be a partner site okay
these are all inbound links they just
need to be followed make sure they're
not a no follow so it's simple just
getting a external link that's a follow
to your to your own website and so the
one thing i want to mention here though
on inbound links from external websites
and that's making sure that not
necessarily every inbound link points to
the home page we want to be able to have
links point to internal pages so let's
harken back to
search console as an example so search
console our links report shows us
links pointing from external websites to
our own website but what are those
linked pages so if we look at some of
those linked pages here we can see the
top link pages we can see on
valleyfig.com slash recipes is the top
link page then the home page then the
about us then slash international so we
want to make sure that if we're trying
to generate backlinks from external
websites to our own website we want to
make sure that
they're pointing to interior pages not
necessarily the home page and why do i
say that because one of the benefits to
link building and off-page seo is
ranking so the whole idea about ranking
is to get some of our other pages ranked
not necessarily the home page the home
page is just a doorway into your website
if we have interesting content out there
on the web
and it's a food blogger as an example
and they're talking about a particular
food item well they're going to want a
link to a page that's related to what
they're blogging about that particular
food item they don't want to link to the
home page the home page is just a
doorway and so that's the whole idea
behind link building we want to link to
multiple pages on the site why is that
because if i take this particular page
valleyfig.com recipes and i just put
that into moz and i look at the link
explorer report for this particular page
the domain authority is still going to
be the same 35 that's what valleyfig.com
is 35 however there's also another
metric called page authority so page
authority is likewise with the domain
authority to score between one and one
hundred and so the more
external links pointing to an internal
page with high domain authority that's
likely going to increase the page
authority of that page so in other words
if we have good links from other
websites pointing to that page then it's
going to increase the page authority for
that page and ultimately the domain
authority for that page and so just like
the domain authority in this case
valleyfig every page under that domain
has a page authority score so the higher
the score the likelihood that that page
is going to rank in the search engine
results okay so that's the whole idea
behind link building is we want to
improve the authority of the pages not
just the domain but also more
importantly we also want to keep the end
user in mind so if it's from a blog or
social media the link pointing from that
blog or social media platform should
naturally point to something related to
what you're talking about not just the
home page because again the home page
more or less is the gateway into the
website so we want to get people to
where they want to go we want to
naturally create a link from good
content to some other good content so
that's the whole idea behind backlinking
so outbound links will direct a user
from our own website to another website
so
the idea here is it's okay to have
outbound links on your own website the
natural ecosystem of the world wide web
okay what i would recommend ear is not
to have so many in a century located
place for example don't have one page
with nothing but external links on it
you know sprinkle these external links
these outbound links throughout your
website but also
if it's not a reciprocal link meaning if
a guest blogger is not linking to your
website but you're just linking to
theirs and they didn't ask you to then
maybe consider a nofollow tag maybe you
know ideally you want to make sure that
these links are just natural in nature
so don't just have a habit of putting
outbound links because the whole idea
behind outbound links is you want to
keep people on your website but if it's
a natural link going from one content to
another and you think the end user is
going to benefit then no problem but
just don't get in the habit of putting
external links on your website because
that means that hey that user that's on
your website may click on that link and
leave your website and not come back so
keep that in mind as well because you
don't necessarily benefit from an seo
perspective by having outbound links on
your own website you want to do it as a
courtesy if somebody else is linking to
you you want to do it for the end user
if you feel the benefit from additional
content under the website but from an
seo perspective it doesn't necessarily
directly enhance your own website in
terms of ranking turn our attention to
duplicate content
so
a lot of us have websites with a lot of
content sometimes we go ahead and take
our website and revise it create a new
one or register a new domain and put
content on that new domain and so
we may find ourselves in a situation at
one point or the other where we have two
websites with the same content or it
could be the same website
with a lot of content but some of that
may be duplicate as well so we want to
try and stay away from duplicate content
but for some of us we may stumble across
it accidentally we may find ourselves
having content that's duplicated and so
we want to try and prevent that because
that's a no-no in the world of seo so
if we have duplicate content appearing
in more than one url there are ways to
rectify
not having the search engines recognize
the content twice so some examples of
duplicate content are for example a
spammer takes an article and posts the
same content on his website or like i
mentioned before you create another
website or register another domain and
have
that particular
content on the old website still or
you're writing a blog post and you tag
it or categorize it and the content
shows up under the tags under the
categories and just shows up in general
so there are a lot of scenarios where
you can find yourselves with duplicate
content and so we want to rectify that
we don't want duplicate content we want
the search engines to recognize the
original source of the content and so
basically if you have two versions of a
web page you may result in duplicate
content issues another example that
would be for example if you have
products you may find that that same
product may be under two different
categories so how do we rectify that
well there are a number of different
ways and so the simple way is what they
call a 301 redirect to the original url
so if you find yourself in a situation
where you have a new website with the
same content you could simply set up a
redirect and we call it a 301 redirect
because 301 refers to
permanent so it's signifying to the
search engines that you're permanently
moving from this page to this page the
other way is through a canonical
attribute and so
the word canonical may not register with
some of you so
let's just uh take a minute to talk
about what a canonical is like basically
canonical tag it's a page level meta tag
so remember that meta tag description we
talked about in on-page seo we'll think
about this as another type of meta tag
and it's placed in that html header of
your web page so basically all it does
is by placing this meta tag it tells the
search engines which url is the original
version to be displayed in index so it's
the purpose of a canonical is to keep
the duplicate content out of the search
engine index so we want to consolidate
our page rank our page authority our
domain authority all to original content
that's the whole idea of having a
canonical and it's a quick solution so
all you need to do is add a canonical
tag to the header so let me show you an
example if you have a site let's just
use cnn as an example cnn.com has a lot
of content sometimes given the breadth
of content that they have they may run
into duplicate content so they simply
just put a canonical tag into
their their header and so by doing that
they're able to
tell the search engines hey
this page this domain is the original if
you find yourself with multiple sites
well you can also use google search
console so remember we used google
search console in earlier examples when
we talked about
links to your site or we talked about
that site map on on-page seo well if we
go on a search console we could
basically say look google because search
console is a google tool we want to
confirm that this is our domain so this
is the domain you should be focusing on
so you can leverage search console to
communicate with google regarding which
site
is important which is the one that
should get indexed you can use the
canonical you can put that on any page
either website or you can set up a 301
redirect so those are the ways to fix
duplicate content issues 301s are the
easiest canonicals tend to be temporary
because they're just the page level and
then search console is a
a good method because it communicates
with google directly and it allows
google to crawl various web pages
differently than if you didn't tell them
okay so if you didn't tell them they're
just going to grab anything they can so
by communicating via the google search
console tool it allows you to tell
google this is the domain i want to
focus in on so let's talk then now about
how the google algorithms work so we'll
shift gears here and we'll talk about
how these algorithms work on google so
google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting webpages and they're taking
all those web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are
google panda google penguin and google
rankbrain so these are all
things that google has done
to make sure that they're constantly
tweaking their search engines to deliver
the best results so let's talk about
some of these these popular algorithms
and before we talk about these popular
algorithms let's just make one thing
clear that google's always tweaking
their algorithms on their search engine
and so if you want to get an idea how
often they do it well they do it every
day they're constantly tweaking it but
they what they do is they release major
changes to their algorithm a few times a
year so if you want to get a sense of
what those changes look like well you
could go to
moz.com and you can go to google dash
algorithm dash change and you can see
here that hey google changes its search
algorithm around 500 to 600 times while
most of these are minor google again
rolls out major changes like panda like
penguin that affects search results in
significant ways so you can go here and
you can go all the way back to 2000 and
see some of the algorithm changes that
have occurred over
the last few years and you can see here
the last major one was done in august of
2018 that was the metacore update so
they're constantly making changes to
their search engine to deliver a more
concise more better ecosystem for the
end user so if it's a better search
engine for the end user end users are
going to come back so the whole idea is
continuing to tweak the system the
algorithms to better show more accurate
results and so let's take a look at some
of the the major algorithm changes that
they've done in the past so the first is
we'll talk about google panda
and panda was an algorithm released back
in 2011 so here we are in 2019 is a few
years ago but still significant in that
really this algorithm emphasized high
quality content because before panda
there was a there's just a lot of
content out there on the internet and
there was a lot of spam content there's
a lot of duplicate content and so really
the idea behind panda is for google to
really deliver in their search engine
results pages high quality content so
what it did was it removed web pages
that had low quality or duplicate
content so that was the whole idea
behind you know the algorithm nicknamed
panda it removed low quality and
duplicate content and that kind of
cleaned things up a bit where if you did
a search query now you'd actually see
better better results and one thing
about panda is because there's so much
quality because google's indexing so
much there on the internet that it's
constantly being updated it's updated
regularly so the next one we're going to
talk about is google penguin so
penguin was released after panda and
what that focused in on was low quality
links so remember we talked about link
building we talked about quality links
over quantity so
naturally you're going to have links
naturally from all websites whether that
be high quality or low quality the whole
idea behind this algorithm is to
sever the links that are low quality and
so the idea behind that was they focused
on two areas so they focused in on link
schemes and keyword stuffing so that's
what penguin focused on was link schemes
were basically
link almost link farming where you
produced mass amounts of backlinks and
not all of them were good quality they
weren't natural links links should be
natural from one high quality site or
blog to another high quality cider blog
and by creating links games you've
created an ecosystem where links just
went to irrelevant low quality spam
related pages and so google's penguins
algorithm update focused in on that
effort to remove or combat pages that
had poor links from being indexed in
their search engine results and then
they also combated keyword stuffing
keyword stuffing is nothing more than
taking your target a keyword and
stuffing it into the content of your
page or title tag your meta description
so any sites that were caught up doing
that basically suffer the consequences
because what penguin did was take care
of sites that basically were accused of
keyword stuffing or had characteristics
of keyword stuffing and they removed
sites that had a lot of links pointing
to it from poor quality sites and vice
versa sites that really had a lot of
external links pointing to other poor
quality sites so that's what penguin did
they took a look at those two areas i
mean so we talked about link schemes
again penguin's aim was to decrease the
ranking of web pages that created
artificially by using black hat
techniques and basically what i mean by
black cat techniques that artificially
creating links that just didn't make
sense just for the sake of getting the
backlink just for the sake of passing
link juice and so that's what a link
scheme is or was and so google basically
tweaked their algorithm to combat those
poor link schemes and so
keyword stuffing as i mentioned a minute
ago it's just repetitive usage of the
same keyword and that just basically
suffers the content is the thing that
suffers here and when the content
suffers the end users suffer so google
is all about quality content and when
you have quality content and that
quality content is indexed and users
find what they're looking for chances
are they're gonna go back to the search
engine to continue to find what they're
looking for with the end result being
presented with quality content so
keyword stuffing really dilutes the
quality of the content and then let's
talk about the third algorithm which is
rankbrain so rankbrain is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning and
what that does that machine learning
interprets search queries that users
search on google so
for example
if rankbrain sees a word or phrase it
isn't familiar with basically the
machine can make a guess as to what
words or phrases might have a similar
meaning and filter the result
accordingly so basically take these
search engine queries and present them
in a way that's logical so that the end
result can be something that's relevant
to what you're looking for and so for
example if you're searching for online
marketing you will get results related
for digital marketing on search engine
remote pages why because rankbrain will
interpret that particular keyword and
they're trying to basically match based
on all the data they collected what
words or phrases might have a similar
meaning so online marketing digital
marketing have similar meanings now that
we've talked about some of the different
algorithm changes that google has made
over the years and continues to make
let's
segue into the types of seo and so when
we talk about the types of seo we're
really talking about
doing what's right what's expected
versus doing something that you know is
trying to cheat the system and so you
may hear the terminology black cat seo
white hat seo or gray hat seo and so the
whole idea behind these terminologies is
that hey what are we supposed to be
doing here in terms of following best
practices in order to get our pages
ranked on the search engines for the
keyword queries we covered and so let's
talk about what not to do first and
that's always black cat techniques so i
just mentioned a minute ago with panda
and penguin algorithm updates you know
penguin took into account you know link
schemes poor linking techniques keyword
stuffing so
those are considered black cat
techniques so black cat is a technique
used to improve page rank by violating
search engine rules and policies so it's
clearly google's made a clear line in
the sand they don't like link schemes
they don't like keyword stuffing so if
you take into account those practices
then you're practicing black hat
techniques to treat this cheat the
system to try and rank faster and so
some other ways of black cat or you know
redirecting or fishing
having duplicate content all these are
are things that are frowned upon by
search engines so the result of not only
algorithm changes is you could get your
website blacklisted from the search
engines if you are caught in violation
of their policies it's pretty clear-cut
so that's why the algorithms are in
place uh the algorithms try and create a
system an environment where you know
good quality content is shown so if
you're keyword stuffing you're creating
lots of duplicate content that's not in
adherence with you know google's
policies for creating good quality
content and as a result you could get
blacklisted so with black cat techniques
you run the risk of being penalized and
you don't want to be penalized by the
search engines so white hat contrarily
used to improve search engine rankings
by following those rules and policies so
in effect it's everything we talked
about today from on-page seo to off-page
seo doing the right thing with your
content in terms of organizing the
structure with headers creating very
clear and concise meta descriptions
submitting a site map all of those are
white hat techniques addressing page
load time using really relevant key
words naturally in your content and
creating high quality content that's
fresh and interesting for the end user
that's a white hat technique that's
going to get you ranked higher and
farther and with better benefits so grey
hat is just simply a combination of
black and white it's the practice of
improving by following the policies but
they considered you know ethically
dubious and so what i mean by that is
listen you you don't want to purchase
links you want links to come across
naturally you don't want to do excessive
internal linking you don't want to have
a lot of links pointing to one page it's
not natural so you want to be able to do
things that
are
natural you don't want to just take
content from another side and claim it
as your own so you want to do things
that
are natural that's going to create a
good experience for the user because if
it's for the end user which it is then
generally it's going to be good for the
search engines and so let's talk about
website architecture now so
basically when i say website
architecture what i mean is we want to
give the search engines an idea of how
our website's built so website
architecture and the structure of
websites important and so every website
has a hierarchy it starts with the home
page the home page is the top page it's
the the domain it's where most people go
to find other pages of your website and
so generally you're gonna have a
scenario where you're going to have a
home page with you know if you sell
products multiple categories and in
those categories you're going to have
multiple products so the generally
that's how a web architecture flows it
follows from top down and the reason for
having a good website architecture
is internal links are spread equally so
you want to make sure again not to apply
a black cat method or greyhound method
of pointing all links to one page you
want links naturally to spread
throughout your website because not just
from an seo benefit but from an end user
perspective you want users to flow
through your website naturally so if
you're planning on developing websites
from an seo perspective you know take
these things into consideration so we
want to take into account the site
architecture navigation we want to take
into account the url remember we talked
about url structure and on-page seo the
rule of thumb is if you can read it the
search engines will read it so we want
to keep it clear and concise and
relevant to the content of that page
when we talk about responsive design
we're talking about multiple devices so
you don't build a website just for
desktop especially when
mobile is being used by a majority of
the users around the world so you want
to build a website that's both desktop
friendly and mobile friendly we also
want to take into account a robot's text
file and a robot's text file is simply
just a text file that allows the search
engines to index
certain pages it tells them what not to
index and so you can always find the
robot's text file normally if you go to
a website and let's just say we go to
valleyfig.com
and then we type in robot or robots.txt
file here we can see if i type in
robots.txt file here this
basically is a file a text file that's
in the root directory and it simply just
gives the search engines an idea of what
they're allowed to index and what
they're not allowed to index so anything
with a disallow means hey search engines
please don't index these pages so that's
what a robot's text file does and every
site should have it because there are
some pages on your website then you
inherently don't want the search engines
to index and you want to optimize for
the crawlers so that means that making
sure that your pages are available and
that means also submitting a sitemap
remember we submit our sitemap via the
google search console so good site
architecture not only makes content easy
to find but also helps to gain traffic
because hey if your site is easy it's
well organized it's built multiple
devices the urls are easy then all
that's going to be apparent to the
search engines and when it's apparent to
the search engines it's going to get
indexed they want to get indexed then
you're going to get found and you're
going to get the traffic so it's just a
natural progression it's best practice
so some important features of good
architecture are again that url
structure code your site navigation and
css or html make it easy for the search
engines to follow build a comprehensive
structure for an internal linking
meaning they should be natural internal
links if a page is relevant to another
page then create an internal link if you
have a very big website with a lot of
content or a lot of products then create
a breadcrumb navigation okay so we're
maybe familiar with that on amazon as an
example
amazon.com has a lot of products and
if you're navigating from one product to
another in one directory or one category
to another category then amazon creates
what they call breadcrumbs to help you
navigate back to where you were quickly
so
these are all good best practices for
good site architecture good site
architecture equals search engine
results so responsive design helps to
make your website mobile friendly it
will increase the amount of time the
user spends on your website which may
improve site ranking so let's talk a
second about mobile friendliness so if i
go back to google search console
there happens to be
in search console a mobile usability
report and so if i click on that report
basically what it's going to show me is
pages that
are do not follow google's best
practices so some of google's best
practices are making sure that the text
is easy to read that clickable elements
aren't necessarily close to one another
and the viewport is set to the
appropriate device meaning the screen is
set to the appropriate device okay and
so
basically if we are found in violation
then the pages affected are going to get
flagged by google and if the page is
affected or flagged by google then those
pages won't get indexed and so we want
to keep an eye on the mobile usability
report in google search console so
remember it's better to have a good site
architecture that bots can easily index
so bots will give preference to web
pages with relevant content and in the
end it will help your website rank
better and as a side note always use a
site map to make it easy for the bots to
crawl your website so we covered that
and on page as a reminder if i go back
to search console and if i click on
sitemaps i can go ahead and submit my
sitemap so if i created an xml version
of my sitemap called
sitemap.xml and i submit that basically
what i'm doing is i'm saying hey google
here's my sitemap file and in that
sitemap file are all the pages on my
website that want to get indexed and
when you submit your sitemap to google
basically they're going to
discover those urls and index those urls
and their search index and that
expedites the process of getting indexed
it expedites the process of getting
found on search and it expedites the
process of getting clicks on your search
results pages and and having that
traffic go to your website where they
can enjoy the user experience and
convert and remember the robot's text
file is there to allow google and other
search engines to know what pages to
crawl so good website architecture like
for example amazon they use breadcrumbs
they have a hierarchy in terms of of
categories okay so you can see how it's
evenly dispersed on the left side on the
right side a poor website architecture
is very slanted in one direction a lot
of internal links no breadcrumbs the
navigation isn't very clear so we want
to make sure things are simple and easy
so let's turn our attention to local seo
so local seo is for those businesses who
focus on a specific market it could be
a whole state like the state of florida
in the united states it could be a
specific city in a particular state like
orlando florida or miami it really
depends on the business and who you are
trying to attract and what geo location
you are trying to attract so if you're
trying to attract a segment of audience
in a specific location then local seo
should be
in your sites uh for optimization and so
when we talk about local seo we're
really talking about optimizing your
website to get traffic from a specific
location so that's what local seo is and
the idea behind local seo is to put your
particular service or product or
whatever it is you're offering to
that particular geo market that
particular locale or that city or that
state so you want to put yourself in
front of the right audience that's the
whole idea behind local seo and so if we
focus it on google you know local
results are based on three factors and
this is according to google so it's
based on a relevancy so if somebody's
looking for a plumber and you happen to
be a plumber in that particular locale
or city or zip code then chances of you
getting found are going to be great
because of relevancy and then distance
so where that person's located based on
your address or where you're located has
a role in how you display on local seo
and then prominence so prominence is
also very important because you know how
prominent are you as a business are you
getting a lot of reviews do you have a
lot of different locations do you have
all your photos and all your information
posted so prominence does play a bit of
factor along with distance along with
relevancy on google local seo so these
factors combine to help find the best
match for your search just somebody
typing in that plumber or say that
italian restaurant or
any particular product or service is
going to find local results and you want
to be there to to meet that person when
they're looking for your product or
service so that's the whole idea behind
local seo and so one of the factors with
local seo is having consistent nap or
not and so what is nip it's really name
address and phone number so it sounds
very simple and it is simple you just
have to be consistent so if you have a
local seo presence on say bing search
engine you want to make sure that the
name address and phone number are can
also the same name and address and phone
number on google so it's just about
consistency so that's what we want to do
we want to make sure that we're
consistent across the board because it's
important for companies that want to
rank well have some consistency and it's
important too when we talk about
consistency to actually have that
information you need obviously the name
of your company you obviously need a
phone number and you need to put your
address in there but really of all three
the phone number's just as important
because when we talk about local seo we
mentioned mobile earlier we know that a
lot of people initiate their search on
mobile and so if they're looking for a
local restaurant or local cafe or that
plumber and you appear in local seo then
your phone number's going to appear with
the results and that gives an
opportunity for somebody to go ahead and
just click on that number to call it
just makes it that much easier for
somebody to get in touch with you so
consistency and having all your
information
are important factors for local seo so
having an inconsistent nap if you will
is not going to bode well for you on the
local seo results okay it's important
because it offers up legitimate
legitimacy it offers up better rankings
and at the end of the day it's going to
help you get those calls it's going to
help you get traffic to your website so
for example if a particular company that
sells puma running shoes
has
yellowpages.com listing we want to be
consistent if it's on yellowpages.com
and this is their address on their
website then you need to be consistent
with that if it's inconsistent and we're
talking about very minor details but
these minor details are important simply
just putting rd as road and then
spelling out row is going to cause some
inconsistency so consistency is very
important why because local seo is also
tied to
mapping you know google maps and so
google wants to see consistency so that
they can offer up the address and the
mapping services so that's one good
reason why it needs to be consistent
another reason is again you know so many
may want to uh drive to your location or
call your location or see if that
location is close to them so that's why
consistency is such a key component to
local seo so in order to get started on
google for local seo what you want to do
is you want to just do a search for
google my business so google my business
is the platform in which you're going to
set up your local business and once you
set up your google my business account
whatever that account is you want to
make sure you have all the credible
information in there i can't stress that
enough you need to have that phone
number you need to have that address it
needs to be consistent but with google
my business there's a lot of things you
can do here so you can manage reviews so
if you do have a location you can go
ahead and manage those reviews that
somebody puts in for your business and
so if it's a negative review you
definitely want to respond to that
negative review if it's a positive view
you definitely want to respond to that
positive review so you can manage
reviews you can upload photos so photos
is a big component as we talked about
with all tags and images you know having
these images help appear in the local
seo results you can manage a lot of
other things your information you can
manage posts you can offer up promotions
there's a lot of things you could do you
could set your business hours so the
more information you put in to google my
business the more information is gonna
can be conveyed to the end user looking
for your products and services and
google my business even goes as far as
offering up the opportunity to have a
website so if you're a business that
doesn't even have your own website you
can create a website right in google my
business and so the end result is this
if somebody's looking for let's just say
lice removal
and orlando
let's just say your child comes home
from school with some lice you need
services that offer up lice removal well
you're going to be able to see
businesses listed in the atlanta region
that offer up the service you're looking
for and if you're on a mobile phone you
can go ahead and quickly you know call
that person you can go to the website
you look at the reviews so local seos
are very important to local businesses
very important and so you want to make
sure you have consistent presence not
just on google but on bing and some of
these other local platforms like
yellowpages.com for example so being
prominent across multiple platforms is
going to put yourself in front of the
right audience who's looking for your
products and services let's talk about
how to measure your seo performance so
all that hard work you've done with
on-page seo
in
coupled with all the work you've done
with off page seo are eventually going
to net results and positive results and
we want to be able to measure that as
you're actually doing the work as you're
putting forth the effort on on page and
off page and so we want to be able to
measure that and so
you want to be able to understand
what to measure and where to measure it
and so when we talk about seo we really
want to hone in on three high-level core
metrics and that's ranking traffic and
conversion so when we talk about ranking
traffic and conversion we can break that
down into this list here what kind of
traffic are we getting from organic
search what kind of traffic are we
getting from mobile devices remember
mobile is very important because as we
talked about with on-page seo as we
talked about with local seo a lot of
searches start with mobile devices we
want to look at keyword ranking remember
keyword research is the first step in
the
seo process even before we do any work
with on-page and off-page you know we
want to look at the local visibility if
we have local seo results we want to
look at engagement metrics so all that
traffic we're driving from organic
search we want to be able to measure how
they're performing and behaving on our
website we also want to measure some
form of progress on off-page seo and
that's in the form of backlinks so all
of these are different metrics we can
measure using different tools so let's
talk about how to go about looking at
these metrics and where to go look at
them and measure them and so
really
monitoring all this behavior will help
us understand how we're performing how
seo is performing and so really what we
want to do is start with organic traffic
and so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors we're driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is google analytics
and google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if i'm in google
analytics and i go under acquisition and
then i go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for a particular
website i can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then i could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from organic search i can also see
engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so
i want to be able to see if somebody's
typing in a query clicking on our link
in the organic search results and then
coming to our website are they actually
engaging with their website or are they
leaving the website after only visiting
the page they landed on so that's all in
these are all important metrics to
measure and i can measure all that right
here in google analytics if i wanted to
i can even take it a step further and
break that down by country so if i type
in country as a secondary dimension now
i can see what country is driving
traffic from organic search so a lot of
your organic traffic information is
going to be centrally located in google
analytics so we also talked about mobile
traffic a majority of searches take
place on mobile phones versus desktop so
google basically is reporting that
nearly 60 of searches now appear from
mobile devices and so if we go back to
google analytics we can also look at a
mobile report so if i go in google
analytics under audience under mobile
overview i can see a breakdown of the
amount of traffic coming from desktop
versus tablet versus mobile and so
you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if i just
type in channel and google analytics as
a secondary dimension and look at the
default channel groupings versus device
category i could see that you know
mobile from organic search has driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking because with mobile ranking it's
based on a responsive website and with
that responsive website basically
responsive being that the website's
going to adapt to the mobile device so
it's going to respond to the device that
somebody's on and so therefore the
metrics or the engagement metrics are
going to be different but if i look back
to google analytics i can see again
bounce rate i can see pages per session
average session duration so if i look at
line three i could see all the different
engagement metrics compared to those
metrics from other devices and other
channels okay so you want to be able to
do a comparison because if behavior is
not up to par engagement is not the par
on mobile then you want to do something
about that so you want to hone in on
mobile traffic specifically from organic
search because the behavior is going to
be different you know people start their
searches on mobile the site's going to
be different and so therefore it's a
different experience altogether so make
sure you track the behavior and more
importantly make sure you track that
page speed so earlier we talked about
on-page seo when we honed in on page
speed so just as a reminder if i'm back
in analytics and i go back under
behavior then if i go to site speed then
if i go to overview i'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
i can also look at specific page timings
and i should be able to see that by
device so if i type in device category
i'm going to be able to see how each
page loads per device and so this allows
me to understand which pages are loading
fast which pages are not loading as fast
and address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from mobile
devices you can also use other tools
that are out there like agency analytics
there are plenty of tools out there i
tend to use google analytics because
primarily it's free and google analytics
is a google product so it works with
other google platforms like google
search console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least i recommend using is moz so i
mentioned moz earlier with on page and
off page seo so if we go into moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add them to mods
and what moz does is they actually track
where these keywords rank and so if i go
into mods and i click on rankings i'll
be able to see on a weekly basis or a
monthly basis how our keywords are
ranking and for what pages they're
ranking so for whatever keyword i choose
to to optimize for i want to make sure i
put those keywords in moz because when i
put them in moz moz is going to on a
weekly basis tell me where these
keywords rank and for what url they're
ranked for so that way i can keep an eye
on ranking over time because in theory
the higher you rank the more traffic
you're going to get and so we want to be
able to see the trend in which keywords
rank okay so if i click on a particular
keyword in moz it's going to give me
over a period of time where that keyword
is ranked be able to see improvement in
ranking for particular keyword the whole
idea behind seo is to choose keywords
that are relevant optimize for those
keywords so that you can be ranked for
those keywords in order to get the
traffic and conversions so moz is a good
platform that helps us monitor rankings
for particular keywords now if you don't
want to use moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to google search
console and so remember we talked about
google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with google search console so
google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into google search
and so here i can see the actual query
and so with this particular website
valleyfig.com i can see that dried fig
recipes over the course of the last
three months had 5
5414 impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple pages
appeared in google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
5414 impressions i received 1100 clicks
so
google search console is going to be
able to tell me not only you know how
many impressions i receive for a
particular keyword but they also going
to tell me how many clicks and if i
wanted to add more metrics to that i can
add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so i can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey are any of my targeted keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am i ranking and i am i showing up
and am i getting clicks so search
console sirs is a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for
you know maintaining local seo so
remember on the local seo we talked
about
google my business so if i go back to
google my business i can go into my
account and so google my business is
going to be able to show me some metrics
so if i go into google my business and
click on insights i'm going to be able
to see
a number of different metrics over the
course of a month i can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when i appeared so i'll be
able to see how many views i receive not
only on search results but on maps then
i can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or in
search did they visit my website that
they request directions that they call
so i can actually see engagement metrics
right in google my business i could see
a breakout by zip code i could see phone
calls by day of the week i could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into
local seo on google my business so that
gives you an idea of how you're
performing organically on local search
and remember you want to be able to use
google my business to hone in on your
specific audience so all these metrics
help you align with whether you're
getting in front of the right audience
and whether that audience is actually
behaving the way you want them to
meaning you know are they actually
contacting you are they going to your
website are they calling you so local
visibility and understanding the metrics
involved with local seo is very
important so google my business is where
you want to turn your attention so
overall engagement metrics are important
they play an important role in
determining rankings for example
we talked about bounce rate to bounce
rate is the rate at which people go from
organic search to your website and then
leave after uh seeing one page and not
going any further so if they land on a
page and then leave the website after
landing on that page it's considered a
bounce and so bounce or bounce rate is a
good indication of how people are
receiving our website or the content
that they're reading on our website
there are other metrics involved like
average session duration or pages per
visit all of these are engagement
metrics and let's not forget about page
speed so page speed is also a good
engagement metric all of these metrics
affect or determine rankings so we want
to be able to make sure that if we're in
google analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website from organic search and there's
a high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's querying and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good domains will effectively improve
your seo performance we talk about
backlinks with off-page seo and remember
quality over quantity and so we can
measure backlinks going back into moz we
can use moz's link explorer tool so
remember if i type in a domain valley
fig i can get
some metrics related off page seo
including my domain authority but more
importantly i can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so i can see
there are 575 link domains i can see
there are 7 900 inbound links and so
just by clicking on that i can get an
idea of the types of websites that are
linking to my site and their domain
authority and their spam score google
search console so if you go back into
search console you can also just click
on links and we should be able to get an
idea of you know what websites are
linking to our site and more importantly
we want to be able to see not only what
sites but what pages they're linked to
remember we want our backlinks pointing
to interior pages not necessarily the
home page so here i can see the top link
page for valleyfig.com is slash recipes
so we want links pointing to our
interior pages not necessarily the home
page that's what's going to help your
performance your rankings for all your
pages not just your home page so having
quality back links pointing to interior
pages help boost the domain authority
and the page authority for that
particular page so again using moz
link explorer tool or using the links
report and search console are good
sources for you to identify backlinks so
when we look at these these reports we
want to look at the domain authority of
these sites that are linking ours the
number of outbound links to the site or
specific pages on our site we want to be
able to look at the ratio of link
distribution you know we want to be able
to look at how many follows and nofollow
so most of this if not all of these
metrics are in moz so if i go back to
moz i can actually see you know which
one's pointing which ones are followed
the total quality of the link that's
pointing to our site again bam so moz
link explorer report tends to give us
all the information we need in order to
measure and get a sense of our backlinks
that help us with off-page seo so there
are other tools out there there's hrefs
again search console there's other seo
platforms out there that'll help you
measure backlinks okay now that we
covered everything with on-page seo and
off-page seo and really everything seo
in general
let's take a little quiz and if you
could go ahead and just put your answers
in the comment section below so
just a little quiz here and we'll start
out with question one which the
following type of site map is
specifically designed for search spiders
so the answer is either a html sitemap
or b xml sitemap so go ahead and put
your answers in the comment section
below i'll give you just another second
to think about that okay another
question for you from a search engine
perspective which of the following link
types could cause a negative effect on
your rankings it's either a purchase
link or b
no follow link so again if you could if
you know the answer or just take an
educated guess go ahead and put the
answers in the comment section below
okay next question a website's robots
text file serves what function is it a
tell the bots what pages should be
crawled and not crawled or b tells the
bots what links should be follow and no
follow so if you know the answer you
feel good about your answer go ahead and
put it in the comments section below
today we're going to talk about seo tips
and tricks so let's get started and
throughout this series we're going to
have a few tips to share with you and
we'll start out with tip number one opt
for smarter ways to do keyword research
and so
if you listen to any of our seo
tutorials in the past you know that
keyword research is the first step but
the most crucial step in starting seo so
when we do keyword research we want to
be able to
basically find keywords that we feel are
relevant to our business that we want to
be found on search for and so here are a
few tips that can help you do that
research
in a more efficient manner the first
thing we want to do is identify a list
of keywords that are relevant so we only
want to focus on relevant keywords for
our business that's a given so what i
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of those
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example
if we have a company that sells dried
figs in a spreadsheet as an example if i
show you a spreadsheet maybe we want to
focus in on just dried fig and maybe we
want to focus on dried fig recipes so go
ahead and put those in a column you know
some of these keywords that you know you
want to be found for so that's really
the first step they need to be relevant
so put them in a spreadsheet so that you
can build keywords around that list then
we want to choose keywords and when we
choose keywords we want to have some
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what i mean by volume
i mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the keyword
a product fit meaning you know is the
keyword relevant you always want to stay
true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example christmas tree you're only
going to have a spike you know during
the winter or excuse me the october
november december months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume
relevancy always trumps
volume or any other metric commercial
intent so we want to look at keywords
that for example have buy in them they
may have low search volume but if
somebody's typing in that keyword then
we can insinuate that the consumer who
typed in that keyword is ready to make
the purchase so we want to look at what
the intent is of that keyword and then
again the difficulty always opt for
keywords that have low difficulty or
competition and so in order to get these
metrics we can use third-party tools and
i'm going to show you a couple of
examples of third-party tools you can
use that will give you some of this
information so the first tool i'm going
to show you is google ads keyword
planner so
if i'm having a google ads account i
could simply go to tools and then choose
the keyword planner and from there i
want to find new keywords so if i choose
the keyword dried figs because that's
the keyword i put in my spreadsheet that
i'm interested in optimizing for and
then maybe drive fake recipes that was
the other keyword theme
so if i enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here i can see dried
figs i have an average monthly search
volume 8 100. that means on average over
the last 12 months that's how many
people have typed in that keyword here i
can see a little bit of a trend i just
hover my mouse over that graph i could
see again for seasonality impact if
there is any seasonality what the volume
is on average per month then i can see
the competition is high and because this
is google ads because it's paid search
they're gonna give me a sense or an idea
of what i should be bidding on that
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once i get this
information here i can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that google ads gives
us a higher low now if we're trying to
measure
ratio between
volume and competition we want to get an
actual sense of what that competition is
so what i always do as a best practice
is go into google search if i go to
google search and i type in dried figs
i'm going to see the actual volume is 34
million 500 000. so i can see that's the
actual search volume for this particular
keyword however if i add a syntax called
all in title before that keyword with
the colon space and then hit enter then
i could see the actual
volume reduces to 31 000 and basically
what this tells me is that 31 000
listings results have the keyword dried
figs in the title tag so if a web page
has dried fig our targeted keyword in
the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if i go into our keyword
analysis here and i
go ahead and enter in that information
so what's my keyword my keyword is dried
figs okay my volume was 8 100 my
competition was 31 000 and so that gives
me a ratio of 81 divided by 31 000 if i
make that into a percentage basically 26
so that's my keyword effectiveness index
or kei or ratio between volume and
competition and so that's an a way that
you can
gather information is by using google
ads enter the information into a
spreadsheet and then sort all your data
by kei you could sort it by volume you
could sort it by competition all these
metrics matter alternatively as another
tool you can use moz so moz has a
keyword explorer tool okay so if i type
in the keyword dried figs focusing on
the united states i could see that moz
says hey look there's anywhere between 4
300 and 6 500 in terms of volume out of
100 the difficulty is 41. and so i can
expect a click-through rate of you know
and so basically the great thing about
moz's keyword explorer tool is i can
also look at the search analysis search
engine results pages what serp stands
for and i can analyze the serp for a
particular keyword in moz so i want to
be able to understand what my
competition is doing so here i could see
if i really want to try and optimize for
that keyword i could see
what the other pages are ranked for that
keyword in the on page one i can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here i could see that we have
a number of different sites listed here
so if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to
climb over to be number one on google so
i find that the keyword explore tool in
moz is very helpful for understanding
your competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant i
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify trends
from a site search query like amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into moz and
we can see just by typing in some of the
keywords we're focusing on we can see if
our competitors are ranking for the same
keywords just by using that keyword
explorer tool and then another thing we
want to look at is lsi or latent
semantic indexing so that's a fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of the
page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we could also stay up
to date on industry news as it will help
you learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt
to
subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here i'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if i simply just go to search engine
watch dot com i find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
could see
why seo and front-end developers are the
perfect search marketing team another
article about optimizing your channel
youtube channel five easy steps so
there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to seo
and keyword research we could also look
at other third-party sites like
wikipedia reddit and core for example so
if i go to quora i can do a search for
dried figs and i could see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas to build
a keyword a list around so for example
the health benefits of dried figs okay
are dry figs safe for diabetes best ways
to eat dry figs so those are all good
keyword themes that we could build a
keyword list around and i did that
simply just by typing in dried figs on
core so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage when you're trying to build out
a keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so
it's all about content so we've already
done the keyword research we still need
to kind of merge the two when we talk
about merging the two it's not just
building content around those keywords
it's much more than that when it comes
to seo and so that's why we always talk
about high quality content so let's talk
about some of the tips that can help you
create high quality content so
first tip is we want to be able to
publish longer and engaging content
longer and engaging content tends to
rank higher on google why because you
have more content to work with and when
you have more content to work with you
can optimize it you can structure it you
can insert different assets like videos
and images and by keeping it long you're
gonna likely keep it engaging and so
google tends to lean in favor of content
that is well organized structured and
long because it is more likely to be
engaging for the end user we definitely
want to include those target keywords so
you want to be able to
you know insert those keywords into
those meta tag descriptions into those
title tags into those alt tags but you
want to work them in naturally you don't
want to force anything content should be
naturally written because if it's
naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use lsi keywords
in the content so lsi or
basically latent semantic indexing
basically just means different terms and
concepts related to your target keywords
so feel free to use terms that are
similar to what you're currently using
these keywords can definitely be used
for seo because they create more
visibility and potentially higher
rankings because it gives you an
opportunity to use keywords that are
natural and work for different
variations and
let's look at examples so if you're
optimizing an e-commerce category page
and your keyword is one mix used for men
so we want to use keywords closely
related to one mix used for men for
example running shoes for men or sport
running shoes for men outdoor sports
shoes or air cushion shoes let's take a
look an example of amazon so if i go to
amazon i could see the one mix shoes for
men page and if i look at this page i
can see a lot of product and each
product has basically some content
associated with it i.e the title of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to
use different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sports shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker all
of these are lsi related keywords
they're similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different products so we want to make
the content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if your e-commerce you want to make sure
that page is laid out properly easy to
read you hear i could see the descriptor
along with the title all kind of merge
together and so there's no break out of
okay this is the product name this
description it's kind of one all-in-one
which i like it just makes it more
natural sounding okay and you can see
these are all broken out uh pretty well
laid out page and amazon is more or less
you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
pitch we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so if you have a web
page you sell products even if you don't
sell products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on amazon and we clicked on a product uh
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well i may not
be so interested in buying this product
i want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
factor comes in where if i read other
reviews then i can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here i
could see that not only the reviews but
there's testimonials so i could see that
here you can see that there's a lot of
stars and you can see the kind of the
review title these running shoes are
very comfortable and lightweight so you
have a lot of different feedback and so
reading custom reviews is always helpful
because even though you're making the
decision it kind of will help sway you
in one direction or another at least it
does for me so that's the the beauty of
a customer review and a rating we want
to be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis so and
that goes for testimonials and reviews
you want to make sure you're always
getting reviews if you're always getting
reviews then that's just adding to the
particular product and so if you're
always updating your content on a
regular basis as well then google's
going to be able to see that and google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engaging to the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to
amazon here we can see amazon lists a
lot of the benefits or one mix in this
case lists a lot of the benefits so here
you can see all the descriptors about
the particular product it's got rubber
sole it's got a breathable textile
lighting you get free high quality socks
with every shoe so these are some of the
features and if we continue to scroll
down we could see some of the details
about the fabric type specifics about
the fabric and a lot of information on
this product page even a sizing chart so
a lot of different features that will
help the end user make the decision so
don't hold back add as much information
as you possibly can as much information
as you have available it doesn't hurt
because in the end what you're trying to
do from a product perspective is sell
the product and you can't really sell it
unless you have information that's going
to convince the user that this product
is what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if i
scroll down here i can see
some more of the benefits you know
waffle rubber outsole soft deodorant
insole again fabric type it's got all
sorts of information it's got images
about the fabric itself the shoe itself
how it's structured so a lot of
information about this and it even does
a comparison and so there's a lot of
information about this particular
product so don't hold back add as much
as you can to convince the end user so
in the case of the one mix on amazon you
know they had a sizing chart you know
they had an faq being additional
information what other products that
customers view from one mix and then
testimonials so these are some of the
basic bits of information you want to
add on your page if you don't have
customer reviews it's okay add faq in
its place again the end result is to
convince the customer to purchase the
product and then build a comprehensive
internal linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products so if i go back here
here i can see other products from one
mix so you should always have a linking
structure so that if the end user
doesn't want to particularly buy that
particular product then you have links
available so they can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product so
if we go back to our product page you
know they have different varieties that
they're showcasing here they have the
size chart they even have a size
convertible chart so if you're dealing
with metrics you can go over to us
metrics feet vice versa you can add a
video you know show a video of if you're
selling running shoes throw a video
somebody working out you know it doesn't
have to be a full-blown commercial per
se but it could be a short 30-second
video of what the shoe looks like on
somebody else's feet so that they could
see somebody walking with those shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you can do it right from your
phone so review your content before you
publish this goes without saying you
want to do that just you make sure you
include everything possible because when
the content does get published remember
google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for google as well we want to be able to
analyze our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rates so this is important
because the meta tags i.e the title tag
and the meta description and the urls
what shows up in google search results
so we have title tags up first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when i say
modifiers i mean you know feel free to
use the word best or
back or free shipping or discount so for
example if you're selling running shoes
25 best sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so
some tips for optimizing the title tag
in addition to modifiers we want to
watch the title length and we want to
include those target keywords in the
title tag so remember you're likely
going to have two keywords to work with
you want to have at least one of those
keywords in your title tag so with the
modifier you know up to 60 to 65
characters in length with that targeted
keyword should get you a good title tag
that's going to get somebody to click on
it so let's look at an example so if i
type in the keyword best recipes for
dried figs you know here i can scroll
down here's my title tag stands out my
url is right underneath that and
underneath the url are is the meta
description and so here i can see some
modifiers 188 best autumn dried fake
recipes or 25 fantastic fig recipes or
10 best cooking dried fig recipes so
these are all modifiers they're going to
help somebody get the click get them to
click on your link and go to your
website so when you don't hit the 65
character lemonade if you go over that
google's going to cut off the title text
so we want to avoid that at all possible
so the whole idea is you know like 10
best cooking dried fake recipes by emily
that's a good enticing title tag okay
takes into account a modifier includes
the targeted keyword and is under the 65
character count some additional tips for
writing meta description we always want
to provide a unique description for each
webpage of the website so no duplicate
meta tag descriptions every page needs
to be unique then we also want to be
specific about what we're offering so if
you have say you're selling headphones
and you have a particular set of
headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind a meta description is to
describe the page but also to get the
end user to click on your link so here's
an example of using modifiers and
describing a page if we look at amazon
again we can see this example here and
if we look at it on google search
results so if i type in amazon bluetooth
headsets ten dollars are on sale here we
can see a lot of amazon
listings in google search here you can
see the use of modifiers in the title
tag and also in the meta description
here we could see that you know this
particular headset bluetooth headset is
on sale 50 off so if something's on sale
feel free to include it be descriptive
about the page let people know where
they're going and use those modifiers
don't be afraid to use numbers in the
meta description even if it's the price
itself even if it's not on sale but it
is the price included it's not going to
hurt the more information you can
include in a meta description the better
chance you have of somebody clicking on
that link use numbers symbols you know
percentages off always help use catchy
words like discount or cashback you're
competing with other listings on the
page so if you have something on sale if
it's on clearance list that it's on
clearance here i can see they even
included the coupon code so feel free to
list as much specific information about
that page as possible the whole idea is
you're competing with your own web pages
but in other cases with competitors so
the meta description along with the
title tag and the url helps separate out
you from the rest of the listings on
search engine results and we don't want
to keyword stuff we want to keep it
within 160 something characters or 160
65 characters because google will break
off the meta description just like they
do with the title tag and so we want
clean natural written meta descriptions
that separate you from the competition
so that means including the keywords but
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if i
go back again to valleyfig.com and i
could see the meta description hey
welcome to the best resource online for
dried fake recipes savory is sweet
snacks are healthy dried food recipes
we've got it all okay start cooking with
figs and so it's natural sounding it
does include the keyword it's not
keyword stuffing it's natural sounding
that's hopefully going to get that
person to click on this particular
website let's turn our attention to
the url so we want to make sure that the
url
is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular url here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so
first of all i don't understand some of
it so that makes it unpleasant boring
and messy to say the least so you want
urls that you know basically are clean
and understandable so in other words we
want to make them seo friendly because
if they're seo friendly somebody
understands the url
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb is if you can
read the url then the search engines can
read the url so here are some tips for
creating friendly urls for seo make it
readable you want to include the target
keyword in the url so if it's dried figs
the url should include dried figs if
it's dried fig recipes make sure it's
dried fig recipes now avoid using too
many subdirectories in the urls so we
want to keep it as close as possible to
the root directory and match the urls to
titles most of the time so let's go back
to our example here here we can see this
is valleyfig.com recipes not necessarily
dried fig recipes but recipes
nonetheless it's in the root directory
okay so at all cost now this is in some
cases unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an e-commerce website
that's calling you know content from a
database so if it that is the case
you're going to have some dynamic
parameters in the url which is fine just
make sure you avoid having too many of
those dynamic parameters it's
understandable that parameters but the
rule of dumb generally is no more than
two different parameters in the url so
prefer to create short urls that's
really the way to go the shorter the
better is the rule of thumb and you know
if you're going to break up the url then
use hyphens instead of underscores it's
just cleaner it's a more understandable
search engines tend to read it a little
bit easier if it's hyphen so here's what
a friendly url looks like for search you
got your domain you got a subcategory
broken up with a hyphen and then the
product so that's just a clean url for a
particular e-commerce site that has
categories and sub-categories so again
we got amazon.com your category can be
electronics your sub-category could be
earphones and your product could be both
earphones it's that simple let's start
with talking about rich snippets this is
tip number four so we want to add rich
snippets to improve your website's
visibility on serps so tip number four
is all about rich snippets so let's
start out by asking ourselves what is a
rich snippet so rich snippet is simply
just a term used to describe structured
data markup that you as a website owner
can add to your html so hypertext markup
language or html is what is basically
constructs a page if we can add more
information to that that will in turn
allow search engines like google to
better understand the information that's
on that web page so the more google
understands about that web page the more
they can put into the search engine
results page so rich snippets is
basically some structured data markup
that we can add to our existing html and
so if we want to add rich snippets to
search engines then how would you prefer
your products to be displayed well if we
have products then we want to make sure
that maybe we have reviews or maybe we
have so um other information in there
like
links to our site okay so there's a lot
of different types of rich snippets that
you know we can add that google can
recognize and add to the search engine
results so if you have a product then
there's a lot of things we can add like
specifically product reviews so we want
to be able to add more information to
the search engine results by working in
some rich snippets so basically the
whole idea is to set up the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the serp
the more likelihood you're going to get
the click and the more likelihood that
click is specific traffic so some of the
benefits of structuring the data for
rich snippets are as i mentioned
increasing click-through rates you know
also increasing conversion rates so when
you get the traffic from organic search
to your website if somebody's looking
for specific product and you have a
number of different good reviews showing
up let's just say 5 stars out of 5 stars
and you have 100 reviews showing five
stars then you know somebody's probably
going to send take some trust in your
brand and your conversion rate
probability is going to go higher it
also helps improve your search engine
visibility because you're adding more
information so in other words the more
google knows about your page the
likelihood it's going to rank that page
and it's more likely that that
information that's contained in that
rich snippet is going to get featured in
either the knowledge graph which is that
graph on the right side or in a featured
snippet which usually shows up at the
top of search engine results so in other
words the more information you give
google the more they can use that
information on their search results page
and there's no disagreeing that the more
information that you have in your search
engine result the likelihood of getting
more traffic increases so for rich
snippets you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product pages the page itself
is an image you can always start there
you can always add a description you can
always add in ratings and you can always
add in reviews so these are some of the
most common attributes you can add as a
rich snippet so if you add that google
picks it up it's going to include that
information in the search results okay
some others are offers
prices site links links to your site and
product availability so all that
information can be conveyed to google
google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to ahrefs over
99.58 of featured pages that have
structured data already rank in the top
10 list of the google search results
page so in other words if you have rich
snippets in your page your chances of
ranking in the top 10 of a google result
is going to be very very very good okay
let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for a great
user experience so let's go over some of
the tips that you would do for planning
a good website for seo and so tip number
one
is you want a url structure that follows
your site's navigation hierarchy so
obviously home page interior pages so
depending on what type of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that site's navigation that site
hierarchy and it all starts with the
home page you want to optimize your home
page to drive traffic to your product
pages so the home page is nothing more
than a doorway into your website and so
the site's navigation
should link to all those different
products so if you have an e-commerce
site with sub categories or categories
subcategories then you want to be able
to
make sure your navigation reflects that
you want to build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking as well
because when you're from the home page
obviously you want to be able to easily
navigate to other pages however when
you're on other pages you want to be
able to have a link pointing back to
relevant pages and not necessarily on
the home page so this serves two
purposes one for the end user obviously
you want the end user to navigate
through your website seamlessly right
second for the search engines they're
following links they want to be able to
understand how your website flows and
links together so you don't want a
scenario where it's a one-way street
from the home page to interior pages you
want basically a home page to interior
interior to other relevant interior
pages and that could be a lateral or
that could be a situation where it's a
hierarchy for example home page category
subcategories sub sub category etc you
want to be able to make sure your site
is constructed in a manner in which the
search engine can read it so css or
cascading style sheets or hypertext
markup language html are your two most
common languages that's basically what
browsers load that's what search engines
like to index it just makes it easy for
them to understand what your page is all
about remember we talked about rich
snippets in the previous tip rich
snippets are nothing more than
supplemental html to describe what the
page is all about so that the search
engines can understand that page and
include reviews or include site links in
the search engine results so this is all
based on html so the more you provide
the search engines in a more structured
manner via html the more the search
engines are going to stay on the page
adding breadcrumbs to your product pages
is also a good practice if you have an
e-commerce site and you have a category
then a sub-category then a
sub-sub-category then a product page
well it's probably not a bad idea to
make sure you have a breadcrumb so that
was that way somebody can easily go
right back from the product page to say
the category page or to the subcategory
page directly without having to hit the
back button or having to go through the
navigation some good examples i think
amazon is a good example of using
breadcrumbs giving the amount of
products they have on their site so go
check out amazon if you want a good
example for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so a canonical
tag is nothing more than a link element
basically or an html element that
basically prevents duplicate content
issues so in other words if we have a
canonical tag as a meta tag basically
we're telling the search engines this is
the preferred or canonical version of a
web page okay so use this web page so it
signals to the search engines which page
they should basically index and pay
attention to and avoid at all the other
pages that have similar content so
that's the idea behind a canonical tag
so that's a good best practice and then
optimize your site for desktop and
mobile i can't stress the mobile part
enough most users begin their journey on
mobile so if you're not sure about what
the search engines like or don't like
you can always refer to
google search console for an example so
if you go to google search console they
have a report called mobile usability so
if you click on mobile usability you can
see what pages they like what pages they
don't like from a mobile perspective and
if you have errors they're going to tell
you what those errors are so if your
website has text that's too small to
read they're going to tell you that
these are the pages with this error and
so that allows you to go and address
those errors because from a google
perspective if you have if a page has a
mobile usability error then google will
not index that page so leverage google
search console to get a sense of what
type of errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when i say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your sitemap so when we talk about
sitemaps we want to make sure that it's
a file and xml file that basically
includes all of our urls and we can then
turn around and give that site map to
the search engines so if you have a
sitemap in xml make sure you go to
google search console so if i go to
google search console and i click on
site maps i can just simply just tell
google where my sitemap is located and
when they recognize that sitemap they're
going to be able to basically index the
urls from that sitemap so we can see
here how many urls they discover and how
many they index so make sure you create
the sitemap in an xml format submit the
sitemap via google search console and
then you can go back and see
how many pages they've indexed versus
how many you've submitted and you want
to make sure that sitemap is dynamic
meaning anytime you publish a url that
url is added to the sitemap fixing
broken links so broken links is not
something you want but it's something
every website has it's unavoidable you
know people publish pages all the time
there's test pages there's all sorts of
reasons why
a site has broken links you want to be
able to address those and again going
back to google search console we can
basically see just by looking at some
reports what pages have broken links and
which ones don't so we could certainly
look at search console to get
information about basically what pages
are broken which ones aren't and then we
want to prefer predictive searches and
integrate product typographic errors on
your search bar so basically have a
search bar that's a best practice but
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
google analytics and looking at the
search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website people not being able to
read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what i found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact i would
even go beyond sometimes most the time
again depending on your business but i
see most businesses now have live chat
enabled and so basically
having live chat enables somebody who
has a question to immediately reach out
to somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous gratification in some ways
so inserting live chat on a website is
more common practice than not nowadays
given it it lends to a better user
experience tip number six improve your
page speed and reduce the bounce rate so
let's talk about page speed and how page
speed correlates with higher bounce rate
if it's a high page load and so
according to crazy page speed is an
important overlooked seo tactic because
for every second delay and page load can
result in
fewer page views 60 percent decrease in
customer satisfaction
seven percent decline in conversion rate
so
you know you can see here regardless of
how specific the numbers are when you
have a page that loads slow you're going
to have lower user engagement and a poor
user experience so you have to pay
attention to page speed and so since
2010 google has been using page speed as
a factor for page ranking in the search
engine results so here's some tips to
focus on making sure your pages are
optimal in terms of speed so
enable browser caching okay you can
reduce plugins if you're using wordpress
as an example you know disable plugins
you're not using getting using a simple
website design going back to tip number
five stick with css and html don't do
anything fancy in terms of technology
because it's only going to complicate
matters optimize your code minify files
meaning hey if you're not using any code
just get rid of it because code has to
execute and that slows down page load
time so if your website has numerous css
and javascript files basically minify
and combine them and that's what we're
talking about there you know you don't
necessarily need a lot of
you know javascript on your page you can
leverage google tag manager or you know
other features that help minimize the
number of javascript files you have and
so you can also get some of these ideas
by going into google analytics so in
analytics under behavior under site
speed under page timings you can
basically see how quick each page loads
and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so
if we let this report load we'll be able
to see some speed suggestions per page
and so here you can see for example the
home page has an average page load time
of 4.89 seconds you can see right next
to that we have page speed suggestions
seven total so if we click on that
basically what it's going to do is going
to launch another google product called
page speed insights and what page speed
insights is going to do is it's going to
analyze the page in question whether
that be the home page or an interior
page and what they're actually going to
do is not only analyze the desktop
version of your website but also the
mobile version and so now we can see
opportunities to improve our page speed
by making sure the images are properly
sized making sure server response time
is changed again defer unused css not
using css that's or getting rid of css
or minifying it so there's lots of
things you can do and again this is
desktop and mobile so on the mobile side
we could see some of the other issues
too that are causing high page load and
so analytics site speed reports page
speed insights are good ways to get an
idea really excellent ways to really
address page load time issues so again
these are just some of the common issues
with page load time there could be other
factors leaning on those page speed
insights reports will definitely help
reduce page load time so
basically according to google a website
should have you know time to first bite
lesser than 200 milliseconds
milliseconds is very very fast so in
case your website is slower than 200
milliseconds such as 500 milliseconds or
more you need to improve it so you don't
even have to measure it by milliseconds
you can even go by seconds which is what
most of us count time and again you can
see that simply going into the speed
suggestions report in google analytics
so ideally in terms of seconds you want
something that's about you know four
seconds or less three seconds or less
obviously as fast as possible so case
study walmart walmart reported the
following results so walmart experienced
a two percent increase in conversions
for every one second of page speed
improvement so think about that there's
definitely correlation between page load
time and speed so in conversions and
user engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement so with
that improvement they also experienced
an increment in revenue so meaning the
pages load people had a better user
experience they were able to check out
easier and that led to more revenue so
they were able to measure revenue
against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase their domain
authority of your website so google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page seo you need to
build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category pages or even content or blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
moz as a good tool to measure page
authority or domain authority so if i go
into moz moz has a page and domain
authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see
what sites have good domain or page
authority just by entering in the domain
so relevant you obviously want to rank
to something that's relevant so if
you're in the food industry something
food related you want to promote your
content regularly on social media so
social media i always consider it all
low-hanging fruit when it comes to
backlinking you know there's so many
different social media platforms
available facebook linkedin twitter
there's so many varieties from images to
pinterest and instagram to video being
youtube so there's lots of ways to get
your content out on social media that
will allow you to not only promote your
band build a community but also
establish a reference back to that page
you can opt for guest blogging okay so
you can reach out to another blogger and
blog on that platform and it could be
reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so
facebook's a good example it could be
having a youtube channel if you're into
video you can certainly set up a youtube
channel build a following around youtube
as well so always start your own page if
that's the platform of choice the last
thing you should do is set up a page on
social media and not keep it updated you
could certainly participate in forums
you can participate in other websites
like cora or reddit that's very you know
content based content driven user driven
i always recommend starting your own
blog blog is a good way to not only
generate content but it's a good way to
incorporate different types of content
so you could set up different types of
content and categories it's a good way
to incorporate different assets like
images and video it's a good way to
get users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be a time constraint
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but creative
in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips so remember
tip number one we want to opt for
smarter ways to do keyword research so
remember we want to look at volume we
want to look at competition we want to
create themes put them in a spreadsheet
so we want to be smarter and which in
the way in which we choose our keyword
tip number two remember publish high
quality content to get more traffic when
we say high quality content remember
break up the content use different
assets organize it structure it you know
make sure it's answering some of these
questions then we talked about in tip
number three analyzing your meta tags
and urls so we want to make sure that
title tag meta descriptions are creative
these modifiers like numbers or
promotions you know we don't want to go
over character counts we want to make
them unique and distinct so that
somebody clicks on them then we talked
about rich snippets and tip number four
remember rich snippets are just
additional html that communicates the
search engines so the search engines can
understand exactly what's on your page
so if you have recipes if you have
reviews if you have videos if you have
images if you have ratings all these
things can be added to the serps just by
communicating with the search engines vs
rich snippets tip 5 optimize your site
structure we want to make sure that you
know you have good inbound links you
want to make sure you incorporate
breadcrumbs you want to make sure users
can navigate your site more easily and
then in tip number six if your pages
load fast then it's going to enhance the
user experience it's going to increase
user engagement and increase conversions
and then tip number seven we want to
build quality link quality to increase
the domain authority so remember we can
use mods to measure domain authority
it's all about quality whether that be
via influencer marketing guest blogging
directories social media setting up a
social media page there's always
something you could be doing to generate
a quality link to your website today
we're going to talk about keyword
research so
what are we going to talk about when we
talk about keyword research we're going
to talk about why we would do keyword
research for seo we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so jesse is planning to publish
a blog of pizza recipes so
she was doing pizza recipes step by step
piece of recipes with sausage homemade
pizza toppings pizza dough recipes thin
crust pizzas she's doing a lot of
different topics on pizza recipes well
what jesse needs to do is understand
what's going to drive traffic to these
blog posts if she's writing about you
know different topics around pizza
recipes so
she's unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take
care and choosing the keywords to align
with your content so that's really the
idea why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they could
have slow search volume for example you
may choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
aligned with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic high competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care in choosing the keywords to me
that's the most important step with seo
is keyword research so we're going to
talk about the types of keyword research
then so we have short tail keywords and
we have long tail keywords so if you
write a blog post about pizza recipes
well what are you going to choose a
short tail or long tail so let's talk
about short tail keywords first so short
tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
and a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two keywords and a phrase or
shorter so short tilt keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be
lower conversions because short tail
keywords like for example pizza recipes
could be considered a short tail keyword
but maybe somebody's looking for
homemade pizza recipes or pizza recipes
from their favorite italian restaurant
so
short take keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with long
tail keywords chances are you're going
to have lower competition that's one of
the benefits but you're also going to
have lower search volume but with longer
tail keywords the keyword is probably
going to be more relevant with the
content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rate's likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look it simplistically short tail
keywords are broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content as not
relevant versus long tail keywords that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes it could take you a while
to rank for that keyword but when you
rank you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long taker
keyword is probably going to be greater
because not many other websites are
trying to rank for that same keyword and
so the benefit of that is if you have
let's just say homemade pizza recipes
with mushrooms that's a long tail key
word but if somebody's looking for that
type of pizza recipe then you know
you're going to track the right traffic
and chances are that traffic is going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that'd be another example more than
three key words in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipes so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more uh specific in nature
longer tail so these keywords are used
for targeted pages including blog posts
if you're writing a blog post
specifically about pizza recipes with
homemade dough then this is the keyword
you likely would want to use versus just
pizza recipes so let's look at an
example between a short tail keyword and
a long tail keyword and to accentuate
the differences we're going to use
google's keyword planner tool so
google's keyword planner tool is located
in google ads the google ads platform
and when you're in the google ads
platform you can simply click on tools
and then keyword planner and so what
keyword planner allows us to do is get a
sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what google's
keyword planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
gonna click get results and what
google's gonna do is it's going to show
us the volume of those keywords so for
pizza recipe we could see the average
monthly search volume is 33 100 for
pizza recipe so note that pizza recipe
and pizza recipes are closely related
keywords and so what google does is they
consider that a close variance so
meaning if somebody types in pizza
recipe then they're also in google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here i
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then i can see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword i can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variance
homemade pizza dough recipes i can see
over the past 12 months what the search
volume is for this on average is 2400
but i could see here in december the
volume went up to 3 600. but for example
in may it was 1900. so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past few months
but on average it's about 2400. so
shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what google's
keyword planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here i can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2 400 search queries for that keyword
now whether you get all 2 400 clicks for
that keyword remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2400
you're going to get a lion's share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
google's keyword planner tool in google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2 400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all 2
400 but are we going to get a line share
that we also need to look at competition
and so google's keyword planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what i want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
google's keyword planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
i want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what i can do is go
into google search and i could type in
pizza recipes and i could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so i want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
i'm going to put in the all entitle
syntax and so what that is going to ask
google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if i
do all in title colon space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000.
so what that tells me is that there are
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if i want
to focus in on my other keyword if i
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if i type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and i just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
enter key i'm going to get 35 million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition i
have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so i'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then i'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and i get
160 different results so here i can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites and web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now i have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about seo
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for seo and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 thousand so i'm gonna
type in 683
thousand what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes
so if i go back for this particular
keyword is 2400 so i'm gonna put 2400 in
under my volume column and then what was
my competition well my competition was i
typed that keyword back in
2160. so i'm going to put 2
100 say so now i have an idea of what
kind of volume and what kind of
competition i have now you want to do
this for a number of different keywords
and when you do it for number keywords
what you do want to do is obviously
choose a relevant keyword that has high
volume and low competition so another
way of saying it is the volume or ratio
of volume to competition and so
basically what we could do is take
volume divided by competition if i make
that a percentage i can see it's 0.35
percent is the ratio between volume and
competition if i do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
i can see that 111
so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah i'm still going to get some
volume but i have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say you know download pizza
dough recipes so if somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
google's keyword planner tool in the
google ads platform we want to target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the google's keyword planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over and we can
get a sense of any particular trend
going on or seasonality so for example
if i saw large growth in the winter
months and not much volume growth in the
summer months then that might indicate
to me that this keyword is more popular
during the winter time so pay attention
to the graphs that you know the keyword
planner tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny halloween costumes well we know
that for halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
september all the way through october
and then it's going to drop after
october 31st which is halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
google's keyword planner tool to find
the volume we use the all in title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 in google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement's going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples are commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords as
part of your longer tail keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for seo so if you have
chosen your keywords properly then if
you do get ranked for those keywords
then it's going to lead to better
engagement with some conversions and so
when we talk about keywords we also want
to talk about our primary and secondary
keyword so every page should have at
least a primary keyword and then a
second carry keyword to work with so
primary keywords are really defining the
nature of your content the secondary
keywords are relevant to the primary
keyword so why do we choose a primary
and secondary keyword because you may
choose a keyword as a primary keyword
that is relevant to the content but may
not necessarily rank very high or have a
lot of volume that secondary keyword is
also relevant to the primary keyword but
also relevant to content and you may
rank for that secondary keyword so you
always want to go with two keywords
versus just one keyword you want to give
your yourself a chance to rank for at
least two different types of keywords of
relevant nature so for web page there
can be several secondary keywords but
only one primary keyword so your primary
keyword is always going to be relevant
to your content secondary keywords can
be relevant to the keyword but and you
may have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool google's keyword
planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if i go in to
google's keyword planner and type those
keywords in i'm going to choose get
results and now here i could see healthy
diet plan keyword i'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900
and then some of my secondary keywords
healthy diet foods diet plan weight loss
low carb diet you know google will give
me a number of different keywords to
work with so i'm going to look at the
search volume of those as well and so
ideally what i want to do is be able to
then look at the volume and then look at
the competition so healthy diet plan i
go into my keyword analysis here that's
my theme so that's my keyword what's my
volume for healthy diet plan
9900 what's my competition so my
competition is 74
700 and that's going to give me a ratio
of volume to competition of 13 so that's
what my contents about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13
and what i want to do is i want to be
able to put these other secondary
keywords in here as well maybe even go a
little longer tail because i want to be
able to
find to keep at least two keywords i
want to be able to find my primary
keyword that's relevant to my content
and then i want to be able to find my
secondary keyword which is again related
to the primary keyword which is also
related to the content and so i want to
be able to choose two keywords basically
and i want to choose two keywords that
are relevant that have good ratio
between volume and competition so that's
the whole idea again on how to do
keyword research you want to be able to
find your keywords use the tools
available to you and get a sense of what
the volume is what the competition is
look at the ratio between the volume and
competition and then based on the
content choose that primary keyword and
then again based on the keyword you
chose choose some secondary keywords as
well because you want to be found for
not just one keyword but multiple
keywords okay let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account lsi
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or reddit we can use
google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
lsi keywords and lsi stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are lsi or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to google search
for example if i type in healthy diet in
google search all i need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and i could
see searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top google's also giving
me some other suggestions here so
they're saying low-fat diet veganism
gluten-free diet so there's lots of
different suggestions right in google
search bar so all of these are lsi
related keywords so if you're optimizing
a page for a healthy diet then you could
choose low-fat diet as a secondary
keyword you can use gluten-free diet as
a secondary keyword it really depends on
what the content is but you always want
to support your content with as much lsi
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in google search so it's
important because if you have a blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so
google for example uses lsi keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on python and your content you want to
support that with lsi keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for a feature snippet for
example maybe you know healthy diet
recipes if i type that in you can see
here there's a featured snippet so if
i'm talking about recipes that's a key
word i may want to use and if i use that
then google has an opportunity to see
what my content is about and place my
information at the top in this featured
snippet you can also again see what some
of the questions are being asked what
males are good for weight loss what is a
good healthy diet plan all of these can
be keyword phrases that you can use so
the answers are right here in google so
core is a great platform because core is
a platform that people go and ask
questions and a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good is a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
right in core so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're gonna probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if i
just type in healthy dieting what i'm
going to do is i'm going to get some
responses to the topic healthy dieting
so what's the best diet for healthy
living what are the top five tips for a
healthy diet habit so all of these could
be keyword phrases that you could take
away with for your own content and so
the benefit here is you're getting kind
of an idea of what's trending what
people are talking about and if you use
tips for a healthy diet habit for
example and you optimize for that well
again that could turn around and bode
well for you because you could be
featured in google as a featured snippet
at the top here you can also turn around
and use lsi related keywords for healthy
diet habits and you can simply just look
for those lsi keywords right in google
remember at the bottom or at the top if
i scroll down i could see some related
lsi keywords at the bottom so writing
google as well you can see in the google
search bar that google provides some lsi
related keywords to your query so if i
go back here and type in healthy diet
recipes i can see here google suggesting
some other related keywords healthy diet
menu healthy diet for men healthy diet
foods healthy diet for women so these
are all lsi related keywords that you
can use to support your primary keyword
and the content you're writing about so
we've talked about lsi keywords where to
find them so they're found right here
they can be found at the top of google
and they can be found at the bottom you
can also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in google just by doing some
additional research within google itself
or on quora so according to google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if i go back to
google again if i start to type in
recipes i could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in google itself i could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes i can also get
the search volume by going into google's
keyword planner so if i type in healthy
diet i'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition i can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if i'm looking for healthy diet
google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are lsi related keywords that google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the google ads platform
another option for you is wikipedia so
wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we could take a look at keywords from
the wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional pages like the see
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so go to
wikipedia as an example and i type in
healthy diet into wikipedia here i can
get just in the first paragraph alone i
can see
some additional keywords that i might
choose to use like micronutrients i
never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe i can use
that as a keyword an lsi related keyword
to my content so if i scroll down i get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
i can look at categories like dietetics
and diets i can also look at the
references section so i can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
i can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to
my main keyword healthy diet so the
answers are right in here on the
platform they're just all over the page
so wikipedia has an abundance of
information you just need to know where
to look so again with wikipedia you can
look no further than the first paragraph
you look no further than the see also
section the references section category
section there's lots of information
right on the page itself to help you get
ideas for keywords so if you google your
keyword with wikipedia term in the
search query and get relevant keywords
from the title tags on the serp so you
can also do that as well so if i type in
healthy diet wikipedia in search i can
also get some information here as well
so people also search for healthy food
advantages or healthy food habits essay
or information about healthy food all of
these are related to my keyword healthy
diet so again another bit of information
for you to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so reddit it's a
popular community where
people post content discuss a variety of
topics so that's what reddit is so with
the help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so key
wording is the average monthly searches
for a particular keyword so if we type a
word in key reddit and choose keywords
from the auto generated list this tool
will extract the keywords and give us
those relevant terms with search volumes
so if we go to the keyword it and show
an example of that for example healthy
food if i get keywords i can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if i just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
keyword planner tool and google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com type in your keyword click
get keywords and what it's going to do
is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with the
search volume let's talk about keyword
clustering now so the whole idea about
keyword clustering is to
really take advantage of the keywords
that we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme
and that theme of keywords is relevant
to a specific page of a website then we
have a better opportunity to rank so in
other words why do we have to target
just one keyword when we can target many
so keep in mind
you know lsi keywords we want to group a
bunch of keywords together that are
similar for content so for example after
some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is seo how does seo
work intro to seo what are the basics of
seo all of those are related to the core
theme what is seo another cluster of
keywords for example could be seo
techniques seo best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page seo
techniques etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
i.e a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword seo best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword mods if
i go to keyword the keyword explorer
tool in moz and just type in seo best
practices
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is going to
show me what pages are already ranked
for that particular keyword so therefore
i can get it a sense of who is already
ranking for that keyword so here i can
see mozmoz medium.com alexa.com so i can
get a sense of what web pages are ranked
for particular keyword or group of
keywords i want to rank for myself so if
we look at tools for keyword research
look no further than moz that's the mods
of the tool i would just use but you
could also use google's keyword planner
which we used in the example so for
example if i go back to the google ads
keyword planner if you're in google ads
you click on tools you click on
cleveland planner and what keyword
planner does is it provides you for a
particular keyword the average monthly
search volume over the past 12 months it
provides you information on seasonality
so if i hover my mouse over a graph i'm
going to be able to see the volume per
month over the last 12 months what the
keyword planner also does is it provides
me some additional ideas for my
particular keyword and in addition to
that it's going to provide me some sense
of how competitive that keyword is by
telling me whether it's low medium or
high in terms of competition so there's
sem rush there's also other additional
keywords tools out there like word
stream or href or the reddit tool
keyword it and then moz is is another
tool i particularly use so if i go to
moz again here i can just type in a
keyword that i'm interested in it's
going to give me the search volume of
that keyword it's going to give me the
level of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so
it's halfway between difficulty and easy
and then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if i were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what i like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular keyword we're interested in
so here i can look at the top 10 list so
this is moz's keyword explore tool so
that's what this tool is and it's part
of moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal i particularly use moz i
particularly use google's keyword
planner and those are the tools i use
but there are lots of tools out there
let's go with the scenario that you have
a friend named sam and he has a website
where he sells shoes but sam doesn't
understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on google and so typically
ranked number one on google there are
some factors involved and those are
factors that are going to help sam get
his website ranked number one on google
so he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or
you sell products other products like
clothing or food or
your automobile website
your mechanic it doesn't matter whether
you're selling to customers or selling
to other businesses you have to start
with the keyword research and so we're
going to go into really explicit detail
on how to conduct a proper keyword
research and then the second factor
involved is high quality content so in
order to rank high on google search you
need to have high quality content so
we're going to go over
what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on-page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on google then we're
gonna get into the off-site engagement
so when it comes to ranking on google
you need to optimize your website and
you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites and so we're going to
talk about what's involved with offsite
engagement so seo being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bringing 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or 20
percent of our landing pages drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 of our
backlinks past 80 percent of our link
juice that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 of our effort on those
keywords landing pages and backlinks in
return for eighty percent of the results
so without further ado let's get started
with the keyword research let's talk
about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google it all
starts with the keywords as i mentioned
before and so
in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so
the obvious keyword here would be shoes
for kids well every keyword that you
target has search volume associated with
it so that means when we talk about
search volume we're talking about how
many people on average type in that
keyword or related keyword on google.com
or google search and there's always an
average number of searches associated
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're going to target a
keyword we want to have as much volume
as possible however there's always going
to be
competition for those keywords meaning
there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
google for that keyword and so the whole
idea beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with
long-tail keywords meaning the longer
the keyword phrase there's gonna be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we wanna do is
we wanna brainstorm some ideas and find
those relevant keywords so let's look at
an example here so if we go to google
ads so google ads has a tool called
keyword planner and let's just say i
have a a website where i'm selling dried
figs and if i'm selling dried figs i
want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them i want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for
keywords related to bread recipes
because if we can optimize for our
recipes page for bread then that will
attract an audience who wants to make
bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example i'm
going to give here and so if i look at
the keyword planner in google ads if i
just type in bread recipes what google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60
hundred and so in order to do keyword
research what i would recommend is keep
a spreadsheet and so the idea behind the
spreadsheet is to document the volume
and the competition you're getting for
certain keywords so if i go into a
spreadsheet here my theme of keywords is
bread recipes my keyword is bread
recipes and my volume therefore is going
to be 60 500. however if i go back into
google's keyword planner google's
telling me the competition is low so
that's great i want high volume i want
low competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so if we're going to
put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if i go to google and just type in
bread recipes i'm going to be able to
see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all entitled colon
and then our keyword bread recipes we'll
be able to see that there are
998 000 results that's a lot lower than
771 billion so that means that 998
sites or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if i look down and
scroll down here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on google and
so therefore i'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now i could see for the
keyword bread recipes i have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my kei
or keyboard effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if i go back into
google's keyword planner if i typed in
bread recipes you could see that google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say i have another
keyword that i want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if i type
in banana bread recipe in google's
keyword planner now i can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368 000. i can
also see the competition is low so those
are good signs so now i can see 368 000
i'm going to go ahead and put that in my
spreadsheet now i'm going to go into
google i'm going to put in my syntax all
in title i'm going to put in banana
bread recipe i'm going to hit enter and
now i can see i have
233 000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if i
look at the title tags i can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
google search results so that tells me i
have 233 000 results that i have to jump
over in order to rank number one on
google so i'm going to put 233 000 in my
spreadsheet now i can see my kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157 158
and so to me that's a lot better number
to work with or in other words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant and it has a higher ratio of
volume to competition so therefore
banana bread recipe is going to be a
better keyword to optimize for in order
to rank number one on google so that's
the whole idea behind keyword research
you want to brainstorm ideas there are
plenty of tools out there so the tool i
recommend is google ads keyword planner
google is going to give you how much
search volume they're going to tell you
the competition but then you're going to
go into google search you're going to
use the syntax all in title to get a
more accurate read on the actual
competitive number and so to find out
how keywords that your competitors are
ranking for you can use those keyword
tools that i mentioned another tool that
i use is miles so moz if you go to
moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword for
example bread recipes it's going to be
able to tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing i would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
reading and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
can stay up to date on industry news to
get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on one keyword to rank for we want
multiple keywords to try and rank for so
the primary key work and to find the
nature of our business the secondary
keyword could be just highly relevant to
our keyword at the end of the day we
want to choose multiple keywords to try
and rank on google for that page so for
example we have a blog and we're using
ice cream recipes and we're blogging
about ice cream recipes we can have a
primary keyword that is about ice cream
recipes or homemade ice cream recipes
we're going to always want to find out
what the volume and the competition is
our secondary keyword could be built
around other similar keywords like
low-fat ice cream recipes or fat-free
ice cream recipes or low-fat homemade
ice cream recipes those are
complementary key words just like our
bread recipes and banana bread recipe so
one thing we want to do when we do
keyword research is we want to be able
to target one keyword per content when
you can target many we want to be able
to target multiple keywords not
necessarily target one keyword and so we
want to be able to cluster keywords see
we don't want to target just one we want
to target multiple keywords per page and
when we talk about clustering if we go
back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords into a content
theme so why target only one keyword per
content when we can target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to target just one
keyword we want to target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily gonna get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and when you don't get
good engagement if people don't stay on
the site to engage in the content and
they just leave the website after
landing on the page causing a bounce
then
the content is just going to continue to
fall down the rankings and we want to
prevent that we want to move up the
rankings we want to be number one on
google we don't necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summer time and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do i make you
know a bread or how do i make a specific
type of bread or how do i make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talked about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keywords and trends and whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question that's the whole
idea behind content content is not just
to fill a page it's to really fulfill
users requirements that's when you get
good engagement so if somebody's typing
in something on google and they're
looking for an answer your content
should answer that question but we also
want to make the content readable so in
other words you know write for your
audience don't impress anybody with very
high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey i've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to remember when
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hat techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to write an article
about how to write good engaging content
we don't necessarily have to write all
that out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the point of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
i like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you could
save them on really any social platform
so infographics tend to tell a better
story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person is engaged so
we're going to rank that favorably so if
you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again those best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords in your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like easy perfect yeast bread or easy
crusty french bread or something that's
going to be engaging you know the best
bread recipes or how to make the best
homemade bread you know something that's
going to draw somebody's attention to
the title of that blog post so we want
to include lsi keywords so what i mean
by lsi keywords in your content we mean
you know long tail keywords make it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content always stays
relevant to the audience okay shorten
your sentences and paragraphs so don't
write long paragraphs remember we want
to break this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to
pen the image with text so that way if
the image doesn't load then at least the
alt text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action then that's going to keep
somebody engaged and have them act on
your content so these are steps to
creating high quality content and so
let's look at an example here and this
is a three month old post on buzzfeed
and it's 21 pictures that restore your
faith in humanity so it has a lot of
likes a lot of tweaks and that means
it's engaged people are engaged when
reading that and so if we go and look at
it as an example we could see it on a
buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we can see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's that don'ts
obviously don't lift content we don't
want to lift content from another
website so that's plagiarism so we want
to have our own unique content we also
don't want to take images from other
websites and so if you do happen to find
an image that works for your post and
it's on somebody else's website ideally
that's not a good situation but if you
do happen to do that then always give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on google
search so
let's just do an overview of what we're
talking about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on-page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
urls so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank high on google search we
also want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
google search they include website
architecture having a secure website
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered
meta tags so both play an important role
in ranking high on google so we want to
be able to write unique title and
descriptions for each page on our
website when i say unique that means a
title in the meta description need to be
different for every page on the website
and so if you're not quite sure what a
title tag and a meta description tag is
if you go to search and just type in any
particular search query the title tag is
what's going to show up here and bold
and then the description is going to
show up below it below the url and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's gonna happen is
the
meta description tag or the title tag
will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we can see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and into this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond
based on their need and so we definitely
want to avoid keyword repetition but we
want to be able to use that keyword in
the title tag because if you remember
from the earlier segment when we did the
all in title syntax to find out exactly
how many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example
if you just put in a title tag that says
learn digital marketing well that may
work but if you put a number in there
like five easy ways to learn digital
marketing that might get somebody to
click on your link and go to your
website so having questions in your meta
tags can also increase your
click-through rate for example if you
just put learn the importance of first
page rankings not too bad but again
generic but if you put it into the
formal question how to rank number one
on google it's more action oriented it's
gonna get somebody to resonate with the
question that they have and that may be
their query how to rank number one on
google and so these techniques will
help you get higher click-through rates
and so according to backlinko
title tag with a keyword can improve
site ranking so remember we want to
include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have 65 characters
we want to include that keyword but we
want to avoid stuffing the keyword in
there we want to again make the title
tag action oriented maybe with the
number maybe as a question with the
keyword in there once naturally not easy
to do
but that's the beauty of seo if you can
follow these best practices and write a
good title tag then the chances of you
improving in your search results are
going to be greater so having only one
h1 tag in your post is going to be good
so remember when somebody clicks on a
link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1 tech because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags h tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
california fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content we'll look no
further than including a video into our
content
so not only will this video help keep
the engagement high but it breaks up the
monotony of the page and it's from a
third party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there h2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of h1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden texts we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your h1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h1 tags so
if we go back to our page example a
short sweet tag here california fake
banana bread it's relevant to the
content it's short sweet and breaks up
the monotony of the content and more
importantly and again any content you
have on the page should always answer
the user's intent remember people are
using search to answer questions find
information our content should be able
to answer that for them so according to
john muller senior webmaster trends
analyst at google header tags would
definitely help google for rankings in
the search results so we want to use
header tags so when it comes to urls we
want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this url
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's a best practice remember
canonical urls a canonical url signals
to google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use a canonical tag to signal to
google this is the original content
please index this content and that
doesn't hurt to use a favicon url
meaning a small icon
it helps to break up the monotony and
help your url stand out we can add
targeted keywords in the url so again
looking at the url here i can see we're
using targeted keyword as part of the
url structure vegan banana bread and
notice the h1 tag is fake banana bread
so it's all consistent and it flows
naturally urls that are no longer
existing then we want to be able to set
up a redirect for those urls meaning a
301 redirect is a server response for
google that says hey google this page is
no longer available but we permanently
redirected it to this page which is now
available so that's what a 301 redirect
does it helps signal to google and all
the other search engines that if the
page is no longer there that's fine
you're just going to go to this page
this is the page that's permanently
there now and another thing we want to
do here is if you have mobile urls you
want to include those in the sitemap and
we're going to hit on that in just a
minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that url and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the urls the urls are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lower case from the url
readable urls again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the url
is then google is going to understand
what the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on google search so according
to backlink 2 urls that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
children's shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
nike puma adidas on the women's side it
could be nike puma adidas on the child
side it could be nike puma adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy do we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has nike
puma adidas the women should have nike
puma adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and css or html meaning
we want to be able to use something that
google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in html and that's
what google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going and we don't
want to have unnatural inbound things
you always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here i can
see as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well this has an internal
link to another page on our site and
this happens to link to a page where
somebody can buy the ingredients so it's
a natural internal link so john doherty
of credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the credo website is architecture
so for example in credo john dougherty
has increased the organic sessions by 74
and pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised by changing the
site architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure
https means it has a secure license
meaning the site is secure so google
likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be http so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling ssl certificates
and that means when you enable an ssl
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
https so google prefers sites that are
secure versus non-secure so if you use
hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look into
buying an ssl certificate getting your
sites flipped over to https because
what's going to happen is your url
structure is going to change when your
url structure changes google's going to
recognize that because they're going to
index your site and when they index your
site they're going to see those secure
urls and that's going to work favorably
in your favor and help you rank higher
on google search so websites using
secure
or https
have a higher chance of ranking higher
so https is a ranking signal because
google indexes those pages so let's also
talk about sitemaps so sitemap is one of
the most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
urls into one file so we're basically
going to
prioritize all our web pages in a
sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if i
type in
sitemap.xml i'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and i
can also prioritize them i can also
alert google as to how often they change
and every page is going to have a date
stamp associated with it so google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google is going to see that site
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
content's updated frequently we want to
let google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a sitemap we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
urls in the sitemaps so we want to be
able to add all our original urls in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
dynamic urls sitemaps for larger
websites and what i mean by dynamic urls
that means that if i look at this
sitemap and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the site map as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more urls when the
sitemap grows with more urls then that
means then google is going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
dynamic site maps is we want to be able
to capture all the urls just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our site maps and so i would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in xml
sitemaps
into google search here i could see xml
sitemaps generator and i can be able if
i have a small website just create a
free and simple
sitemap on my own when xml sitemaps
creates it or your platform creates a
dynamic sitemap either way the sitemap's
going to sit in the root directory and
then what we want to do in turn is let
google know where that site map is so in
search console we want to be able to
submit the sitemap so you're going to
add the sitemap you're going to let
google know where it is it should be in
the root directory and it should be
called
sitemap.xml and when you do that google
is going to be able to take those urls
and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 urls google index 521 so
one thing about urls here is when we
create a sitemap we're putting all your
urls in there we do not add no index
urls in your sitemap and what that means
is that any url we don't want google to
index we're just going to exclude from
the sitemap okay so we want google to
take all the urls we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sitemaps for seo can increase
your website's visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your urls that
you want index you're telling google how
often they're modified you're telling
google which ones are important and
you're submitting that to google and so
google is going to be able to take all
those urls quicker index them quicker
and when they're indexed quicker you can
get ranked quicker and when you get
ranked quicker you can get traffic
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
site maps so let's turn our attention to
page speed now so when the last factors
for our website besides architecture
making it secure and adding sitemaps is
want to take a look at how quick our
pages load here are some tips in order
to optimize page speed because ideally
the quicker a page loads the more
engaged the user is going to be if it
takes a longer time for the page to load
all the elements of that page then
what's going to happen is the user is
going to get impatient maybe leave the
website all together or go to another
page and so we want to be able to
optimize images so any image that's of
large size in terms of megabytes we want
to be able to optimize that to compress
the image so that's one way to speed up
page speed we want to use a simple
website design you know html with css or
cascading style sheets just a simple
design with simple hierarchy and website
navigation structure so nothing fancy
nothing complex just a simple website
design with optimized images we want to
leverage browser caching and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text etc and so we want
the server to respond as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in google analytics so if i
go to google analytics and i go under
behavior and i go under site speed and i
go to overview i'm going to be able to
see what my average load time is for my
site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under four seconds anything
four seconds or higher and it's likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions and google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then google's
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potential
page loads slow and if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see the home page of the example is
loaded on average of seven seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if i click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called page
speed insights and basically what it's
then going to do after it's done running
is it's going to tell me all the ways in
which i can optimize my pages not only
for
desktop but also for mobile so here i
can see for desktop or for mobile i can
look at some ways in which i can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirect so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today walmart as an example
experienced declining conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increase conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page load is low time will make a world
of difference in terms of engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
off-site engagement so previously we
talked about on-page elements and
website factors that affect our rankings
for search results but we also need to
turn our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and on to
other websites so that's off site
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
so
we did everything we possibly could we
updated the meta tags the title tag the
meta description we added h1 tags we
made sure the site architecture was
sound we submitted a site map we we made
sure the page load was good and fast so
we did all the things we're supposed to
do on our web page but we're still not
ranking well what do we need to do well
we need to turn our attention away from
our website into other websites we call
this off site or off page seo and we
need to basically generate links from
high quality sites back to our site so
if we've done everything we can on our
own website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant
other websites that are of quality
other websites that have high domain
authority
then we're going to see an increase in
rankings so it's just a matter of
getting quality links from quality
websites that are relevant that's what's
going to move the needle on search after
we've taken care of all the on-page
elements so more backlinks from high
domain authority results in higher
rankings seo is a combination between
what we do on our website meaning
optimizing the page and making sure our
website has good site architecture and
follows the best practices in terms of
site maps and page load then we need to
turn our attention to the backlinking to
improve our domain authority so
according to backlinko analysis offsite
engagement is one of the most important
elements for ranking number one in
google so you can't just focus your
attention on updating the title tag and
making sure the pages load fast you have
to turn your attention as well to
getting back links from high quality
sites that's off-site engagement and so
gaining links back links from multiple
danes is vital it's vital because they
bring referring traffic to your site
they bring credibility to your site but
more importantly google is going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website and if these
sites that have backlinks or links
pointing to your site and if they're of
high quality then we call that passing
link choose so it's going to bring
quality to you in terms of organic
search so if we look at an example if i
do a search for banana bread recipe
there are 241
billion results for banana bread recipe
why did this particular page from simply
recipes rank number one well we can turn
our attention to moz and moz has a
report called link explorer and so moz
link explorer report helps us identify
our own page authority our own domain
authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if i put
that particular url into link explorer
and notice the url
here is short even though it uses an
underscore when it shows a hyphen it's
still ranked number one and why because
off page elements help this page rank
number one why their page authority out
of 100 is 58 their domain authority out
of 100 is 82. and what does that mean
well that means that they have a lot of
good links from other domains of high
quality they have 824 linking domains to
this one domain they have 3 600 inbound
links and they're ranking for a lot of
different keywords so if we scroll down
we're going to be able to see
kind of a break out the quality of
websites that are linking to them so
they have 19 domains with a domain
authority of 91 to 100 linking to them
they have 15 domains between the range
of 81 and 90. so what does that tell me
between 15 and 19 that's 34 particular
domains that are very high quality
linking to it and so we could see the
breakout of the linking domains we could
see the top file links to the site and
we could see the page authority so the
link explorer report gives us an
overview of what pages are linking to
ours and it also gives us an idea of
what our own page authority and domain
authority are because domain authority
and page authority both need to be high
in order for us to rank on google search
in order for it to get high we need
links from high quality sites so that's
the whole idea behind off-site
engagement so some of the offside
engagements are influencer marketing
meaning is there somebody out there on
social who has a huge following but not
only do they have a huge following but
are they relevant to our product for
example usain bolt who's a famous
sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling nike shoes maybe usain
bolt can
reference us on twitter or facebook
that's influencer marketing getting
people to influencing people to buy our
product we can engage with audiences on
multiple social media platforms like
facebook and twitter meaning if we're
running a promotion on those running
shoes then we can promote that on
facebook okay we can promote that on
twitter we can also bookmark our webpage
on popular bookmarking sites like
stumbleupon we can also put our content
on discussion forums like reddit we can
join high pr quality
q a sites excuse me and post answers to
questions related to our business like
cora.com so we can engage in sharing our
content and answering questions so
there's lots of ways to get links to
your website if you have a blog post as
an example you can
make sure that
maybe that content is shared on a
similar blog post so if you have an ice
cream recipe
blog post well maybe you can look at a
dessert blog post and share your content
on that particular blog post and have a
backlink pointing from that blog post to
yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time of sharing it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
authority so not only do they help
domain authority but
they improve the search rankings so in
google's eyes the higher your domain
authority higher the page authority in
google's eyes that means your page is
important it's credible and we're going
to prove it in the search engine
rankings it increases brand visibility
if we have our content on a highly
engageable website a highly popular
website or a blog it's not it's going to
lift our brand visibility if we have
usain bolt who's very famous sprinter do
some influence in marketing for us then
that's going to increase our brand
visibility so anytime we can associate
with something that has some influence
or some clout or high domain authority
then it's only going to increase our
brand awareness and visibility so again
it's going to increase our domain
authority because of the association of
passing link juice from one domain to
another it's going to then as a result
increase referral traffic because if
we're on a high quality website that
gets a lot of traffic then the chances
of some of that traffic go on our site
is going to be great and again it
improves the credibility and trust of
our website and that's what we want we
want google to trust us and a way to
build trust is by associating our
website with other websites of high
equal or higher quality so when we talk
about offsite engagement we want to do
some guest posts on relevant websites so
if you have that ice cream blog
go to another blog like the dessert blog
and do a guest post so not only that
will that improve your brand awareness
but it'll generate a backlink and maybe
drive some referral traffic you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions like core.com or reddit get
your content out there start a
discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your
your site on a directory like yelp for
example or yahoo directory you could
prefer testimonial link building meaning
if you serve products or offer up a
service well somebody could provide a
testimony on their website or you could
just earn backlinks from relevant
authoritative web pages like we
mentioned quora or wikipedia there's
plenty out there so the idea is to
associate yourself with high quality
websites but do it naturally you don't
want to force anything so if you're
selling a specific service or you're
selling a specific product look for like
mining services or products that
complement what you do and that'll
create the natural environment natural
ecosystem that will eventually give you
the benefits that you need to rank
higher in the search results pages so we
don't want to purchase any links we
don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on
low-quality websites or directories it's
all about quality not quantity with
offsite engagement so having offsite
engagement complements what you do on
your website for onsite together both of
those efforts will get you higher search
engine results so let's start out with
why gtm so let's just say you're sam
and you have your own e-commerce website
and you want to understand how people
are interacting with your website well
sam today's world of websites contain a
lot of interactivity everything from
videos to pdf downloads to commenting to
form submissions uh to all sorts of chat
functionality interactivity going on
throughout the website so there's just a
lot that you need to track outside of
just page views and so
really what gtm does is they help you
track all these things i just mentioned
everything from somebody clicking on the
play button of a pdf to somebody
clicking on the submit button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function so that's what gtm is so
why gtm because it helps us track all
that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to really place a
piece of java code which is just script
and the script that's added to a web
page to collect information so that's
really what a tag is it's just some
script that gets put on a web page in
order for you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third-party tools okay so that's
what gtm does it it basically allows you
to take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in gtm
so
if you want to for example collect how
many people you know enter
a
chat functionality and start chatting
well you're gonna take that script and
you're gonna put it in gtm and gtm will
then allow you to start tracking that
information so that's really what gtm is
it just allows you to put tags into a
container or think of it as a toy box
you have all these toys and you want to
track well you can put all those those
toys or tags in a toy box or container
and we're going to talk a little bit
more about that but before we get into
gtm let's just say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your webpage and you want to update
the tag well your developer considering
it's probably a small
update to your website he's probably
gonna not um hesitate and is gonna go
ahead and turn around and do it normally
and so normally what happens is the
developer is gonna go to the website and
update the tag well what if you have a
few things that you want to track all
those things i mentioned before from
downloads to clicks to
you know somebody checking out to
watching a video well your master your
web developer is going to go well hold
on a second now all these requests are
going to take time i need to put them
into the work queue so to speak well
what happens is when they go into work
queue usually it's going to take some
time and
in some cases you as a marketer need to
launch a campaign and you want to get
that tracking uh added to the website in
time for the campaign launch so you want
to go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer's
like well i need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
is my point and so that's where gtm
comes in because there is a solution
update your tags faster and that's
google tag manager so when we say gtm
that's what gtm stands for google tag
manager it's a place for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember are
just snippets of code that allow you to
track things on your website
interactively interactive activity and
basically when you have gtm you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so
that's what gtm is all about so why gtm
because we just identified two benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website and two
you can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and so that's the benefit of
gtm so the benefit you get those tags
updated very quickly via google tag
manager okay so that's what tag manager
is so what we're going to talk about
today is specifically what tag manager
is and what it does we're going to list
some of the benefits of tag manager
we're going to show you how it works and
then we're going to show you how to get
started with tag manager tag manager if
you're not familiar with working with
webmasters and dealing with javascript
and tags and all this jargon is just new
to you today okay well don't fret sit
back we're going to take it slow this is
an introduction into google tag manager
again let's start out with what is tag
manager so we've already introduced it
to some degree because we already
introduced is a tool where you can put
all your tags into a toolbox toy box or
container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if i'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can i
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a google tool
hence the name google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
is deploy and track tags on your website
by passing your webmaster so that's tag
manager and so examples of tags that can
be deployed vehicle tag manager are
numerous these are just some examples
like google analytics facebook pixel
tracking or google ads there's no limit
into the number of tags you can track in
tag manager there is no limit you can
add any number of tracking tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
javascript codes quicker so remember
these javascript codes or snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
page view or somebody clicking on a play
button or tracking somebody who converts
or even just goes to your website so the
biggest benefit is you can take that
snippet of code let's just say facebook
let's just say you're doing facebook
marketing and you want to put that
facebook pixel on your website so that
you could track people who come from
facebook and convert well you don't need
to put that facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager
really quickly and the other benefit
here is all tags are managed in one
place and that's that to me is really a
good benefit because when you start
adding tags on your website and you have
some tags in tag manager it just gets
very confusing so ideally all the
tracking code you have on your website
needs to be in tag manager think about
that all the tracking so if you're doing
bing or you're doing facebook or you're
doing twitter or you're doing linkedin
and you're doing google you're doing all
this type of marketing on all these
different platforms you're going to have
tracking code for all these different
platforms and instead of putting on that
code on your website return gonna slow
down the slow time of your web page and
website you want to put them all in tag
manager so they can be organized and you
know exactly what you're trying to track
and the other great benefit of tag
manager is there's a versioning control
so let's just say you have added tags to
your website via gtm for the last six
months well and let's just say you add
another tag yesterday if you added that
tag yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version it's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a piece of
mind so to speak just because you've had
code to your site there's no guarantee
it's going to work and so you can always
control what version you're dealing with
in tag manager and we'll talk a little
bit more about that so the biggest
benefit here to me with tag manager is
you have event tracking and so we talked
about some of the things you could track
on your website from videos from play
buttons to somebody clicking on the stop
on the video or pausing it all the way
to somebody again chatting or let's just
say somebody clicking on that purchase
button on your website okay and you want
to track all these different things
these different interactivities and
buttons well event tracking is what
you're going to use to track all those
buttons and to me this is the biggest
benefit of tag manager and i'll show you
some examples as we go along and if we
didn't mention it already i'll mention
it again it is free tag manager is free
there's no limit so once you have tag
manager going you can add as many
tracking codes as you want there's no
limit on the number of tracking codes
you can add to tag manager okay so it's
free and you can use it to its fullest
advantage okay so it's also high
security meaning that it has different
levels of permissions okay so you can
have uh somebody just go in and look at
the different tags and tracking codes
you have in gtm or you can have somebody
who is very familiar with tag manager
and go in and add the tracking code to
tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag manager work because you're
like rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and javascript and
and versioning and publishing and all
this other stuff well i know i'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here okay so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactivity whether that
be a video whether that be a blog
whether it be a form submission you have
a website with some interactivity and
let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe google or facebook
and you want to drive traffic to your
website fair enough you're joining the
millions of other websites that are out
there that have interactivity that also
drive traffic to the website so income's
google tag manager and so tag manager is
important because again we know we want
to track people coming from that
facebook campaign or that google
campaign interacting with our site so if
you are running facebook and you are
running google analytics well guess what
you want to put that tracking code in
tag manager so google analytics being a
google product works very nicely with
tag manager facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if i add
facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say i had google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
manager is controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
i am i'm in tag manager i just went to
tag manager.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so here if i look at all
the different tracking code i have on my
website through tag manager let's just
take a look at google analytics so if
you're going to use tag manager you
might as well put the google analytics
code in here so here i can see i have
google analytics as a tag in tag manager
now for facebook if i'm running a
facebook campaign well i can take that
pixel tracking and put it in gtm as well
and here i can see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to gtm i just
basically took what facebook gave me and
put it into google tag manager so you
can see i can add facebook and google
analytics and again i can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform i can add to google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so i just showed you an example of how
you could take facebook and google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember i mentioned toy box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if i take
my facebook tracking code and put it
into a container i need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager i'm going to have an account
and if i have an account i'm going to
have a container so here i'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's google analytics that's
easy here i could see i have google
analytics added so if i click on google
analytics here's my tag and if i take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
google analytics is a google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy i can just choose
google analytics then i'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so i need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
google analytics tracking code so in
this case i'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if i get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
google analytics is going to fire so
that's really what it comes down to is i
have a tag and i need to tell tag
manager when to trigger that tag that's
really what the structure of tag manager
is it's tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if i go back
here you can see facebook well here's my
facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell gtm when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the javascript code
that you get from say facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so
variables are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
url or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples i just
gave you are there to get your tag and
trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if i
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side i can see variables so
remember i have built in and user
defined so built in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case i need to get my trigger to work
with my tag i can use a variable so
those are built in and then i have user
defined so these are what i define these
are what i created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that javascript code okay in the
case of facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
i click on adwords remarketing again
it's a google product so i don't really
need to even deal with code i'm just
going to select google adwords
remarketing okay so you can see gtm
integrates nicely with some of the other
google products but let's just say you
have a facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling gtm when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell gtm when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of javascript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it and even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to facebook you
want to maybe track that you're going to
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell gtm when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the url
equals facebook.com or some other
condition so the tag cannot be created
until the creation of the corresponding
trigger so tags and triggers go together
you can't just create a tag and not have
a trigger otherwise your tag will never
fire and then the variable is there
again it stores the information when
defining a trigger or transferring data
to tag so a variable has a variety of
data okay so you pick and choose the
variable you want to use
with that trigger okay so you're making
sure that by defining a variable you're
making sure that you're telling gtm how
that trigger should be fired so let's
take a look at another example here of
how all three play together if i'm in
this account i'm in this container if i
look down here i can see google optimize
that's another google product so
what i'm doing here is i just chose
google optimize as my tag it's already
integrated so what does that mean i
don't even need to deal with any code
i'm just going to select optimize well
we have the tag google optimize but we
need to tell gtm how to fire that and so
here we're going to tell gtm to fire it
on all pages so that's basically a very
simple example because we're firing it
on all pages so if i want to look at
something specific again facebook here's
my tag here's my code what's my trigger
well my trigger is it's going to fire on
specific pages how do i know that well
if i look at the trigger here i could
see the trigger is a page view but i'm
telling it to fire on this particular
hostname so the tag and trigger go hand
in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager and you're going to create your
account and then when you create your
account what's going to happen is you're
going to
set up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
ios or maybe android or you can even set
it up for amp except an accelerated
mobile page so most people by default
are probably going to set up tag manager
for their website and so when you do
that when you actually select website
what's going to happen is you're going
to get some google tag manager code in
return and so the whole idea here is
you're going to do a swap what you're
doing is basically you're saying okay
google i'm going to take this google tag
manager code and i'm going to put it on
my website i'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in gtm
okay it's gonna go into the container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are going to work so that's
the idea behind the container and then
one thing i wanted to mention on the
account is it's a google account so when
you create your account then make sure
it's the same account you use with say
google analytics or some other google
product that's a good best practice is
always use the same email address when
you set up your account so that it
integrates nicely across all the
different platforms meaning you can go
from say google analytics right to
google tag manager in one browser
without having to log out or log in okay
so when you create the account you're
going to create your container if you
choose web then you're going to be asked
to place code on your website and when
you place that code on your website then
you are free to start using tag manager
and that means you're free to start
adding tags okay so if you want to know
more information about installing google
tag manager then what i would recommend
is visit the quick start guide website
of gtm so again if you're curious as to
where that code is located in google tag
manager well when you create an account
and you create a container that
container is going to have a specific id
so if i click on that specific id here's
where i can get my code okay so again
when i'm logged in to tag manager i'm
gonna click on workspace but in the top
navigation i'm gonna see my unique gtm
id if i click on that that's where my
code is going to be located and so again
your code needs to go in the header and
there's another script that needs to go
in the body and if you're not sure how
to add the code to your website well you
can always click on the quick start
guide here okay and that'll take you to
a quick start guide page a reference
page related to google tag manager so
let's talk about creating a tag so once
you get tag manager installed i'm sure
you're excited to get going and create
that first tag so let's talk about how
to create a tag in tag manager so when
you're in tag manager all you need to do
is basically you're looking at all your
tags if you click on tag in the left
side navigation you'll see all your tags
and there's a new button there so you
just click new and so basically what
you're going to do is you're going to
create your first tag and so what i
would recommend once you get tag manager
installed on your website i would
recommend setting the first tag up as
google analytics so that will get you
going with tracking page views on your
website when some when somebody visits
your website okay so ideally that's what
you want to do you want to get google
analytics as your first tag and tag
manager so what i'm going to do is
because analytics is a google product
it's already integrated nicely with tag
manager so i'm just going to click on
google analytics it's going to be a page
for you that's what i'm tracking and now
i have to set up a variable and so
what it's going to do it's going to ask
me to set select a variable and so what
you're going to do is you're going to
select new variable and what you're
going to do is you're actually going to
go and add your tracking id here that's
going to be your variable so where do i
get my tracking id and analytics well if
i'm in analytics i'm going to go to
admin and then under property settings
i'm going to see my tracking id and all
you need to do then is go to tag manager
and paste copy first you got to copy
over that tracking id then you're going
to go to tag manager and paste it and
then that's going to create a variable
for you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so i've already created
it and
basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
i have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if i get a visitor to any
page on my website then i want you to
fire google analytics
so that's basically in summary how to
set up your first tag and my
recommendation is your first tag should
be google analytics and when you set up
analytics you're going to have to set up
a variable for the tracking id and so
you get the tracking id again from admin
property settings copy and paste that
tracking id over save it you have your
variable that variable is going to be
included in with the tag then your
trigger is going to be all pages and
there you go you have your first tag you
have your first variable you have your
first trigger so that's basically what
you want to do and once you've added
that tag once you've added that trigger
then the only thing you need to do now
is basically publish the tag and so
anytime you save a tag you're going to
go ahead and submit it so that way it
gets published so again what you're
going to do is let's take a step back
here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking id so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking id and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying hey
i want this tag to go live now this tag
and trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually added tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for google
tag assistant you're gonna see here that
it's basically just an extension that
works in chrome and unfortunately it
only works in chrome browser it doesn't
work in any other browser so go ahead
and install that extension into chrome
and when you do that you're gonna see
this nice icon here in your browser and
now if you go to any website and i click
on google tag assistant and i click on
enable okay so basically i'm loading
google tag assistant and now once i
refresh the page i can see that this
particular site has google tag manager
installed and not only does it have tag
manager installed i can see that it's
also has google analytics running i have
also google optimize running and i have
google ads remarketing tag running in
tag manager so that's what tag assistant
does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now i'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a look at what
that looks like so if i go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's gonna happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can i see in preview mode i
could see that i have gtm firing but i
also have some other tags found on this
page remarketing i have google analytics
i google optimize i have some other tags
firing as well and so the preview mode
shows me what tags are firing on any
given page and i can also see what tags
did not fire okay so here i have a
number of tags already in gtm but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say i clicked on the donate
now button i'm still in preview mode so
i'm going to be able to see what tags
fired now i could see
i have a couple of tags that have fired
on this particular page and then i can
see what tags did not fire on this page
okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode before you even submit
a tag and trigger to see if it fires and
that's the great benefit of tag manager
so if you're not sure if something's
going to fire or not then you can always
go into preview mode and if you are sure
it's gonna fire then you can go ahead
and submit it so you can leave preview
mode and just go ahead and submit that
particular tag and trigger so here i'm
gonna leave preview mode and now once
i'm done and i'm sure the tag is gonna
fire and go ahead and submit all my
changes that i've worked on in terms of
setting up tags and triggers so that's
really gtm in a nutshell so i have my
tags okay my tags are just snippets of
code that i'm going to put in whether
that be facebook or vet tracking or any
other google product like optimize or
page view then i have my triggers my
triggers are there to tell gtm when to
fire that tag and the variables are
there to help those tags and triggers
work together so remember that
particular variable we set up for google
analytics okay so here it is right here
because we want to tell gtm what
property to specifically fire in google
analytics so that's why we set up that
variable but there are all sorts of
variables google tag manager has
built-in or variables already created
for you or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again i can't stress
that there's an unlimited number of tags
you can add to tag manager there's no
limit so you got everything from
anything from google to non-google to
event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
i want to go back to an older version i
can simply do that so here you can see
i'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and i can't stress that
you know tag manager is there to help
you track interactivity on the site
because if you have a site that's
interactive that has a video that has a
download button let's just say
you know you have all sorts of
newsletter sign ups facebook youtube
buttons on your website just like this
website does and you want to be able to
track how many people click on that
particular button well you're going to
need tag manager and when you have tag
manager you're going to be able to track
all of these button clicks and
interactivity on your website thanks rob
with that we've reached the end of this
video stay tuned for part two where
we'll be covering topics like google ads
google display network google analytics
facebook and youtube ads and much more
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn